Wow...
Tasting, tasting...
My voice is sharp before any...
Yes, get excited!
Testing...
Microphone test...
Ah ah, microphone, okay.
Audio is a freaking thing.
Oh yeah, it's streaming time.
Are you guys there?
Testing...
Oh, YouTube gave me acknowledgement I'm live.
Hello...
Good morning!
Good evening!
Good afternoon!
How are my little wiflings?
Very very sweet!
No one is going to get that reference.
Good morning!
How are you?
I'm currently glowing because of the events that occurred last night.
After a stream that should not be named.
You guys had some very interesting marshmallows for me when I woke up.
I do have some good tiny VLR news.
AC and Emmys second batch of emotes have been accepted and paid for.
So do hold your breath for them.
The girls picked what emotes they want and they were very charming.
I think they're adorable.
Up next is ordering Sheevee and Mersi's emotes.
I'm having to do it in batches.
The wait time is 30 days.
But as soon as they've been accepted it's just something in the background that I don't have to think about.
Which is fantastic.
I am submitting my emotes last because I know how ever so patient my beautiful wiflings can be.
So I do appreciate your patience until the new emotes do show up.
We are getting there.
We will soon be there.
I will do that later.
My voice is short unfortunately but hopefully the microphone is covering up the majority of how badly short it is.
And I think we're just going for it.
We will wait as long as it takes.
I think ours are going to show up in like 40 days which is quite a lot.
Considering how much mome streams.
I'll be a whole second but I mean I see their emotes have been submitted and I get to see the adorable drafts.
The mot artist has already worked on them before so it might be a faster process.
Question mark.
I don't know.
I submitted to them the ref sheet.
They're all the emotes and what they want here.
Time to diminish.
No we are going to save.
I have a cup of tea.
I've got a hot war ball.
I may or may not have slapped myself a little too hard but I hope.
That phantom we saw earlier.
He said he had an ancient king of Hyrule.
What else do we know?
The element was nowhere to be seen in the wind runes.
I guess we'll just have to go to the place marked on our map.
But first you should infuse your sword with that element.
Right okay.
We have just picked up the third element.
The element of water.
Oh the light.
The skulls open up.
Hello.
No.
That's right.
I knew this was here for a child.
Yeah someone was so adorable in message and they were like mome.
I'm like yeah.
They were like mommy.
What hole did you use?
My refund.
Bless you.
Hope.
Brained where are you?
Did my language not unfair?
Where are we going?
I was going to say swimming pool.
Hi Sony what's the transformers last night?
Is this one I've ever had watching a movie?
Oh I'm so glad.
I actually love doing watch-alongs.
Especially like on stuff I've never seen before.
Fucking hell it's going to take forever.
I'm lucky I picked up a bomb sack honestly.
I can't read the site from Marshmallow.
I have no clue.
If you use firefox there should be a little extension for translation.
Unfortunately I don't use anything else but firefox.
But I think you can all translate if you try hard enough.
Wait I can't...
I can't do anything can I?
I can only get this.
Well oh well we got 100 for that.
Oh we can go buy an upgrade on something.
Yeah we cannot do anything.
There's something to the bomb we can do unfortunately.
I'm not sure what that is.
We're currently just exploring because we've got access to the...
Oh no they're having to do a time crunch.
Chomp chomp.
I'm always the last to finish eating.
Oh can't really...
How about you do you...
No no trading.
Oops.
We're dying.
We are very...
We are getting very close to finishing the game.
As far as I'm aware.
I don't have that yet grrr.
Alright we can come back another time.
Oh there's a big guy up there.
Let's go get him.
Shonen's always a fed gopher.
Let's just let them have people eat slow.
You made it here really quickly.
You're filled with surprises aren't you?
It took me like one third of the game.
But sure if you mean getting here quickly.
There you go.
That's so cute.
That looks like...
No one wants to trade Kinstone pieces either.
And here my food I've got stuff to do.
Bruv honestly.
Hello thanks everyone for joining.
I am not going to even pretend I know what's going on with the schedules.
Some people will be online.
Some people will be offline.
That's it. That's all I know.
Don't ask me anymore because I don't know.
What do you say?
You've played this before.
I have. This is a lovely childhood game of mine.
Oh we can give these girls houses.
Who do we think is the best here?
Do we do the green bunches?
Come on green bunches.
Yeah give us green bunches.
No there's something really annoying about this little side quest we're about to do okay?
There will always be one girl that doesn't have a house because they didn't call to end.
It's annoying.
Shira Fanta Fusion Ward.
Well I've just had the best idea.
I can rent out my house for some extra cash.
No not long lords simulator.
We can't escape.
You've made a perfect match.
Singing in forever. What a bother.
It's so nice to be here at last.
We need to find a place to quiet and down.
It's so nice to be here at last in such a big townhouse.
Are these maybe they're a reference to another Zelda game?
So now he can rent out but we need to find someone.
What do you want? Why are you bothering me?
Oh my name is Gorman. I'm trying to hand in real estate.
Turns out I'm a total pain.
It's a total pain right now.
I'm looking for a 10 and you see the thing is I can only rent to a wimp.
Do you guys remember that reddit post that went semi viral?
Where the guy was like looking for a roommate.
But you wouldn't have to pay if you're a woman.
You'd just have to give up the goods basically.
Yeah I don't know if you guys remember that but I do.
And it was pretty wild.
You found me a house yesterday. Go rent.
Oh I remember that.
Yes.
Okay I knew I wasn't the one that knew about it.
That was legit. It was pretty nice.
Right we actually can get access to the rooftop now.
Once we pick up the last item we're going to do a massive amount of exploring.
Because you want to make sure you get naturally due.
Is that supposed to be the lead? No it's not.
So my update last night.
Yeah last night I was doing my research about this game.
No chance. I don't think I can play sub six and make it interesting.
I'm going to be honest. I don't think I can make it interesting.
Strongest, strongest, strongest explorer.
Oh does he want to teach me anything here?
Hello.
Come again when you can jump further.
I never believed Sivir's your kind of game.
It would be fun to just be like scorching it but...
Wait is this going to give me like 50 bombs then?
That's a big bomb bag.
Well you are a big spender thank you.
It does! It gives me 50 so I'm going to have 50 arrows as well.
Okay okay.
I assume the shield doesn't actually give me...
You already have a fine shield.
Yeah I was going to say.
We already have one I'm not sure.
No one seems to want to fuse Kinstone pieces.
Have I like done everyone?
I think I might have done everyone in town.
Strongest big spender and she can handle deposit.
Hope you're having a good day.
Yeah I'm having a cheeky slow morning.
I've got my cup of tea.
I'm just letting it cool down a little bit.
We'll go at the Castello and upgrade our equipment.
We can...
Oh look at that.
Zoom in.
Absolutely zoom in.
I think it would be...
It's a group club idea.
They do an endurance club by each other and so...
Unfortunately the girls can't do that because they need to move out.
Or their parents are going to come flying in the room and be like,
Shut up!
I love hedges!
I love gardening!
It's saving me from the snake!
That's kind of the problem.
That's why I'm always like,
Please support the girls because we have plans of moving to better locations and stuff.
I knew gardening would pay off.
How long is stream today?
I don't know.
It depends how much time we piss off about.
Wow!
I actually don't know how much longer.
Lore-wise?
We only have one more item to unlock.
You're in presence of the true master, Grimblade.
If you train me, you become a master.
Would you like to train?
Yes please.
I think we've only got like four more hours of gameplay.
To learn the meaning of the power of this technique,
you start with first, second, third.
Yeah, sure.
I was listening.
But this is only the beginning.
It comes to real thing.
You must feel the technique.
That's why I will never possess your body.
With the Grimblade possession technique.
Watch this!
Position!
No, I think it will be like four hours.
Oh wow, I can like shoot.
You must try it yourself.
When you're...
Oh, that's such a good thing.
Oh.
No way!
I just like straight up have a laser beam now.
Do you teach me anymore?
You're awesome.
Can you teach me more?
No, there's nothing more I can teach you.
But that's pretty cool.
If I'm full health, I have a bullet now.
Possession.
We refuse this forbidden stream allegation.
Oh my god.
I don't want to know the allegation.
Them allegunkns.
I was outrageous that stream.
But for anyone that gets annoyed with me going
bit, bit, bit for all the bees.
I visit her every hour to have much to offer
but you're welcome to stay.
Stop!
They're so cute and humble.
The stream didn't even get limited ads
even though the context of the stream
is absolutely outrageous.
Oh, the falling trees up.
You can visit the Swordmaster at the lake.
Did I not?
Did we not go back?
I thought we went back.
YouTube ads are such a working system.
Are you guys getting ads?
I told them not to put them on stream.
Wah!
Oh, well, I can definitely go to that lake right now.
What?
She's trying to gain it.
Right, so we basically just don't,
just don't get caught by the AI.
I don't know how severe it is
or if it's like accessible.
Wah, it doesn't seem too bad.
Um...
Who even gets bothered by the bees?
Well, literally, if you're considering,
like, with a hook or something like that.
Here?
That doesn't seem right.
Woah!
No way I did that!
Wait, is there a hidden-
Yeah, okay, let's definitely do the hidden stuff first.
I'm shooting my laser beam!
Oh my god, this is so OP!
Sorry, but actually...
What is here?
Oh, I went the right way.
I went the right way.
Uh...
She's charging my laser.
The laser's also two times your sword damage.
Are you winning, Strunnion Chat?
Yeah, we're infusing the third element!
We now are adding the water element to the sword.
Which is fantastic.
I don't have my blanket and I'm
killing the circulation in my leg.
It's my pure accident.
I don't have access to my alternative Twitter.
But I hope that audio did well.
The power of the element allows you to
split into three copies now.
That's cute.
We're winning when Strunnion is on the screen.
There we go, just like that!
The audio was Ace here.
What is it?
I was like, oh, it's so cringe.
Like, I struggle so much to talk when I'm like that.
I was just like...
Please read me out.
I was the best I got.
I couldn't do it anymore.
Okay, glad you're in.
Ah, frickin', not to be...
Yikes, my nerve.
Sorry, I just woke up.
No, I didn't.
I didn't.
No, you gave me money.
I didn't get demonetized.
That's what it's saying for people who
like hate when I go like burger bing-boot,
but it's babas bing-boot.
The reason why I brought it up is because
we didn't get...
Gammy, stop it.
Not again.
We didn't get demonetized.
But thank you for the tip.
Thank you for the super chat.
Was there something under here?
There it was.
Burger bing-boot, that is.
The bath we knew won.
We knew won.
We're doing it.
I don't know what we're doing,
but we're doing it.
We're not jumping down.
We probably should go gambuzzle shells soon.
What do you think, Link?
Pretty dark and spooky, isn't it?
Makes you want to cry, doesn't it?
You're not scared?
Well, neither am I.
Come on, let's go.
I'm actually going to chug my tea.
I do apologize.
Tell you what, we'll go to Hyrule
because it sounds a bit more nice.
The background ambiance in Hyrule is a bit nicer.
Let me just slurp this tea.
But thank you, Broly Legends99 underscore.
You're getting very specific with the names here.
We're on an adventure.
Big Ben Zershin.
I have no clue what this is.
Like Big Bilbo Baggins.
Like Big Bilbo Baggins, Big Plugs.
Like Toys, that kind of thing.
Algo has no close stroneas.
I'm architect.
Oh, no, you can say architect
because it just sounds like architecture.
Don't forget to take them in if you haven't.
Oh, I'm already hired, okay.
I changed my wind.
She's gone, lads.
The Vietnamese fucked me up real good
but they also have really good food
so I'll allow this discretion
that has been against me
via the Vietnamese.
But I forgive you, Vietnamese lady
that destroyed my toe.
Yeah, I changed it.
Healing very beautifully.
I'm very happy to say
it doesn't look like there's any sign of infection.
Doesn't smell like that.
Not getting any indication.
So I get to put a salt bath for it very...
I think in five, well, four days
to soak away what I can.
They said you can use hot water
and swirl it around
but it's a bit too sensitive
for that at the moment.
I'd rather not.
But I'll do a salt bath shortly
but we're healing nicely.
Things are looking good.
The painkillers are painkilling.
And life is good.
I've got a few shorts
of the girls coming on the way
which I'm excited about.
I'm going to put some
cheeky advertisement money into
as I always do.
Mercy's short.
I thoroughly enjoyed
Shout out to the editor.
They just applied themselves
on the website
and they turned out to be
exactly what I was looking for.
Edit and style and all.
And they've never complained
about any of the edits either.
I love me.
I love me an edit and slave
that doesn't complain about work.
I love it when you guys
still complain
and I get to put you at work.
But he edited Mercy's
Senpai Should I Be Blonde
and I've got everyone
to do a version of that.
I'm about to send that off.
Oh no.
Strony's removed Tony on chat.
No.
I'm still here watching mommy.
Are you watching me in spirit?
Because you no longer exist.
We're all willing slaves
on this farm.
Yes but not for cat-a-wise.
Not cat-a-wise.
Ever been jealous of an editor?
Yeah, me too.
I mean...
Is it jealousy?
Is it jealousy
if I'm taking advantage
of the editor's hard work?
Is it jealousy
if I'm taking advantage?
Strony was here
peeling you in on the new Zelda game.
I haven't...
I'm still yet to see it actually.
I do apologize.
However, it looks fantastic.
I would watch it live with you guys.
But if you didn't know,
most game trailers
actually get copyrighted.
Because for promotional reasons
they get permissions
of certain songs
or additives
Yes?
It should have been me.
If you phrase it like that,
yes.
Oh, right.
Well, fucking relax.
You know.
I just put the files together.
So, can I tell you some secrets?
But these are bad secrets, okay?
These are bad secrets.
No one should know.
Oh, Tim...
Tim Schrotto.
There, see?
Netherlands praten.
I'm from the Netherlands?
Thank you very much.
One euro.
Yeah.
Streaming must not be named
was very useful.
I am glad you guys didn't judge me.
I honestly thought I was like,
relatively like...
But, like, you know,
I went exploring
and I was like,
damn,
strong a freak.
And I'm like,
am I actually?
Are you guys just scared to explore?
Please leave me alone.
Gami!
Gami, when did you get your hair done?
I've seen more degenerates.
Yeah, we're up there with you.
Okay, thank God.
Gami, I see you in that tree.
Don't think I don't see you, Gami.
Gami, don't be naughty.
Gami, that...
Okay, that's just a quick way down.
Tharya, thank you for coming,
a member.
Hi, BW.
I was...
I was like,
oh, you need to stay filled in.
Right, what's the plan?
What's the plan, Batman?
Up.
What's the plan?
You need to tell me the strategies.
Left.
Hmm, I know what left is.
Yes, yes, left.
Do you remember as a child,
I couldn't do this section?
Same as before.
Left.
Oh, no.
I wonder I couldn't do this as a child.
Same as the beginning.
Up.
Up, left, left, up, right.
Same as two before.
Up, left, left,
left, up, right.
Up.
Oh, thank god.
Don't ever make me do a logic puzzle again.
The disrespect.
Make me do a logic puzzle first thing in the morning.
There was a key that's needed tomorrow.
Okay, a key.
Oh, it's a new house.
Oh, hello.
My name's Dampi.
I'm a grave digger.
What's that?
You were called here by the ghost of the king.
That'd be the ancient king of Hyrule who rests here.
I've seen him myself.
Well, it's just king.
I can't see any reason not to let you in here.
Take this key.
Oh, that was a super easy little safe quest.
Mummy do be smart.
Well done.
Easy peasy lemon squeezy.
Gami!
Gami.
What's with that crow?
He up and flew away with a key.
Charge after him and get that dang key.
I lost the key.
Have you got a spare?
What?
A crow took the key and flew away with the tree.
Well, don't just stand around and get the crow.
Charge at him and give him that tree a rattle if you want it back.
If you stay with a person long of you,
spice things up.
Oh, yeah?
Mellow to spice things up by going in the book.
Oh, it was that quick.
So we managed to get the key back.
Yeah.
Okay.
Please tell me it's not going to swoop down and yank it
and it was just like a little small side thing.
I'll open the gate for you.
Be careful this time though.
Hello.
I'm going to kill you.
Yeah, let's fuse.
I love crows but that behavior is unexpected.
Oh, we never played that.
What does it do?
What have we just done?
Hey, I've just had a great idea.
This will add you a little more risk.
I'm so excited.
Curious.
They fit perfectly.
Hi.
What are you doing here?
This is a graveyard.
There's ghosts here.
Oh, yeah.
Speaking of which, my brother lives in town.
He's a troublemaker prankster,
but I often wonder what he's doing.
Push.
No.
Wait.
Why did that give me a noise though?
Did he dig the grave?
Surely not.
Okay.
Yeah, we're not doing that.
How about this?
No.
Oh, okay.
We need to push through graves at a time.
Oh, we need to hit those buttons.
Wait, are these like all secret graves?
No great braving for our shock and behavior.
Look, I'm a child.
I don't know the implicate.
Why would I move that one?
And why did it give me the do-do-do-do-do-do-do?
Oh.
Can I do it?
I can.
Can I?
Is that three or four?
I took my legs off.
Oh, let's go.
You got a piece of heart.
Dang straight, I got a piece of heart.
I'm just so good, baby.
So this one didn't move.
I wonder if the king's grave is up there.
Surely a mystery.
We'll never know.
Okay, let's try this again.
No, no.
It's just grave discovery.
How do I get over there without breaking my guys?
Oh.
I can just like pass through stuff.
It may be the royal crepe, but graves are creepy.
No matter where they are, where is the king's supposed to meet?
I'm good stuff.
I'm not so sure.
I even want to help anymore.
Can we just go somewhere that's less creepy?
Oh my God, he took a hammer in.
He took a hammer in.
I'm doing aimbot from halfway through.
I'm literally sniping him from the map.
So that's horrifying.
Oh no.
What one is it?
Is it this one?
Because I can see a platform there.
Right replaying.
Middle left or right?
We just wanted to hold.
You can burn the mummies with a lamp.
Right, get that lamp right here.
Middle was first.
Oh, it doesn't make a difference.
What's going on here?
What's going on?
Ah.
Oh wow, that disappeared so quick.
Okay, okay, okay.
I was getting a bit worried.
I was getting a bit nervous that nothing was going to occur there.
Oh no.
This is not good.
Do I have time?
Wah, wah, wah, wah.
Okay, that was freaking lucky.
Because that was not good.
That was not good.
But we did it.
We did it.
We did whatever challenge was necessary.
Further into the...
You...
The devs knew exactly what they were doing putting that there.
That is so cheeky, honestly.
Well, this totally doesn't look like a battle dome.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How do I put them on fire?
Oh.
I need to give it a drive by.
You didn't tell me there were scallies underneath.
Of course the fires start attacking me too.
Oh wow, we like sped on that.
We didn't even have to go left or right.
Yeah, can you speed it up a bit, mate?
Yeah, a bit quicker.
I've not got all day, mate.
Yeah, a bit faster.
You got a canstone piece.
These mystic stones are said to bring happiness.
Fascinating.
An ancient king of Hyrule.
How strange.
And the source of the flow.
What's that supposed to mean?
Her fanny, mate, obviously.
Wait, no, you kicked me out.
I didn't finish exploring.
Let me back in.
Wait, did I even have a key?
Oh, they're fake doors.
No way.
Oh wait, how did I get back?
Oh, suck, suck, suck, suck.
Mumbo.
I was like, you said it enough.
A little cheeky suckage there.
I got nervous there, right.
We'll go thank the graveyard guy for letting me in.
Thank you.
Oh, he's already gone home.
Honestly, I'd be home too.
Hi.
Oh, less, less, less, up, up, up, down.
What was that last time?
Yeah, let's fuse.
What you got for me.
Stranny, I know you approve of dolls.
What if the doll is taller than the person normally is?
Has it all been done?
Oh.
Well, I guess we're going back to the graveyard.
A tall, skeletal doll?
Cheeky skeletal moment?
I don't know.
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Ah, so you moved the graveyard and now you can go outside.
I'll get lonely.
Can you come see me sometime?
I have plenty of Kinstones.
Oh, is this like infinite Kinstone person?
Like a Slenderman doll.
I don't think I could tolerate a Slenderman doll.
Oh.
Well, that's the source of the floor if I've ever seen one.
A waterfall.
Hello.
How many shells?
I think we might need to gamble.
Oh, we're 700.
Do you have any more to fuse together like you claimed young lady?
Oh, you do.
I wonder if she's just an infinite...
I'll come back.
I need to cut the grass, okay?
The source of the floor is...
Wow.
I fucking got so nervous.
I was ready to pop at two minutes.
I got a little heated during the stream.
I was ready to pop after two minutes.
I was like, bro, I can't.
And then I got shy,
so I actually lasted the normal amount of time
and I was like, yeah, this one's like...
What's in here?
Hello.
Well, we definitely need to gamble now after that.
Yeah, I expected minutes just to be talking.
No.
Are we really doing gamble?
I don't know.
Gamble time.
Hello.
Traits.
The odds of us getting the same thing is diabolical.
If we end up with the same one figure percentage,
this just proves my gamble luck is just outrageously bad.
Aw, Zill and friends.
Zill is the one with the drippy nose.
He likes to wander around town with his pals.
He knows a lot about Hyrule and he might even give you some tips.
Aw.
I don't...
Right, we'll do this for like a whole four minutes, okay?
That's the best I got.
Four minutes in me and then we'll move on to the actual gameplay.
I think we have to go top right now
and then we unlock the last area and the last item.
Um...
Our probability is 97%.
How many...
Is there a hundred figurines on the door?
You...
Catch a game play.
Golden rule.
They call the snakes the rules.
I mean, I guess.
Okay.
Stunning hearing you finish...
Oh.
Great.
Now she's cool to live.
Aw, wait a minute.
I'm glad you...
Bond Liz.
Thank you for the mimbo.
There's a girl from my hero.
Your profile picture is bigger.
Let's take the girl from my hero.
I just forgot the name.
95%.
Right.
I'll stop.
Yeah, tell you what, I'll make a deal.
I'll stop once we get a duplicate.
A chaser.
Yeah, those things were chasing me.
They were getting my ankles, honestly.
We'll stop when we get a duplicate so we can be hero.
Hemiko.
Yeah.
There are 136 figurines total.
Okay.
So the probability is two.
Well, I guess that's our gamble time over.
Thank you everyone for playing at home.
I appreciate it.
Literally what the percentage is so high.
And it was one that we had literally just go up.
Oh wait, I can swim now.
Right, can I still not get this?
It doesn't look like...
I don't see a Minish entrance.
Oh, I need to jump with a freaking cape.
Right, okay, we're gonna go get a cape.
Right, no one wants to trade me.
That's fine.
We'll go get some switch for the reeflings
because I don't want you guys to be too hungry.
On our adventure, I'll get you your lovely cape.
Yes, thank you.
Nothing this time.
That's okay.
As long as the reefling got some food in this, come on.
I wonder what the mayor says now that we've been in his house.
I may look somewhat idle too, but no, sir.
I'll be working terrifically hard as soon as you leave.
You can bet that.
Oh, he's just like classic doesn't do anything.
Right, we now need to go top.
Right, let's speed things up a bit.
Get to work.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, my bad.
Wait, is that a bump tree?
Oh, a cheeky bear.
Hey, I could actually use you right now
because I can't shoot my laser beam.
Thank you.
Basically every polish.
Hey, you can't say that.
Oh, we can swim.
Once we get the last item, we will do a full exploration.
Whoa, I can see that guy with a rock helmet over there.
Oh, I'm getting...
No, no bomba, no bomba.
Hello.
Oh, that's what the king gave us.
The two fit perfectly.
He has a cool hat as well.
What's your favorite item in this game?
A stone door.
So that's what they meant by the source of the flow business.
Well, this waterfall certainly is the source of Hyrule's water.
According to King Gustav,
the final element lies somewhere behind these falls.
We've done a long enough length.
Let's paint that element.
Maybe my favorite item is the light
so I can fucking see in this cave.
Oh, I'm missing.
I'm missing.
The bat's just so skinny.
Right, whoops.
In both.
Um...
Oh god, what's that doing?
Oh, you can't destroy it.
I'm on fire and I can't do anything.
I guess it makes you vulnerable.
Oh, no more bomba.
No more bombs.
I can't take any more bombs.
Give me my gambaba.
Oh my god, why is he so aggressive?
Get me up this wall.
Oh no, they're going to chase me up the wall.
No, leave me alone.
Leave me alone.
I'm just a per innocent boy.
I have no family.
Spare my life.
Hey, we found another wind crest.
Absolutely, right.
Let me think about that.
Stop!
Oh my god, just a minute.
Get me in this cave right now.
It's even worse than the cave.
Oh, that didn't even hurt him.
What's there here?
Okay, just...
I swear if it shells.
Bro, we've got enough shells.
I don't want a gambaba though.
I don't want to send gambaba.
Oh, gambaba at the end.
Up or down, up or down.
I'm going up.
I'm going up stairs.
I'm going to enter.
Jeez, the bat and fire station caverns.
Think of the tourism industry.
Okay, I'll take you.
What?
I need out.
Jeez, let me.
The race.
Wait.
I've just done a 360.
No.
Right.
Yeah, I was going to say,
there's clearly something in the war
if it's giving me a ledge.
Some of those are ropes though.
I'm not even interacting with that.
Anything in here?
Whoa, red.
Oh, yes, I've unlocked it.
Have a gun.
It was like, what?
Oh, I'm rubbish at this game.
Shawnee's going to turn into a hoarder
of pyramid crafts all of a sudden.
Literally, there's so many shells.
So this wasn't the way I was supposed to go.
What is?
I think I've done wrong then.
What?
Oh, there's a door there.
That I didn't take.
There is a fitting fitting.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Did it?
Sorry, excuse me.
Pardon me, coming through.
What have we here?
Some kind of vortex?
Well, we seem to have hit a dead end.
What shall we do from here?
Go in the vortex.
Close talk.
Am I still alive?
Link, what were you thinking, child?
You just reaped the world winds, as they say.
We could be dead right now.
I must admit, it did the trick.
Are we?
In the lands above the clouds?
Then there must be something here
that can lead us to the fire element.
Let's go find it.
Ah, you surprised me.
Normally, surface dwellers can't walk on the clouds
like we do.
My sister and I went to the Depokori Festival
on Hyrule Town,
and when we came back,
there were monsters everywhere.
I bet if I could just fuse a Kinstone,
but there are monsters about even...
Do you think you could search for the Kinstone people?
Oh, do you need like...
Oh, no, we can do it.
Fly, Strony, fly!
My favorite dungeon.
Are you late this year?
I think the air tops are maybe...
Really?
I know the reward is like...
getting...
Uh, yeah, we li-
Did I not skip the clouds?
Oh, hello.
Okay, but I don't have what you need.
What about you?
Oh, this is bad, really bad.
Oh, hey, look at that.
I've never seen a surface dweller on the clouds.
You must be pure of heart.
Maybe one such as you would listen to the tale of my woe.
See?
Right, I'm...
I just heard it from your sister.
Thank you.
That sounded really rude.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
I do have it.
Sorry, I pressed the wrong button.
The controls are...
Slightly different position.
Ooh, where did we unlock?
Cause it's red.
Ooh, is it gonna be a coup?
Oh, we were just there!
I was just there!
Rude.
Honestly.
Okay.
Uh, let's go a little further right?
Cause I can...
Or no.
What am I the bad dude?
Heh heh heh.
What's down here?
Wow!
We are short.
I like how we get to dig the clouds.
That's so cool.
Oh!
Wait!
We can get Kenstone pieces in here?
Or was that, like, actually there?
I think that may have actually been sitting there.
Okay.
Uh, let's fold down.
Cause we've not been in them here.
Wow!
Hello!
Did I have your missing piece?
I did!
All yours, buddy.
Mysterious cloud.
Uh...
A couple more to go, I guess?
That's probably more shells, honestly.
Uh, we take a little left here.
A little cheeky left.
Uh, what is over here?
Is there anything of interest?
No.
Let's jump down first to make sure we have,
adequately,
the woman trouble.
Oh god, they're going to knock me off the map.
Okay.
Two hit.
Oh, he just...
Oh, we got a...
Okay, okay, okay.
Second piece, second piece.
Yeah, let me get up, let me get up.
Thank you.
Skyfish.
Skyshark.
Honestly.
Skiyark.
Great.
What is this down here?
A little to the left.
Let's grab that wind gust.
Don't want to get in trouble.
Let me get up.
Uh, oh, there was something up there.
Hmm.
Can I do it?
Whoa, where are you?
Did I need a shield from him?
Well, luckily...
Okay.
I'm sorry.
What was that supposed to do?
A bow and arrow?
I think a bow and arrow.
Oh, suck him up.
Because he's an arrow thing.
Gimme your cloud right now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're not so big without your cloud now, are you?
Mario's gonna...
Oh, sugar.
Right, we need to come back to this one.
Because we don't have the correct piece.
Surely, I will not forget the location.
Surely.
Hope you'll...
Okay, uh, middle left is...
Uh, tree...
Middle left.
What?
No, chicken shells, but I'm so full.
Jar of boomerang will not...
What?
That is my favorite mermaid waifu?
I ain't even a mermaid.
Oh, good thing.
Ah.
Oh, there's another one of those guys.
Wait, you perish.
Yeah, we're getting there with the minish.
We're on the last element,
and then I think everything goes to do the time.
Yeah, yeah.
Perish.
Oh.
Okay.
Is this it?
Okay, we now know...
it's middle left for whatever one is missing.
Oh, there's five?
Oh, them...
I don't know what one to do then.
Oh, well, I don't mind if I do.
Oh.
Am I gonna have to do a second lap?
I feel like I'm gonna have to do a second lap
around this area.
I don't know.
I can't remember your style.
As soon as you said mermaid,
and I'm like,
I'm not a mermaid.
And I'm like,
oh, wait a minute.
I was like,
oh, wait, hold on a minute.
Hold on a minute.
I didn't write that part of my line.
Oh, I got two licks in.
I'm the most.
One each.
You know, for an enemy,
you sure as heck don't actually directly attack.
I'm gonna get shoved off the map because of that.
Oh, I need to defeat him.
No, I'm...
Okay, I need like an eight-foot sword,
like an Elden Ring.
Or just do that and knock yourself out.
Aren't sirens the evil mermaids?
I mean, I guess.
I guess you're lucky that I don't have to sing,
or you'd be in such deep doo-doo.
You're not in deep doo-doo.
Right, enough with the shells.
We ain't go all the time at Gambo.
Sure, drop this here.
I won't say there's something here.
Just get me up.
Freaking go.
There's a cheeky hole.
What's up there?
I don't know.
What's down here?
Oh, a fusion.
I'll take it.
You fit.
Perfect.
I calculated.
Calculate.
Yes, yes, calculate.
True, true, emoji gamer.
Okay, two more.
I have one golden piece.
I just need the other one.
I can go back to the middle one that I missed.
Wow, we can't get up there.
But we can get radio.
There's not like a secret on the wall or anything.
Where are we going?
Come on.
Okay, we're now back on the other one.
I need to go top left to get the last piece.
Which I'm going to do right now.
Top left.
Yes.
Baby, last piece.
Oh my God.
I'm so smart.
Oh, there's something here.
Hey, don't give me.
You know what?
Okay.
I should have gambled.
I admit it.
I should have kept gambling.
I apologize.
Okay.
I think it was in here.
Literally the game's like, please gamble.
I'm like, I'm child.
I shouldn't be doing it.
Right.
Did we?
I think it's back at the start.
And the other one.
There's a back at the start.
Question mark.
I don't know.
Serves you right for not gambling.
Did you know that 100% of people that win big give up,
like right before,
I can't remember what the meme format is,
but yeah, it's awful.
Please don't actually gamble.
I'm actually getting a bit turned around now.
I'm like 99%.
I already did this one today.
So what's up here?
Okay.
I grabbed that one.
What was back down here?
I can't remember.
90% of gambling addicts quit before they hit big.
Yeah, literally that's so terrible.
That meme format is absolutely a reader.
I'd actually be really interested in doing a deep dive
into the gamble psychology
because I struggle to comprehend it
because I just get really...
Right.
Am I going the wrong way again?
I think I might have.
Oh, I got red.
Okay, it is just random.
I'm running in circles.
I know I'm trying to get back to the start.
I don't know where the last podium is.
Any podium goers?
I think it's back at the start.
I think I just can go back now because I've got the piece.
Unless it was back there.
Wait, hold on.
Let me do a U-turn.
I'm too busy yapping.
No, we did do it.
Right, go back up again.
Yeah, the last one's back at the start.
Okay, okay, okay.
No, no, Link, no.
I'm starting to think you just like the gravity of falling.
You can't go back to the start from here.
Always gambit till you're broke.
No, this is terrible.
I think it's to the right there.
Right, I just need to take our U-turn right and then we found it.
This, this is it.
Surely.
Sure is it.
Oh, there it is.
I just need a drop down.
Wow.
Whoever said go right, time them out.
No one said that.
You don't have to say that anymore.
Oh, we did it, we did it, we did it.
Get me the heck out here.
Why gamble when you can give your money a mummy?
No, well, you don't need to do that either.
What's more of a ways gamble or giving me money?
Choose your, choose your challenger.
We did it, yeah.
Fantastico, fantastico, let's go.
And we got two redkenstone pieces of all that.
Oh my god, look how pretty it is.
Oh, and we can get a freaking flight stolen.
Thank goodness.
Hey, we found another wincrease.
Now we have one more to travel to when we use the ocarina.
Hey, ocarina.
Now, how do you build something like this on top of a clown?
Maybe someone lives inside.
If so, perhaps you could ask for the element.
I'm just checking if there's a hidden secret on the outside, but no.
It's kinda...
Okay, now the man's out of my way.
Do you remember that portal?
Oh, if it's an old link, my quest to match kinstones has taken me all the way up here.
I'm not sure you've noticed yet, but we're on top of the clouds.
The wind trebles here.
They protect the path of the palace of winds where the wind element lies.
Oh, it's you.
I thought I'd never make it back here, but thanks to your kinstone, I did.
If you're looking for something, go talk to the elderly lady on the fourth floor.
Okay, elderly lady, fourth floor.
Blue flower, white thorns.
There's something like that, I can't remember.
Oh yeah, give me your pot.
Look, there's the old man.
He's up in there, and there's something.
Oh, it's Link.
Thank you for your help over there.
I've got something else here.
Take this.
Huh?
Did you double damage?
Imagine if I let that gentleman slip away.
Why is everyone asking for the pieces I don't have?
You know, feel well.
I don't have that piece.
He just upgraded my bowl.
Hello?
Let me guess.
You're going to ask for a piece I don't have?
Oh, you asked for the piece I actually do know.
Hold the button.
A snake.
Yeah, yeah.
It's all coming in my way.
Well done.
Hey, they set perfectly.
The wind tribe is very skilled at pieces.
So skilled in fact.
We have more of them than we can manage.
We can't even store them.
I wish someone would take them.
You wish someone would take them?
Say no more.
No, I'm not doing anything in here at all.
Yeah, oh, thanks.
She's slow.
I'll take that.
Don't mind if I do.
Thanks, hen.
I appreciate it.
Yeah, your collection's a whale.
Oh, what's that?
You need someone to take away all your pieces?
Oh, you shouldn't.
Yeah, you shouldn't.
What's going on?
Welcome, welcome.
Long, long ago and then the age before that.
I tried the brand and the place you call the wind ruins.
With our magic,
we moved our palace up into the skies.
We are the wind tribe.
We've been watching and we know all that is happening
on your surface world.
We know a small boy collects elements
to lift the curse for a princess.
We know of Vati and his evil acts.
The winds tell us these things.
The wind element that you seek lies deep
in the palace of winds above me.
When the blade has been infused with four elements,
sorry, forgetting my lines here,
the way to the light force shall open.
So it is told in the legend of the wind tribe.
Vati himself may already know this.
Surfaced well as they're not permitted
to enter our palace,
but you, boy, are special.
You may continue to the roof.
Can I fuse with you?
You're a cheeky granny, you are.
You're cheeky cheeky granny.
You got me a weekend stone to fuse.
There's this device in the palace
that allows you to fly in the sky.
When I get bigger,
I want to explore the palace and find it,
but I'm too scared right now.
You just walked over me.
That's rude.
And before someone complains
about being weighed down by Cherries.
Cherries for me to take.
Right here.
Oh, baby!
Okay, full health.
Ready?
We're going to do this
and I'll make a tea,
and then we'll do lots of exploring
to see if we can get all the hearts and stuff.
One, irritation.
We find our way to the very tops of the cloud,
and then we have to go even higher
to find a floating palace.
I can't believe what a long way we've come.
And look how high we are.
Don't look down, blink,
and watch your step.
It's a long fall from here, ya bam.
Look, I'm trying my best, jeez.
Don't need to...
Oh, I'm gonna need them.
I'm gonna need to...
There's so many enemies on this map.
Oh.
Oh, it made them fall.
Oh, that's not very nice.
Where'd they go?
Can I stop coming?
No!
I didn't know you could do that!
But the scallies...
I just got pranked.
And 4k.
Alright, hold on.
We need to do the boomerang.
So we need to do the boomerang?
Is that it?
Am I going crazy?
What do I need?
A bow and arrow?
Am I like, banned arrows now?
Okay, okay.
Arrows, arrows.
It's fine, it's fine.
Guys, why are you sweating?
I was going,
hmm, I missed the logic in this puzzle.
Oh, whoa.
I almost fell off the map
because I wasn't paying attention.
Eeps.
Okay, let's do a bow and arrow.
I need to go by with 3?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Why would you give me stones?
I can push, I have no idea.
Wow.
Music game, good.
Wow, please don't hurt me.
Please don't hurt me.
Whoa.
Okay, I've actually got a fright there.
I'm like, I just jumped in my chair.
Like, I knew it was going to happen,
but I still got a fright nonetheless.
What is going on?
Whoa.
What am I to go?
I can't do that.
Whoa, whoa.
Where's the fire going?
Oh my God, I'm so skinny.
I'm actually so skinny,
I didn't get hit once, Lamal.
There's a fluffy cloudflown here.
It looks awfully comfortable.
I too would like to sleep on a cloud.
Should I?
I'm going to use the boomerang.
Oh.
Because it doesn't cost any ammo.
I jumped too.
Literally, give me a wee fray.
Oh, I'm supposed to be here.
Ew, what happens if I sat on it?
Oh, I'm actually...
Logic puzzle or I'm just...
Am I going the wrong way?
Okay.
Use a bomb.
I'm about to blow this.
I would not have figured that out.
I'm going to be honest.
Oh, yum.
Ah.
Shadow Wizard money game.
We look at these spills.
Well, I lost that fight anyway.
Oh.
I wondered that.
We unlocked the figurines
before we actually went against them.
Bro, bro, bro, bro, bro, bro.
This is the shit.
Shadow Wizard money game.
Oh, I'll get wrecked.
Oh, bless I am. You've got Rockscape. Great. Jump with the greatness of Ease. Hold the button and jump faster.
Right. Oh my god. Oh, I'm so good. I'm actually so good.
This game. Well, we can officially fully explore the map now. We'll do.
Gamma. I saw that.
I'm actually so good. You have this figure. You must be a fan of the family.
Oh my god. I love being able to jump.
Okay.
I just can't roll up them.
I cast and bear her growth.
I'm still in mulch. I'm still addicted to mulch.
Whoa. Game shields up.
I can't.
There's a strong gale blowing here. Try not to get swept away and hold on to your hat. You're my hat.
Am I supposed to get blown away? I think I'm supposed to jump.
I am supposed to jump. Whoa.
I was almost gone there. I'm not going to lie. We almost didn't make that jump there.
Oh.
What? Okay. We need to do the magic staff thing.
Okay. Okay. We're getting there. We're getting there.
Zelda. Let's go. That panel. I think if we stomped on it hard enough, it might flip over.
Yeah. We're still missing two bottles. No. I ain't doing it.
The money's good, but I ain't doing it.
I ain't missing it.
I don't actually remember how difficult the boss is up ahead.
There is a possibility we have to go...
We have to go back. We have to go deeper.
Because we are missing out on a lot of exploratory goodies.
Oh my... Bruh, who's...
How skinny you can come?
Ah, can I do it in time? No, by a freaking bore here.
No, Gami. Stop it. Gami, that's mean.
Okay. It looks like I need to jump between two.
Yes. After this area, we'll do exploring.
We'll try and get full hearts. We'll go back to all those master tutor people as well.
Professional speedrunner confirmed, actually, though.
Witch dungeon. This is for the fourth element, the wind element. We're in the sky temple.
I might want to activate my boots first.
Oh, I don't like this. I don't like this.
I'm just going to take the HP damage because...
Yeah, I don't want to have to do this.
Oh, and the fucking boots respawned.
Well, I'm not mad with Spain.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, and the respawn.
One thing I could absolutely decimate about this game.
Okay, and then straight down.
Jeez, get me over there.
I tried to put up my uno collab.
Schedule, and it kept rejecting it for some reason.
I think me, Mercy, and me are just too powerful.
I kept saying error when I put it up.
Sorry about the uno collab not being up, but there is an uno collab.
Oh, as far as I'm aware, there's an uno collab.
Silly me. Silly me. I'm being a silly sausage.
But I'll try and get it up.
Why did you do that?
I'll try and get it up after the stream.
Oh, killing me.
Tiny time. Tiny time.
Tiny time.
Oh, no. Oh, no, this can't be.
Is this a logic puzzle? Well, I can only push it.
Oh, shit.
Like this.
Oh, that's a star.
A bluntly half as well.
I'm making it worse.
Oh, no way I did it.
Oh, my God. I don't know how I did that.
I'll take it.
I think this dungeon
is actually pretty big.
Can't believe you let me cook.
Can I jump over this?
No.
Oh.
I never see it until it's really obvious.
I got it lucky.
Wait, no.
Did not already have access to this area?
I'm losing it.
But I just did that.
Oh, I have a key to get here.
Yeah. When Twilight Princess, I've never played another Zelda game.
This is the issue. The only reason I'm doing malely good on this one
is because I actually played it before.
But focusing, there's another...
a new 2D Zelda out which I'm actually super interested in.
I need to watch the trailer.
But I think we might be playing Baltoi.
Baltoi? Baltoi.
Baltoi next week.
That's lovely, the piece that I've been needing.
I need to do what now?
Okay, I just send it.
What?
Thank you, Imperial Monarch. You're work right now?
Oh, I'm doing lawn work. Oh my god.
Someone commented under the video, like the audio.
You should... oh, I'm at work right now.
So I can't listen. And I always so tend to send back.
No, do it. Get hard at work.
I can't be doing this. People are getting fucking trouble for this shit, honestly.
But I was feeling it yesterday.
You guys were letting me talk about whatever my interests are in that.
So my brain was like, yeah, let's get rid of this.
How did I hurt myself in
trying to hurt the enemy?
Please get us in trouble. No, like, literally, I was like, no, this is...
I had to hold myself back. I don't know if you guys do this,
but I type out responses on Twitter and stuff, and then I delete it
because I'm like, no, you idiot. That's not a good idea.
Don't do that. That's so bad of me.
Hey, it is from...
Can I even get him? Yeah, I was going to say, can I even get him
without perishing? One way or another, he's going to get me.
It wouldn't mind some hearts. I'm starting to get a bit low.
Finally finished working, mummy. Thank you for the... yeah!
You're welcome!
Less than 3,000. Thank you so much.
Broly legend, thank you. Sorry.
I'm struggling. Just, just, just...
I'm struggling to read. I can't believe it. I can't believe my inability to read
is coming back to me. Oh, there's a heart! There's a heart! There's a heart!
Wait, this is not where I'm supposed to go?
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh, I can just go for it.
Because I have flight now. Can I jump for this one?
No, you cannot! Please, if you ever thought that you could
perhaps jump for that one, please don't jump for that one.
Don't be like me and think you can make it. You cannot make that jump.
Eh...
That's what office toilets are for.
That's terrible!
Right into... right in his arms. All of my guests, you're one too.
Please, game you... this game...
What the fuck is that?
Armor? Okay.
I need to buy a large quiver right now.
Because if... ow!
Bro, this game needs to start dropping hearts. Please do not make me go all the way back to the start. I'll cry.
Bruh.
I need focus. I actually need to focus! What's going on?
I need to focus.
Yeah, yeah, get fucked.
What is going on?
How much freaking arrow I put in you?
Oh, I'm actually gonna die. What happens if you die in Legend of Zelda?
Oh my god, the teleport's right there, I think.
This is the first teleport.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay. Let me get up, let me get up.
Oh! What the...
Wait, so I put a billion arrows? No, this isn't the teleport out!
Sugar, I thought this was the teleport here.
I am so low, but I don't want to go all the way back.
Holy crap, I just need to not mess it up. Don't mess...
Don't mess it up, it's fine. Don't mess it up though. Don't mess it up!
Can someone drop me a heart? Like, seriously?
No, I couldn't have done that worse if I tried!
If I tried, if I tried. If I tried.
Literally, the game has put me on life support.
Oh, am I actually gonna die? I really don't want to go back though!
Oh, please have a heart in this.
Can I keep leaving the room and then coming back?
Oh wait, I need a pot, sorry.
Hold on, is this gonna drop a heart if I do this?
It's dropping rupees, so if it's respawn and there's a chance it'll give me a heart.
Hold on, hold on!
Bear with me, bear with me, Aces in the room, bear with me.
Oh, come on!
Give us a chance for a heart! Why is this game so
allergic to dropping hearts from pots?
Literally, I'm just getting my bank account up right now.
A freaking shell! I don't need a shell!
I actually am starting to wonder if they even coded
any hearts to drop in these pots.
Yeah, thanks for the five rupees. That is useless for me right now.
Do you have fairies? Oh, I do have fairies!
Alright, I'll use one fairy.
That will have to do.
There is a possibility.
We don't do this, you know that?
We might have to go back and get more.
Thank you for your...
Yeah, you're more than welcome.
Ah!
Of course a heart drops when I've dunked the fairy.
Oh, Justin no more.
Yeah? Okay, well...
Shadow Wizard? I'm gonna get it.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Don't do that again. Jesus, I was cheating.
Oh, they're giving these kinsome pieces though, because I kinda need to trade.
They're gonna lie.
Don't fight me, bro.
Give me a heart! Give me a heart! Don't be shy! Give me a heart!
Can I whack him when I'm around?
I'm just going for it.
I'm just going for it. We are getting so low health.
We are getting so low health!
Oh my god. That for a key?
Something has to give.
Wait, can I just permanently get rid of this guy?
Fuck you!
Did they always drop fairies?
New Zelda lore?
Did they always drop fairies when you whack them? Or was that just like really good
rear drop?
Get in my bowl! Get in the jar!
What? No!
No way!
Oh my god, we got the big key, but we still don't have the teleport.
We didn't drop fairies! Fuckin' get hit ya! Bam!
Give me that right now. Right, we've got two fairies.
Oh my god, learning!
Ronnie talking to Reflings. I just called you guys Ronnie there.
Ronnie and Reflings together becomes Ronnie!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and all the hearts are here. Oh god.
Oh, I'm sure I've mentioned this before, but I'm no good with heights.
Hold on, I think I see something down there.
I guess that means we have to take the plunge after all.
Oh shi...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I've got my wee tiny shield. You be nice to...
I looked the wrong way! No! I'm at full health! Oh my god, sorry.
I'm having a stroke. Link keeps looking so. I don't know why.
I don't know why.
How big is his freakin' sweat?
Ah!
Oh, I need my shield.
Why is it he can push me off the map?
But when I go to push him off the map, that's no possible.
And then he says I'm a wane. I've literally...
Is that gonna work?
What am I doing? I'm having a stroke but not the good kind!
Oh!
I'm having a stroke but not the good kind!
Oh my god!
Right, I'm just gonna keep coming back and forth.
I was getting absolutely rolled. That is embarrassing how bad that went.
I need to keep coming back to respawn the hearts. I'm so sorry.
Mapologies, mapologies.
Yeah, we're definitely
exploring to get the rest of the hearts. Because if I'm making and the rest of the
jars, if I'm making mistakes like that,
we ain't gonna be making it through anything. This is supposed to be
a game for children question mark? Absolutely not.
Because that is insane. Right, let's go.
Is there like 10 Pokemon sound effects
in one? What do you mean?
How much further do we have to go? This place goes on forever. There's no point in complaining
about it. We must press on more. After all, how much more could there be? Come on Link, let's go.
I like how the game acknowledges this area is so vast and
ridiculous. Okay, hearts.
Oh, no.
I do not consent.
Okay, hug someone else.
Okay, up the stairs.
What's up here? Slames.
Okay, let's suck these guys off.
Aw, I could have got a double kill there.
Um...
Mom.
Oh, that's what I didn't want.
I assume I need to do that.
Well, maybe if you weren't so selfish
and now I'm gonna have to restart the room and do that
all over again. I should have been new. Oh, I kept them all
perished. Okay, that's fine. That's fine.
Don't be nervous. Don't be shy. Is anyone online
right now that I need to shout out from the Allure?
Any of the Allures online?
Or what's the situation? Oh, I can jump over these.
I was like, aw, I can't do anything about that.
Wee! Oh, just
no more. I got a kill. Sheeby and Azura
in 30. Oh my god, that's right. They're playing
um, they're playing Jelly Bean game.
Uh, if anyone wants to join them, you can.
Oh, sorry, I'm to jump into it. My apologies. Yes, I'm to jump
into it. Yes, I knew that. Okay, well, I completely missed a lot.
Wee!
Uh, yes, they are going to load up a lobby first
and give each other, get each other in the lobby
and then they're going to reveal the code so you can
Jelly Bean snipe, uh, Sheeby and Azura.
Yeah, okay. Jelly Bean game!
Uh, this is my problem.
I don't know if they just continually respawn.
It's very plausible that they do.
Can I not? Okay, I was going to say, can I not do that?
Uh, no. You're in
my way. Please don't do that again.
Uh,
I've just done a 360.
Ow, where?
Um, I think I need to jump down
in the middle here. You know that? You know that? I'm getting a memory.
I'm getting a memory! Oh, I love Childhood Me.
You're so smart. Thank you for coming. We're literally saving this run
right now. Childhood Me, I'm not even joking.
We got a...
Yeah, I'll take that heart, please.
Great. So we go up here again.
Core memory found. Literally accessing
core memory. Right, and then...
Oh, you lose health so quick in this game.
Hold on a minute. Let him get up. Let him get up. Let me try again.
Let me try again.
That's it. Let him get up. Let him get up.
If it's gonna be safer going all the way around, I will go all the way around
because, bruh, let him get up.
Let me redo. Give me a shot. As if this is safer.
I think I actually is, though.
Lulululu...
Okay.
Why am I so premature
with my fricking actions?
Man...
I could have sworn.
Okay, let's try that again. Let him get...let me get up. Let me go.
There! As everyone is my witness, I am on it.
Right, so what's up here? Okay, it is definitely
a lot faster just to go the other way. I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, that's a jump down on water.
We have an ability to jump down that way if we still desire.
So then water's over here.
Yeah.
Shadow Wizard money. Oh, I can't do it.
I'm gonna need a cup of tea and I'm gonna...
I'm gonna need a fricking cup of tea.
I'm nuking this...I'm nuking this place into oblivion.
Yeah, that's what you get.
Do I even have anything that does damage?
Put me on fire, will you? Yeah, bam!
Didn't even insult me like that. Right, what we got? What we got? What's the...
A dungeon map? Well, I didn't even need it.
Thanks anyway.
Yeah, you're no grabbing me.
You're no grabbing me. Good luck.
No, no! Get me up the stairs.
Get up the stairs, get up the stairs, get up the stairs, get up the stairs.
Oh, why so many?
A child's game, by the way.
Right, fuck it, we're jumping over here.
I don't know why we're jumping over here, but we're just going for it.
We're sending it. Oh, okay, I'll take that.
You now have three. Just collect one more and we'll get another unlock.
We've got a city to burn. Scottish Rage Charging. No, no, I'm calm.
I'm calm, I'm calm. Oh, I have to go down.
Okay, I'll go down.
See, you're not the only one that can jump your bams, honestly.
Right, we went left, so now we have to go right.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't even know where we are.
A freaking rock.
At least I got a kingstone piece. Where the heck are we?
Oh, fuck, fucks sake!
We have fucking offerty.
What the fuck do I need to go? Right, not that way.
We'll go all the way back.
As if you guys respawn!
Yeah, we're definitely
exploring. I'm getting like full health.
No, no, not the fire though, not the fire though. As long as I don't get the fire,
because as soon as you get given the fire, right.
You perish. Alright, I know what to do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come on.
Get in, get me in.
Oh my god, how much health do you have?
Ay, yay, yay!
Followed me at the convention like...
Jeez, I'm getting absolutely wrecked.
This is probably the hardest...
This has to be the hardest part of the game.
Bro, this is getting outrageous.
Oh, please don't run off the map, Link.
I know your arse is on fire, but please...
For me, for me, Link. For me, Linky-Poo.
Whatever the heck is this wizard?
That's the spells.
Oh my god, right.
There's a bomb that has to go here, I'm pretty sure.
This is the worst. Literally, I have to admit, like, all of a sudden, this is, like, tedious.
No game developer wants your game to be...
Huh?
Am I not?
Oh, I have to...
Easy.
Easy, I'm just...
Wow, I'm so skinny.
Actually so skinny, so I had to hold my breath for that when I was like...
I had to suck in, I had to go...
Oh, there's the door! We're, like, right at the boss fight!
I don't think I'm...
It doesn't matter.
Okay, we're right at the boss fight.
We can do it! We're so close, replay! We're so freaking close!
Right, so I don't need to do anything here.
What do I need to do then?
Oh!
See you, jumping on my head.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, hug someone else. Where's my hug?
Huh?
I think I got another.
What is it?
I need to go back already.
Wait, what's going on over here then?
Hold on, I've missed something. I've missed a...
I've missed a vital clue. What have I missed?
A boomerang? Can boomerang even go over?
Hello?
Hit the switch with a bomb.
As if that was the move!
That wasn't even on the same pixel tail, like...
That wasn't even on the same tail! How is that supposed to figure that out?
Oh my god, they're paling me with money as a sorry.
I need to drop down?
Am I going crazy?
I have to go up
in order to go down, but only up and a little to the left.
Okay...
Up and a little to the left, so there's something to the...that can fall down up here.
But I need to fall down on the left side.
I come friend, I come friend!
I'm learning, going!
I need to fall here.
Oh!
I'm so fucking smart! And this game is just proving how smart I am.
Alright, stop charging bro. I can't hit you if you're charging me.
I can't hit you if you're charging me and I'm not full health.
Oh! Bro! You're not even in the same tail as me!
Glowy.
I'm going to start dropping bombs.
And the Legend of Zelda. The hit video game.
Legend of Zelda.
Well, I didn't...
Can I just shoot?
Link, sorry.
Alright, how do I...
Just jump?
Oh! How am I supposed to make a mini jump?
A mini jump.
Okay, we did it, we did it.
Shadow Wizard minigame. We look.
Oh, I fucked that one up, didn't I?
Yes, I fucked that one up.
That was fine, I'll reset when we go up.
I think this is the ball?
I think?
Please be easier. Oh my god, we're still going?
Give it a break!
Alright, sorry, sorry, sorry.
I've got one fairy to my aid.
I just need to not mess this up.
Let's not mess this up. We should watch you play a puzzle game.
It just ends up with me swearing.
Okay, okay. I'm already seeing something that I need to.
Some. Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Phase 1 already complete, question mark?
Phase 1 complete, question mark. Please let me on.
Do I need to get on? I don't know. Is that supposed to jump on that?
I don't know. Nope.
I'm not...
What do you want from me?
What do you want from me? What do you want from me? Do you want me to get on you? I don't know. Oh, okay.
You've just killed me. I just refused to let me on you.
Maybe I was supposed to jump on you? How is I supposed to know that?
How is I supposed to know that?
It's fine. I didn't need the HP.
So the blue guy is not friendly.
Go on and fucking spam it!
I didn't do it. Oh, I didn't do it.
Hold on. Hold on. I'm fucking dodging me. I'm fucking dodging.
Wait, hold on. I don't want him to get me.
Okay, here we go. Now jump on his back.
Jump on blue. Okay, I'm on blue.
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. You like that? You like that? You see that?
Power and skill. Jump! Okay, it's fine. It's fine. I've got a fairy.
I've got a fairy. I've got a fairy.
Why the heck are there so many? I don't even remember.
You need to jump. Please jump. Oh my god, please. Please.
Please. Please! Why is he doing backflips?
Fuck it!
No! The HP can't take anymore!
I might lose this. I'm not going to lie. I'm actually released.
I'm not confident. I'm not confident.
But that's not going to stop me. That's not going to stop me. Jump on his back.
Okay, completely miss his back. It's fine. Okay, jump on his back.
Okay, okay. Easy. Easy. Easy.
Easy. Easy. Take it. No! Don't jump! Why would it not be
sequenced to his freaking back? Why would you do that?
Why would you do that? Get... Oh, I'm going to need calling a fairy.
Get on his back right now. Jeez, love.
Right, bro. If the game doesn't put me on his back, what do you actually want me to do?
What do you want me...
We ain't going to do it. I think I'm actually going to die here. Oh my god.
Stop! He keeps, like, purposely going away.
Oh, get to fuck. Oh my god, did we do it?
Oh, thanks again for dropping me. No, it's fine.
I didn't want to win. It's fine.
Child's game, by the way. Child's game, by the way!
And you just nuked my freaking allies.
Ooh, it actually doesn't really seem
to matter what... Oh my god, we did it.
Don't ever make me do that again. Why was that so hard?
My hands were sweating. My hands are literally sweating
so much right now. Why was that so hard?
Oh. Oh, it's a snail.
That's wind?
Is that wind? Why would the wind look like that? Shouldn't it not be, like,
a cloud or, like, three little wings? You got the wind element!
The wind carries the seeds of flowers scattering life across the lands.
That's called wind dispersal on seeds. The wind element is the embodiment
of that power. Yeah, me, though!
Okay, we now have even more health, which I will take.
Get me out here. Get me out.
At last, we've got all four elements. Let's go
revive the sacred blade. Now this is where everything goes to
Judy Kaka. Bruh, I need a victory
cup of tea after that. I'm not even kidding. I need a victory cup of tea.
Hello, Elder. Now would you like to fuse?
Poster check.
Currently a shrimp, the way I like it.
A chest in the graveyard?
Yeah, yeah. I'll take it. I'll take it.
Oh, they fit perfectly. Right. There's a tornado at the top of the winds.
Receive the blade. I already did. I thought her dialogue was going to change, actually.
Okay, I'll get ready. No, no, no.
Kaka. Oh, we can trade with you as well. You want green.
We destroyed like a billion monsters that need green. Or that drop green, sorry.
Yes, I am going
to basically do all the side stuff. Like,
no. We'll play gacha. How about that? We'll play gacha
for a bit.
You guys have so much money. Thank you. Thank you, thank you.
I'm going to upgrade our quiver size, not to be confused
with you quivering last night to
my audio. Thank you. Thank you. I'll be here all week. That's not even funny.
Oh. Well, when I said it wasn't funny, you didn't have to actually
announce that it wasn't funny. Okay.
Mate, when I explore before, yes, I absolutely will.
Where do we start?
Like, where do we start? Tomato, tomato.
There's still a few things you need but to fill store, but no, everything. Yes. Okay, the
town hasn't gone to Shisa yet. So, I'm actually
right. We have the cape.
How the fuck do you get in here?
I don't know how I get that. But yes,
there is like, all the
weasels floating about on itself. Do everything you've done before you completely
hit the sword because this is the point of no return.
I already did him and he gave me a heart, I'm pretty sure.
The door's shut. We can't open it from the side.
Why can't he open it from any other side either? Alright, let me upgrade our quiver size.
Oh, the quiver. Yes, that.
Kin stone the door, most likely. You are a big
gender. There's a way you get in that house.
Right. Oh, are we laundry?
Hi, Link. If you have an empty ball, I can put one of my charms
inside. Oh, that's cute.
Oh, something red, so it's something good.
You have to get every figure in
the gacha. What does a butterfly do?
What does a butterfly do?
I don't know. Oh, she's got to be laundry.
Oh, wait, you're that ghost. I met your brother.
Don't worry, I'm already looking for another job.
Oh.
I think we can also learn a new technique
because we've got the cape now. Imagine watching like, I don't know
how old Link is lore-wise, but imagine watching like a 12 year old jump
of it with a cape. You have the cape. You have acquired a new skill.
I'm ready to train you. Yes, I would like to train, please. Now I will teach you how to take three.
The down thrust. First, equip the cape. Second, equip the sword.
Jump, and then at your jump's peak, thingy. Yes, I understand.
You see it, do you not? What does it do? I must possess you.
Oh, no.
Oh, I like that.
Wait. Hold on a minute.
Am I not AB?
Okay, there we go. Sorry, sorry to be a little second there.
My apologies, my apologies. Please do not look at me in the eyes. I'm
rather embarrassed with that move. Joy butterfly's appear.
Catch a joy, increase Link's speed while digging, swimming, or shooting. Oh, okay.
There's nothing more I can teach you. Now you must train yourself. Okay, we can now go to the other
masters to get trained up. Right, we'll do some gachapon,
since we actually need to do it in order to get full
health. Are you guys feeling lucky?
Oh, hello. Yeah, trade. I really
wish you could do it all in one go, and before we get like another one that we already have.
Gambit time.
Down throws. Big octa rock.
Octa rock is such a good ASMR trigger word.
Octa rock, octa rock, octa rock. I'll be saying that in my next
ASMR video. Octa rock.
Gambit time. What are we going to get?
What are we going to get? We're going to get Percy.
Which I didn't actually solve his problem. I'm pretty sure he doesn't have access
to his house or something.
If you put extra in it increases your odds of not getting a duplicate. I don't want
to burn through it too much. Although
we do seem to be getting like tons of stuff anyway.
Strony calling you a good octa rock ASMR win. Oh no, I never looked.
Oh, I wasn't paying attention. Sorry, I didn't see what we just unlocked there.
I like your outfit, Strony. Thanks. I didn't model
it myself. I had no say.
But I like the bikini.
With the tape kind of thing. Okay, we got rope.
Not to be confused with Chibi.
T minus seven minutes until your beloved milfs are live together.
Playing the most predictable game of all.
Jelly bean game.
I'm actually a big fan of color combinations. I'm drawing you right now. Oh yeah?
You like my green? My vert? Is this in French or vert?
It's vert. 91% probability.
Look, 90% is not really high. Anything above 50% is like a one and two.
Although then again, you guys did see my luck.
The third time I freaking got it. Yeah, you better buy that
freaking figurine. At least you get money if you pull up the same thing again.
And what happened?
Exactly.
I can't. Oh!
The great dragonfly.
Dragonfly Vechiver? I'm actually
kind of down. Dragonfly Vechiver.
How would she look?
Would she have a toggle to open up her wings?
I mean, I like that. Dragonfly Vechiver.
I don't think I've heard of a dragonfly Vechiver. Oh, the forest bakori.
Very elegant and ladylike. Would a dragonfly
be a milf? Wait a minute!
The dragonfly would be a milf because if you didn't know, dragonflies are the most successful
predator.
Oh my god, I need someone who's in a shot or corner to play her.
Oh, that would be outrageous.
Yeah, that's
fucked. Yeah, that'd be outrageous. But that's funny as fuck.
And before I even put, oh, I'm triggered. Oh, go fuck off me.
I'm just leaving about. I've actually been getting in a model in Wings and 3D. Dragonfly
Vechiver. Munker.
Hire me, I'll do it, I'll do it.
A to A, geez, the probability going down.
As long as it's not a blight. A little too far. Oh, all right. Okay, okay.
My bad. Speaking of dragonfly.
So he gives me five rupees every time I have a duplicate, which I should be the goose.
Prey and Mantis Vechiver.
They don't have, I don't like Prey and Mantis.
Not far enough.
Oh, it's Mama's Cafe. This is the best place
in Tentorite. She can also pick up some good tips. I actually love this
little cute save mission thing. It's actually really sweet. I know it's not
like, sweet, sweet, but.
87%
Not far enough.
For anyone who is lurking and is like,
what on earth are you doing? We have finally unlocked all the items
in the Legend of Zelda Minish Cap and we are currently just doing all the side missions
because if we progress the story any further, basically
everything goes to Judi Kaka and it's not very
nice section of the game and the game unfortunately
is one of those games that reverts back every time you load up the same save.
So the town will not be restored and
you'll constantly have the ability to do the boss fight type thing.
And I'd rather have it fun time.
The Wind Tribe. God, this is so like 9.
I wonder how long development took on this game. I feel like a lot of love went into it.
You know, a lot of love, a lot of hard work tears.
I never heard anything bad about the development of Game Boy games, to be honest.
But then again, I guess back then you never really ask those kind of questions.
Like, oh, is, you know,
how was development? How is this? How is that? Like it was all insider thingy.
But now like development teams in that are being so open and honest
and like saying like this is what's happening, this is what we're doing next, the type thing.
It came, it took Nintendo two years to come up with this beautiful game.
That's fantastic. It really is
a beautiful game. Really, really.
I love it.
They're paying you rupees for
JPEGs, honestly. I think this came out. Pina
Hyrule's Fruit Vendor. She hates vegetables. She won't even sell
tomatoes even though they technically are fruits. Freak!
Oh my god, Nintendo!
Steady on, some folk just dinny like certain palettes. You know, everyone's tongues a wee bit different.
Oh my god, that is a Nintendo.
Well, literally, they're
brutal. They like their fresh veggies.
Mayor Hagen, the mayor of the town of Hyrule, he's a big collector of odd mass.
He's built a shelter in his garden just in case monsters attack Hyrule.
He knew. Is he a body?
She a fur diver. Every time I hear that I am
Jingle, I'm the last one trailing off forever.
Meeps.
Nintendo went crazy for that one. Hagen Love, you liked that the mayor
of the town does nothing? Oh, and Eni and Meenie,
the high-reliant vegetable growing in their fields are exquisitely delicious.
Apparently, Brocco sells some of their crops.
They've got like little lore for all the townsfolk. Oh come on, give me a game
where it's about restoring a town, please. I'd love it. I'd go absolutely.
Oh, there's this game that's coming out that's called like...
It's like a hotel game. You run it.
Oh, Stockwell and his wee pup. Oh my god, he's called
Stockwell because he's well-stocked.
There's this hotel coming out, but it's like
you're playing Vampire or something.
And I don't know if it's in Early Access right now
or they're about to do Early Access.
Sheebie is live. Is there a...
Ezlo has Link, a young boy on a quest with Ezlo to restore the four
swords with the sword's power he hopes to remove the curse of Princess Zelda.
Join Sheebie and Ezra live on Fall Games.
Yes, if you want to play with Sheepsters and Ezra on Fall Guys,
you can do that right now. I kid you not, they are doing it right now.
As long as you don't mess up tea.
Yes, we are literally just playing
Zelda and finishing the main quest
and all that today. I don't know how long it's going to take. I thought it was only
going to take four hours, but considering we're at the two hour mark
and I've made no progress, um, yeah.
It's fine. It's fine. This might be a little bit of an
endurance stream. Dr. Le, a gruff talking academic type who says
he's studying the PCORI. He doesn't seem to be aware that they're actually living in his own house.
Aw. If you're looking for an older RPG
that has rebuilding, look into... look at Dark...
look at Dark Cloud or Dark Chronicle. Oh, I love like the repair
ability in Assassin's Creed Brotherhood and Assassin's Creed 2.
You get to like repair either Monty Regione
or Rigatoni, whatever you want to call it.
Scissorblades, that's actually a pretty good name for them. Or you get to repair like
Roma and I really like that aspect of like fixing it up and like the environment
changes as you fix stuff up and like you go on quest to do it.
I would absolutely love to develop some kind of game around that.
I've not met you yet.
A great butterfly... oh no, in the Minish Woods.
I have met you.
Oh, I didn't realize the fairies were different types.
Like a dragonfly, a butterfly. So what's the... is it the blue one I've not
met yet? No progress blasts through that part of the game.
I mean, we got the last elemental, that's all we need.
Past that coded...
Bro just said Rigatoni. Oh, sugar, that was a joy butterfly.
I probably could have read that, honestly, but...
We're trying to get through it. What's our percentage now?
75%, ooh. It's getting low.
How low can you go? How low can you go?
Not exactly retro, but Bastion has a little bit of that and it's a good game.
I haven't played Bastion.
I don't... the only Bastion I've played is...
Shoulda picked Mercy. Shoulda picked any kind of support.
We ended up losing. All your fault, your tears are what I
live for.
Leaver appears in Wild Runes real full. These baddies
are really underground. You never know where they might pop up. Keep your shield raised and ready.
Your race will win, Stan. I wanna be Winston.
Uh...
Lucky 2. Lucky 2 appears in the sky.
I can't move, but they throw lightning bolts, steal their clothes with the gust star.
Oh, like how it actually gives you a base on how it flew.
Oh, Monkers. Monkers, I've got DMs in the discord. What does it mean?
Um...
Oh, okay, it's just one of the girls requesting something.
That's fine.
And Shibi might be cooking up something that I wholeheartedly support.
So I might need to get her a few assets for that, which is perfectly fine.
My apologies, a little bit distracted.
I can't believe it.
Shibi, unbelievably, came up with a concept that I
actually was considering.
But it wasn't possible for me to do it
because of timing issues, I didn't have enough time to pursue such a project.
However, Shibi just came out with it and I was like...
I've not told her that I actually had an interest in that,
but I will 100% support it if she's interested in it. I'm not really sure how to go about it though,
because it's a bit hot to track down.
But yes, we'll see. We'll see how it goes.
You just killed him, I did.
Please read it out loud. No, I can!
Don't get me wrong, I'm a blabbermouth. I can hardly hide anything that I'm interested in.
But that is not a project that a
beetle appears in various areas.
It is not for me to spill beans about.
I spill many beans, and I flick many.
But that's not for me.
Probably 50% and then we'll take a break, I'll go get a honey tea because my wee voice box is already...
Oh, Nairu!
Nairu, she's looking for a house in Hyrule to move into. She's a descendant from a line of oracles
of the land of Labriana. I'm going to say that's probably a reference to another
Zeldor game that I've not played.
Yes, probability 50% and then we'll have a quick break. Beans and tea
all over. Oh, okay.
Vacuum pumped beans, no thank.
Do you have anything cooking which not even the girls know about?
Oh, I've already heard that one. Um, that the girls don't know about?
I have monthly events.
I did post the old monthly events, but some of them are outdated
and can no longer be utilized. Oh no, our probability dropped.
We'll have to get two in a row that we've had.
So, in July
is
Minecraft server with the girls.
The video game comes out as long as we don't hit any issues.
Aw, peaceful Hyrule.
I love that I just got back and you're talking about our flicking beans.
Oh no, I'm not. Broly legend. I'm talking about beans on toast.
Cause I'm British.
Thank you for the tip of the super chat. I'll take it.
Is the Minecraft server going to have mods or be vanilla?
I think Emmy might want it to have mods. I always like vanilla, but
it's up to her.
I guess it's up to her. Whatever she wants to do.
Shaders are instance based, so she puts shaders on.
I don't have to see it. 68% on probability.
We're getting there. We're getting lower.
And after yesterday, I thought Stranny wasn't vanilla. I'm not that bad.
I didn't think it was that bad.
What was that?
Just...
When does the Veil or Game come out and where can I purchase it?
It is free to play. It will come out on itch.io and you will know about it.
Ah, sugar! We're really starting to hit the
repeats.
Since you said you wanted vanilla Minecraft.
Azura's Dona Thon is the event
for August, although I am going to try and ask
if a VTuber that does game shows will host a
game show for us. I just need to get all the assets together.
If you didn't know, in order to have a high acceptability
rate on collabs, if you do all the work, people are much more likely
to accept.
I currently have to do that and put it all together.
I basically have to reach out and be like, hey, do you want to host all the Veil
or girls in a collab? None of us will stream it, so you'll get all the views.
Oh, by the way, I've actually planned out the entirety of the game show, so all you have
to do is take these assets and files and put them where they belong
and then you get to have everything.
Yeah, basically. So I'm going to try and get that done. I don't know if
they're going to accept the person that I do want to
host it is going to accept.
Because they are incredibly busy with projects
all the time. But you know what,
in this world, if you don't ask and be a cheeky shit,
you don't get... I was talking to Hexa
because she was going to do a watch along, but she felt ill
or she had to go to hospital and all of that. And I just checked up on her
and I was like, I hope you're doing all right now. And I was like, I know this is cheeky
but do you want to do an ASMR collab? And she was like, fuck you. And I'm like, oh, okay, shit.
Like, if you don't ask and you don't get in this world, people might be
like, I'm so embarrassed to be rejected by someone for not doing a collab or whatever.
Bruv. Bruv. Either they'll say yes or no.
And guess what? If they say no, that's not a reflection of your character, that's not a reflection
of your work, that's not a reflection of your content. Someone
might just know before it and that's okay. Like, then you'd be afraid
to put yourself out there. Like, literally, I've got what? Six ASMR
collabs planned? I mean, I'm about to reach out
to more folk. Aww. Cat-less Link.
I hate that I put Link in all caps now. This is killing me
on the inside. ASMR in the hospital
but you missed 100%. No, she's not in hospital, then who? Will there
be a link on Discord? Actually, I don't know.
Discord. I can't...
The main viewer on Twitter can't talk about it but all the girls
alts can talk about it.
But yeah, then there's
another seven ASMR
collab coming out. Well, there's actually three more in the works. I'm waiting for this
animator to come back because they're taking their
sweet arse time and it's kind of just holding up the old
Oh, Farori. Farori, she's looking for a house. We're sure to got one.
Looking for a man in finance.
Eh, right. Want to do... What percentage are we at?
When can I make my cup of tea? 62%.
Okay, we're getting there. Once we hit 50%, cup of tea time. Do I make
myself clear? You will all get up, you will all stretch your legs, you will all go
and poop poop. Well, I don't know how fast you can go a poop poop.
We're at 100 rupees because we're absolutely burning through it.
Sadly, you cannot give all three a house.
I know! It's absolutely nonsense. And I
realise I actually shouldn't have put that green girl in a house because her reward
is she can dye your clothes a certain colour
but we're already green. So why does she even offer that as a reward?
Who knows?
One of them. We're at 61%. Let's go, let's go, let's go.
I already have popcorn. Do I have to stretch? Yes, everyone has to stretch.
What? Goron merchant. Oh no!
I just realise we haven't helped that poor Goron. Right, we're going to do it.
He needs more buddies. We'll get more buddies. I think what we'll do is we'll take
everything like one at a time.
60% we're getting down to the 50s.
The 90s.
A mountain pokori! Does it mention their Scottish?
Their song is actually a saying that they are fully fledged mountain
minish now. Oh. Ting, ting, ting along.
Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun. What are we at? We're at 59.
Oh, we're at 59. We're getting there.
You can choose.
You can have, close whatever colour you want as long as it's green basically.
You have to choose the buff to win. You already helped him twice.
I know but doesn't he not end up with like six pals or something at one point?
I basically need to dig in all the mobiles and then trade
a Kinstone with the walls. I'm like 100% sure that's how
we got his first buddy. I just got you so
don't do that again. This is why we don't catch her.
Get your phone, get your phone. How many would you like to see?
How many would you like to see? Wager one.
Does Scotland have mountains? Yeah, we have Ben Nevis.
It is the highest mountain and a young woman
tends to her cuckoos. If you help her, gather, she'll give you
a reward. Yes, she will give money.
Yes, there is a mountain called Ben Nevis
in Scotland and people climb it. I don't think
it is definitely not severe. Don't you think it's Mount Everest or anything like that?
It's definitely not severe. But Scotland's very hilly.
Wheaton and pitta. The couple baked bread and high roll.
Their tasty pastries hold a secret. If you're extra lucky, they'll be a helpful item inside.
I like that.
Poor Goron having to rely on wishes to get some
pals. Oh no! Oh!
The Vealur account finally tweeted out all our mascots and I could see everyone
together. Did you know Snowberry's mascots are actually the
tallest and biggest out of us all? Out of the
reflames, the snippets, etc. I think it goes
um
Who's the smallest? I think Pin Pals. Then
the... Oh no!
Hold on. Herum,
Pin Pals, reflames, snippets,
bleeding hearts, and
Snowberries in size. So we... Snowberries are the
biggest out of us all. They're big boy.
No, reflames aren't the smallest. There was a
height chart created. I'll need to ask the
freaking concept artist. Um, because
Emmy, some of you caught it, but
Emmy's loading screen on her background music was the
mascot that was concepted, but she made her
Pin Pals the way they look now. So I had to get an updated loading screen
and all that like very quickly. But her background
music, it was too late. We didn't have time
to alter it because we had those assets. There was
a miscommunication with the asset maker
Yumi. Yumi's fantastic by the way. I absolutely loved working with her.
But there was a miscommunication. I was like, hey, the deadline's
May 1st. And she thought the deadline was June 1st
and I'm like, no, that was the debut date and it caused
a bit of a back walk. Um, but we actually had
that issue. I had that issue with a lot of artists who were making assets.
Ball and Chain Soldier, whatever you CBT your way off the map because
they didn't want to see you again. I had a lot of issues when
the debut date was announced
to be June 1st.
All artists either saw
that and went, oh, I can take my time with my work.
And it was like, no, I'm still asking
for you to do it by the deadline I gave you, which was more than fair.
But everyone unanimously. So if you're an artist that worked with us and you're listening
right now, don't feel bad because everyone fricking did it.
And everything backlogged to May.
My birthday was actually supposed to be when I was making shorts for everyone
and that didn't happen. I was also supposed to pre-make
all my like, thank you ASMRs, that didn't happen.
Because everything got clogged into me.
So it was a fricking developmental nightmare. My mother's birthday.
Yeah, June 1st.
My birthday now, get wrecked. I don't know.
You know, in the last dungeon, honestly. Your deadline is like, do not force me to move.
Yes, I was not budging on debut.
I'm sorry. I was not delaying any further.
Man, miss the reflins, okay? I needed to be
at my reflins the rose.
Sorry.
Sorry, I can't, I can't
say what I'm doing right now.
Wait, back to Gambo.
It's spain, everything's spain.
Everything's spain.
Everything is spain.
Everything's cool when you're part of the team.
You're almost at 8k, I bloody hope not.
I was like, I'll be able to get the clap
and ASMR out right now.
Music
Sorry, I'll make a cup of tea in a minute
51% on the thing
Stony would be the killest boss ever
No, I know how I'm feeling right now. I'd be a terrible boss then
I
Yes
right 51% on the
percentage over Gacha, please do not gamble. Yes, I am going to try and
I
Was extinct steamed from stand
Sorry, sorry
Azura and sheepsters is playing
Fall guys if you want to join them live you most certainly can we are gacha pointing until 50% which we are at so I can go make a honey tea
We have been released from our percentage
Wonder I wonder how low we can actually how low can you wait?
So does that mean we have 50 gacha now? We're like over halfway there. Oh, yeah, the probability is 49% now
Wait, so this is terrible to gamble below the rate. This is all gonna be repeats. Is it not now?
Yeah, I was gonna say now that we're below 50%
We have to do well, we're gonna be rich on rupees we have 125 rupees. Sorry my hair's in the way
You can't see it
Great, I pull that lever. Well, if only you could do it automatically. I wish I could feed it in like a
Is it it's called a pachinko machine?
and
I wish I could do it
Still statistically better than one all in
They aren't even plain been
They've been waiting for people for like 20 minutes
As if there's not enough stream snappers to play as if
Yes, we already had that we've gonna go on a hundred and thirty rupees long
They were late to tell people they could join so now others have to download the game. Oops
Chat to scare to play with the veal or girls. I was gonna say you guys are too scared to go against two mills
What's going on here?
Hey, you should you quaking in your little boots, huh?
Hey, little ball sack trembling at the thought of the the superiority that they have over you
Come on now. Don't be scared of them
Yeah, I don't have it installed. Why do you get a lot of replants?
How have you not got that game installed? No fool will appears in dungeons the clinical walls normal tax may not work for the boomerangs
It's pretty effective and they spawn in a fairy. No, I'm literally downloading as we speak, but internet
Or is the internet absolutely wrecking and decking. It's trembling, but that's no way
How many likes did my cheeky voice click? Yeah, I'm allowed to ask
I was embarrassed by like, oh my god, how many people have interacted with that?
I was actually someone drew me caught up in rope and I was gonna like rate my little cringy paragraph
But I want to do something slightly different
This time around and I might be able to have time to do it after this stream if I don't go too crazy
I'm still getting home from work
Oh, yeah
You can't play with the moves
Wait, does fall guys have cross play with console?
um
700 lights. Oh my god
Reflint stop
Yeah, the shabari picture. Yeah, so it's gonna do a cringe thing. That's it
Wow
Right, we need to actually get all of these in order to get that last heart. So I think we're committing
We might be committing here and like running our bank dry
Now I know I can increase the odds by increasing the shells, but we're gonna run out of shells long before that
um
Fall guys supports cross play. Okay. Well, there you go. If you've got a console apparently you can do a cheeky stream
Okay
Yes, I already have that figurine unfortunately
If I got a figurine
Would you guys halt glue it for me?
I don't know why people find it disgusting actually find it pretty good. I really don't mind it
If I had a wee Willy winky, I'd ink all the way your staff, but all you'll spill it
Yes. Yes. Okay. It feels good, man
Oh, sorry. I'm just putting a laser beam off in your freaking shop. Do excuse me
I mean there's already the acrylic
I ordered the kitchen
And I was so excited for them to arrive and then I could show my hands again
Well, just in an ASMR video
Unfortunately my french tip is starting to grow out so it doesn't look very nice
Um, but that's not gonna stop me
Uh, if if it looks I don't know how to take off gel because
Someone said that if you try to take gel off at home, you create like mustard gas in your own freaking hoost or something like that
Um
Wizard robes get in my face
Yeah, that stuff does not come off nicely with home put
Yeah, like I don't want to go back to the well, obviously I can't because I'm a freaking tool
but um, I was literally just gonna let it all grow off and like cut my nails as
Like it got like too long. I assume I can cut it without like creating mustard gas
Or is it gonna be too hard to cut?
Actually that reminds me. I need to make uh your tap in ASMR
um
Because when you have like hard acrylic nails the ASMR comes out so much better. Yeah, it costs fine. Okay, that's fine
Don't make this bleed to our money. Oh, that's mustard gas. Yeah. You have to wait from a growing up. Yeah, that's fine. I don't I don't mind that
Oh
All of these self-transformants have the fighting tournament at the PCORI festival for they are the great potential
Oh, they see great potential in blink
Oh, that's fantastic. Wait, so we've not even met all of the masters yet
Okay, how many have we gone through we've not even gone through a hundred pools yet. Jeez
Um
Stroney, I will literally do anything you ask. Oh
Yes, I am waiting for the key chains and then I can do like uh
Maybe just be like a regular ASMR video
But I'll just tap on everything and start like tapping on the girls faces and their wee key chains and that
I think I'm so cute. It's a coin name
And I'll be like this is this is in me and this is a zero and this is a circle and this is sheepsters
um
I've probably said it but I gave the girls nicknames long before they had glee rock
Appears in the cavern of flames a glee rock has a hard rocky shale and mount carino hating and lava
I thoroughly enjoyed him as a boss. I think that was a really good boss
Didn't enjoy the jumpy jumpy boss ear tempo. That was not really for me to be honest
Well, I'm to stop and after 50 percent. I'm addicted
I lose 100 percent of the gacha. I don't pool
See even though we're now at 180 coins. I started at like less than 100 for the duplication
Same I will do many many things to make Johnny
You you being happy makes me happy. I don't need nothing else
Other than a smile on your goofy face
Maybe maybe if I'm really really well behaved. I might even get a giggle out. Yeah a little hee hee
Happiness feedback. Oh, yeah
Oh
Minish Vati before he became a sorcerer
He was a simple minish. He had always been entranced by the evil that lives in the hearts of men
There's not evil in the hearts of men must catch a gambler stop before winning big literally be with the next one
Shawnee does your model have any pierce things?
My model doesn't have the pierce things. Um
Originally my bikini toggle was actually gonna have indents to show
I I'm
to show the pierce things
but um
It got there was a few there was a few development on the show. So it's like such a small detail that it doesn't matter
Um
Do you have any pierce things? I did
I don't have any facial pierce things
I don't have any ear pierce things
The rest is up to you
Oh god, we're at 41 percent. This is getting bitey. Only the fun one
Um, oh
A mayfly the great mayfly fairy on mount crannel. She provides you a larger bomb bag. Oh wait, so I have seen her
So I've not seen the green fly fairy wherever a dragon fly fairy. Sorry green flies
A belly no
I see was actually supposed to have a belly piercing in her development art
You'll see it. If you didn't see the exposed room. She's doing a short about it
You know for 40 percent
Catch a chance. We're winning pretty big right now. Hold on. We're on a good streak. Let's not forget
I forgot we're going to play this game. I'm like, don't worry. Don't worry
Um, we are at the stage before everything goes to our chaos
So an armpit piercing
Um, we are currently just gacha pawning out the wazoo because apparently we need all 100 percent gachas
A in order to get access to a heart that we'll need so we can have full life
Every gacha pill layer with cell is a little cap a strange creature that looks at first like a cap
He speaks roughly and treats link like a child, but he actually really likes link. Oh
Bum piercing got it. Why some surprise? I don't know. I've never heard of an armpit piercing. Oh 37 percent as rough
40 percent is nearly 50 50 totally worth it. Spoken like a true gamble
Spoken like a true gamble
A bunny. No, my bunny is not pierced. I absolutely would not have anything near it
I do not have a a slight comprehension of the
desirability
to
Oh
No
A bunny. Absolutely not. Are you joking? Why are we talking about piercings?
Because I may or may not have some piercings. Do you want to hear it? Oh, hold on
I think you may be able to hear it if I mute the in-game audio
Hold on
You may be able to hear this
Do you hear that from a little nail against it?
There you go that one's for you
Ah
Tapping it. Oh, should I do tapping ASMR?
Piercing tapping ASMR. Would you guys be done for that?
That would actually be kind of hilarious
Well, let's pray obvious then and you trigger on lot. Oh, yes. Oh my god, right. I'll record that because that's hilarious
Piercing tapping ASMR, wink, wink, nudge, nudge
Yes
Did you just? Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah, I did
Oh, I know our gacha nightmares. We're now at 200 rupees. He we're actually starting to really run into it
Can we tap it for you in the ASMR?
Great. Now pull that lever. I'm pulling it
New unlocked someone is wearing only a hoodie again. No
Maybe
Yeah, like I had I had a good time yesterday. I do not deserve to wear a bra right now a bra
So
I've been wanting you to make piercing taps. That's funny
Well, you got your wish because I can make it super easily
I need to make the tummy rumble in ASMR as well ASMR lying on your girlfriend's stomach, but it won't
I
That'll probably be my next like meme ASMR. I'm not really sure it's a thank you ASMR. I think it's a more of a meme ASMR
Only wearing a hoodie nothing else. Yeah, I don't even I don't even have socks on
Heartbeat ASMR when you want to hear my heartbeat
It's not very relaxing
But honestly, do you want me to talk during it or do you just want like breathing?
And heartbeat because of where the mic is placed you can hear like what I breathe and in the other ear quite well when it's against me
It's not going good. It's not going well. We're getting absolutely rigged
I think I asked for taps on the last day
Socks are the tool of Satan. I honestly don't mind socks because it kind of contains the sweat
Out of curiosity is a picture. I'm going to be audios or will the rest of the stuff
Or when or will you and the rest of the girls we do and other stuff?
Um, definitely like early access to meme stuff is
Like for me early access or like youtube archive to my audios perfectly fine
Um, as for other stuff. No, it's like audio based content
Talking to please and we talk
Oh, no
Yeah, I'm feeling this percentage probability debuff. This is getting rough
They're one in three now. We're at one in three
With how hot it is over by me me we're in
Even we're in a hoodie. That's worth. Okay. We got it. We got it one in three one in three
Cry at ranting during the heartbeat ranting about what came what see this catcher game and legend is elder
Yeah, freaking probability dropping down to the floor. I bet you probably the probability will be one by the time we're done with it
and
The wind tried
The wind sure
Renting about whatever conspiracies on your mind that day
Oh, I have a really controversial one but might filter people
But then it means more of the tight-knit community. Maybe it's win-win
I
Strongly be movie script when absolutely not I have no desire for that
I've seen that meme done a few times as well, but if the meme's been done before I might
Whereas like
I I don't want to say anything but I have to admit I've never looked up clapping without
Clapping ASMR, but without my hands before like I think that's funny as heck, you know
And then again, it's probably already made and it's sitting on youtube
Shawnee always does the filter and yeah, I do it myself. Don't worry. We demand the filter
Okay, so you know how there's been abortion bans
It's absolutely nothing to do about religion or anything or any of that crap
A mold worm appears in minish roads
They come out of the ground when they sense free if you get swallowed you'll take damage get all dirty
Watch out because when you're dirty
I've never seen that enemy
and
It's about like it's about
Raising the population because the population is crashing right now
And what happens when a population crashes? Oh, you can't have infinite growth
No infinite growth for you capitalist cogs. No, no, no, no
Um, so that's why bond reception and abortions are being outlawed because we need slaves
We need poor
Because you know who benefits from abortions and all that stuff
People who are not in a position financially and responsibly to raise children. That's who benefits from that really
and
Embryo and all that
So yeah, um
We need more cogs in the capitalist machine
so
Yeah, again, capital is interesting
because yeah, um because of the nature of
Of um development as well. So if you think two generations back your grandparents will say
I had seven brothers and sisters and then your mum and dad
They had three brothers and sisters and then your mum and dad had
I produced you solo because at the rate of success
You don't need to farm all these children popping out at you willy-nilly
So the population is heading for a crash landing
fair
Uh ace more running about capitalism
Me mum's the youngest of 11. How many are you gonna have those the question?
because
Statistically it goes big party a big party big family medium family
Uh, and we're we're heading to one to zero territory. Actually. No, we're already in zero territory
Isn't south korea zero point four for the replacement rate for every two couple
Wait, zero point four. Yeah for every two couples. There's one child
Does that make sense?
One they're gonna be a popper. Yes, exactly. Um
Depends on how many you want. Oh me how many I want
And
Um
South korea is at zero point seven. Okay, and I think it went down. Yeah
This is the uncap rhetoric I membership for yeah, I don't even know what uncap is but thank you
Oh any capitalism report. Okay. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. I'll be here
Um
We'll be having plenty of kids on the farm. No, you're my kid
Is that weird
You're the father. What?
Oh, I jumped. I was like wait link and jump. Yes link has a cape
um
Do you even want children? Yeah
With a boisterous crowd and a cute crest these feathered friends are the most popular pets in high rule. The baby chicks are like small boos
Uh, anarchy. Oh an arachnid
Oh, you're teaching me phrases. I don't even
No, you are my children and I'm also pregnant with you and you're the father
Uh, I'm still not commissioned that artwork. Yeah, I need to hurry up and do it so I can make it because it's hilarious
Ah
What's your name gammy gammy gammy atlas blossom
Nice to see you to see you nice
Sweet home
Boy girl both how many
Uh, wherever the reeflings are that's how many
Whatever number we've got we've gained, you know
Wow, I've already had that
We're now at 270 coins
8 000 reeflings. That's a lot of birthing. I'm gonna be honest
Birth throws are winning right now. They are absolutely winning
Jen
Uh, I'd rather raise a dog
To be a grandpa of its pup since I love dogs cats. I'm allergic to rip being allergic to cat
I got two precious poodles
I don't think I'm getting any more putters on
So many questions about that
What about
About me being prego with you, but you're also the dad at the same time. Like don't think about it too much
It's like a little warp
Um, because like if you Azura's lore is that she's actually your literal mummy
She creates civilization which makes her your mom technically and all technicality
Uh, but I birthed
Azura technically
Oh, we got a new one our percentage is now less than one in three
It's less than 33 percent. So it's less than one in three
One in three to the infinite
It makes perfect sense to me. Okay. Well, I'm glad it does because
Prego strongy was off
Yeah
Do you want to try some cuttlefish milk?
You just have to do you have to do something first to make the cuttlefish milk come in though
Oh
Young couple Romeo. Oh raw mayo and julietta grew up next door. They're dating now
But they plan to marry once they get their pets approval. Then you go talk to their dog
Yes, god, please
I wish to do that. Maybe I'll get some fun out of that
um
Like what milton tin I got a beefling diet through
How would that even work? Would you have to get the piercing though? No, um, if you didn't know
boobly mooblies, um
It's not like one singular flow of
Milk, um, it's like little tiny
multiple little things
Um, so the piercings do not have to be removed for that
Just means you have to suck a bit harder
Oh
Refreshing treat udders udders. Can he call it udders? That's that's rough calling it udders
We'll have to get a zero to demonstrate
Done for that. We have a deal
Okay, I think I'm gonna have to put the heat in on and get a cup of tea because it's frozen
Nothing nothing. Uh, apparently Aussie houses have like the worst insulation ever
There's like nay insulation to them at all
I believe it because I've rented
And uh, it's absolute piss, so I'm gonna need for the heat on
Are you saying you want us?
Exactly
Oh, oh, they're called chuchu. That's such a good name
Is there like a percentage thing? No, what goes down here?
I don't know what goes down there
But there isn't a percentage we've got five tiger scrolls. I'm gonna need a few more. I thought I had more than five
Stony sand in his early. Yeah, I'm gonna need to have you do a certain demonstration
If you didn't know, is there a chibi or live on fall guys right now?
Wow
Oh, I just got weird pain on my leg and my ankle. Please pull the memory amputism. Leave me alone
Oh, we're on 30% now. So if we hit the 20s, that's one in five
One in five gacha pools
Wow
867 shells, we're gonna be here forever. Should we take a break? Should we take a break and do explore?
Great now pull the lever. Yes. Yes. Okay. We'll take a break. I'll get a tea in me. I will go do some other stuff
This is there a
live on the commune
Oh, I like like
Uh, yes, we'll take a break and we'll go do some questing and we'll come back to this
I am going to 100% this game because I don't think I've ever actually done it before
Um
And I wouldn't mind 100% in it with you
Just gives me another reason to yap your head off for like hours on hours because I thought this is gonna be a forever stream
but certainly in turn another way
Well, she can
I'm just being about domain
Don't overthink it and we could take a drink and get the drink
Okay, I'm gonna go make a honey tea
Uh, when we get the next successful gacha pool and we'll go for a tinkle
Right go away and board head you
I said at the next successful gacha pool
At the next we will go make a tea
Ah London this small ranch lies just outside high rule town father and daughter teen Talon and
Malon run it and they sell the finest malon more like melons because I know where that milk really comes from
Okay
We will go and take a very quick break. I just need to tinkle um and two
I'm just using a kin stone
The game is nice and gives me kin stones when I need them, but I guess
Right, I'll leave you guys by the little chicken so you can go
Okay, oh wait, can I sit on these chairs? Can I role-playing sit on the chair? Yeah, okay?
We're totally at a cafe date right now
Hey, I will be like a few minutes. I just need to boil the kettle
Give me give me
Three minutes, okay
Oh
All right, I've gone for a piss and the kettle's boiling Gimli says hi and I put the heating on
I'll just be a minute. I'm heating up a soup like in the microwave
Oh
The way you were brave thing I thought we were gonna have another in the endurance stream
The way you were breathing
I know you came in here
We are saved yes
Oh
Thank you for the five a
Rolly legend
I really struggled to say your name to two L's on it
And my brain always recessed on us that I'm saying to me. Hi Gimli. Yeah
I've got you only have one cat. No, I have two putters. I have baby boy and my little princess. Gimli is my princess
and baby boy is my little munchkin cat that I
The universe sent to me as a laugh
and
I am a big
believer in not breeding cat breeds that are detrimental to their health
And then the universe said here take this boy and I was like right fine. I will take this boy
Um, and I love them to pieces
He's a very silly cat though because he hurt himself and I had to take him to the vet
Which was not a fun experience
Uh, because cats were really dumb and don't show any pain
Uh, and I just it was petting him and his like
Blood had matted his fur on his back leg and I was like, what did you do?
And then I managed to cut it away and he had a big nasty gash on his leg
but um, he healed up nicely
and and
I was having to warn the vets because I was like, I'm so sorry, but like I've only just got him
I have no idea what his temperament is with vets like if he's aggressive or not
So please be careful and they were like he was the sweetest boy we've had all day and I'm like
Shucks, you just say that to everyone, don't you? You've got me blushing about my baby boy
Um, but I'm so sorry
But I'm gonna be eating with my in my hands. Okay
I'll try and eat that because I should be lucky
Oh
I have to take your time trying to heal it
It's not toast it's chicken lettuce onion on like a flatbread
Are you gonna be a cat lady? No, I'm gonna be a farm lady wearing milk reeflings all day long
Mmm
Oh, I'll tell you something actually about psychology. Do you know
Why is unattractive to women if you don't like animals? I'll see if someone can guess why
Um, but why do you think that women do not like it if men say they do not like animals
Because then you can't care for them
Shows a lack of empathy. Oh you're getting close indicates. You don't want children. You're getting there
so
This is absolutely outrageous to say but it is what it is. Um
Psychology wise animals are viewed as lesser, aren't they?
Some men view women as lesser
So if man don't like animal, what does man think about women?
Hmm
Scary beans and that is why women naturally do not like men
Or gravitate to words men that do not like animals if you do not like animals. I'm so sorry, but psychologically it's a big old, uh
Monkey
Mm-hmm
I love animals, but not women. Why the fuck are you what?
Do I see or am I just one of the bros be honest or am I like the neighbor next door come on
Show me the goods show me the goods
Um, I have some terrible news to break to you about what I've got going on downstairs if you don't like women
I'm literally I'm literally the guy that doesn't want animals in their house
That's currently petting his dog while getting thinking about getting a second. Yeah
That's like the most adorable thing my dad was like that with cats is like no
We're not getting another cat and then there would be some sob story
Our stray would show up. I think we've had three strays show up
Um and I don't
You're one of the bros for me. Honestly. All right grip grip session boys. Let's do a soggy biscuit. Well, what about it?
Wait a minute you're a woman
My little baby saved me from being forever little pudders
Can't have animals. I'm allergic. Oh, that's a shame. There's some hypoallergenic freaks, I think
But I'm a woman
Oh
I love animals, but I'm terrible at taking care of them. Yeah
I'm I'm
I love my pudders so much. They're they're just perfection
But you have to treat me like an animal. You need to take me on a walk and stuff
You know
You're opening a pen
Are the animals in a box in a dark room whilst you're pressed against the box by any chance
I thought it was the other way around. Oh, no, no, no, no the leash and the collar goes both ways
For once it's a not on me, but on you
No
Remove my dinkleberries, I assure you there's no a liquor here anywhere from below my head, I guess
You need to go nap your tire left
Strony walks up with the collar and leash time for walkies literally walk me like a dog at the convention
You
At least connects our collars together. I don't think we're coordinated enough to walk side by side on our hands and knees, are we?
You can take me on a walk anytime
I always say
I'm
Shorting on the farm with a key leashes out on a walk on
I
Have almost finished the omelette right there one last day. I'm so sorry. I'm trying to heal
You talk to the guy behind you when you get all the figures. Oh, that's very lucky
I'll take that
Elton ring Joe between straw and reef and spender who walks who wait
But either way isn't a punishment
We're losing
Either way, I win you don't understand I win you lose
Someone said that there was like wins pvp
love sense and I was I was this is like the
Ones that I'll always end up deleting someone was like when is pvp love sense and I was like beat me on
Black ops one then scrub and then I'd leave it because I thought like a tape set and all that but just
That's the secret straw and he always wins literally
Oh
Everything always comes up strong especially the reeflings
Have you ever seen the dog that walks other dogs? That sounds we walk each other
We do a bit of that switch up energy. Yeah, I don't
I think like overall my results were like I like doing a lot to you don't wise but
You call me good girl. I'm gonna melt
You say good pupper. I'm gonna melt
I would lose intentionally so I could be walked speak for yourself blank never loses
So is every fling dub
I've never seen a cut off fish on a leash before
I should do like an actual ed and be like, oh, yeah, you like that. I'm not a cut off fish on leash action
I
know
When are we doing the biddy biddy
Stream oh next week if you want up to you
A strongy a gentle queen as this terminology. I'm not familiar with
When are the jewels gets walked to meet you try
I
Also have a honey tea and a cola because that's all I drink. I'm just terrible should actually try and drink more water
Excuse me. I'm just gonna check that Azura and she be are on fire right now. Um, because I don't think
Uh, Azura do they uh, I don't know if they realize that they're playing someone said they didn't realize
Uh, the intention was to do public matches
Oh, there they are. Okay, they're playing that's adorable
I'll generate it on a Azura's screen
Oh, pardon me in a game. No, I didn't read in time. Oh
Oh, well, I'll read faster in another life for this life. No
Everything looks good on
Twitter and all the
VAs are patiently waiting on me, which is nice. Thank you. I sure it's all the VAs are be nice to me
Can we get you a color with your name on it?
Maybe I could buy that for the donut phone
whoa
scrawny
Right, I'm to talk to this man with I'm a rich guy see and I'm a collector taboo
That's his hint on what you need to do
Bro, that's pretty outrageous
Uh, right. We're going to
Reserves something down this well that we could do
Can we get
Oh, I can swim now. Oh
And I can do that don't mind if I do
Right if I roll that
Is that four or three one two three that's three, okay
We just need to go to the mayor's office and then we can get word with the heck is in here
Hmm
PvP looks this kind of goes hard
Do we do
Uh, sure here you go din her name is din
Oh, it's another booty fly and it's in the swamp area too. Did I not bomb that?
Hmm
It's din from the seasons game, ah
Uh, do you want to do something? Yes, you do. Okay good because I have it wherever you need. I have it somehow
Another butterfly, okay, okay
I forgot they were in this
You might love it fit perfectly, you know what else would fit perfectly
Yes, let's use
Din as in one of the three golden goddesses of pyro
I like that
Also be lily pad
Yeah, we're actually gonna need to do these before we go back and explore everything to pick everything up again
Uh, so it's pretty good that we're getting all of these do you trade you don't
And do you trade do you trade do you do no can stone pieces?
Uh
This side of the mayor's office do you trade can stone you don't because you're a sucker
Ah
Uh, I
Pray it's three or else we can't do whatever this is
Okay, there we go. That's perfect
Wow strong strong strong
And grab this push it all the way out the way
Always be faced getting rid of such a nice detail like
Yeah, right and then just grab this
With all your might yeah din is the oracle dancer. Yeah dancer wink wink nintendo dancer got it
What's so important?
money
After all of that
There was money
Oh, I'll take that though. I'm a bit low
Uh, did we buy the big quiver?
We did I'm going to dig on the walls though because we had that thing we have to trade that's on a wall
But oh, I don't even know where the heck we are
But there should be something to trade on a wall, but is it gonna be here? I don't think so
I think it's gonna be around the map
Okay, that was actually really lucky that I knew oh he jumping me
Okay, there's nothing to trade here
The in the pandemic we in the bandemic
Zing
Okay, no, I don't I don't even know where we are
Oh, we're down below. I know we're exactly where we are
Okay, let me finish my tea. Did you guys get some food and all of that make sure you hydrate in school under construction?
Right, there's a minish spot in the bakery. We haven't been
There's a pathway to get up here and in there. So is there a teleportation?
Right
They don't want to trade
How do I become small in this area?
Can't do it that way
It's not possible
That can take me into the bakery if I'm small
How do you how do you get outside and small oh here here here here?
Oh, hi. Oh my god. Do you have a wane? When did you have a wane?
But my sister's back now. Oh right, okay
I
Have a pastry good
Some of you are eating
Hi popper
You ought to be careful when you're running around. Not all of us are so nice. Well, you're in my way. So
Right
So now we need to be tiny and go all the way this way
Oh, wait, is this all gonna be nice? Hi popper
Your people means trash. Hello
Nope
Maybe I should go hide in the cocoon league. It may be dangerous. So it seems like there's danger everywhere. Oh
for guys
Suppose there was a car oracle game before
Wait, let's go to the bakery first. She does show up at both the oracle
games
Am I gonna get hurt?
I am gonna get hurt during it
Hi
Oh, you having a little cat? I like eating leftovers. I just wish the business was going better for him
Why is it not going better?
Do you need me to clean up? I will clean up right now. Don't think I won't
Have his business not going good for them. Sorry if they're charging 60 rupees for a slice of cake sauce
But your business should be doing fine
Uh, I'm not buying it. I'm not buying it. Let's go on here
Sorry guys. Don't need to suck your
Keep that on
Sorry a few and fewer people are coming to buy bread
I can't believe how dangerous it's gotten around here. Uh, I wonder if it's because all the monsters are back
Oh, there's just money up here
We don't need no money. Well, we may if we're buying shells actually
All right, I'm gonna try and finish my now I might as well just send it then. Um, I'll try and finish my tea my cup of tea
These little flower paths are actually
It's exactly what I wanted to see. This is the stuff we need
Give it to me. Oh my god. We complete another heart
How many one two three four five six seven
If seven are missing what seven times four
Uh, wait, let me calculate it
seven times
four
Four seven seven fourteen twenty one twenty eight boom. That's right
I did maths. What are you gonna do about it?
Take me to me a hot second to come out with that there, but we got there in the end. That's the most important part
Uh
Right, I don't think there's anything we can do right now that ghost is unfortunately still in the way
galaxy bean streamer
Oh had to do that
I was like I was gonna do like four times five, but I'm like wait, that's not gonna get me to the number that I need
I need more of those numbers
She doesn't want to trade you don't want to do a freaking thing
um
I don't I've already done his quest
Yeah, I can buy shells if I really need
Wait, you can demand
sometimes
And I don't think anyone wants to trade
Kinstones not we're out of kinstone traders
Right, I think
We've done what we can for the towns people on the most part anyway. Oh, no
Yeah, I grab this how much is this 50
And then we need to feed the reeflings to make sure they're okay, I will get a croissant this time
Yeah, I'll buy
Wait if I buy everything do the minish change
Maybe the minish are like yay. We're sold out if I buy everything
Hold on
Welcome tasty tasty. Yes, bye, please
Yay, we've got a blue one. Let's go give me give me
Oh
The question but if you got a color for his reef and what color I think it would
Oh green might be a bit ugly though
Welcome, please buy whatever you like I have terrible news. You ain't got nothing to buy
Hmm, right. Well, that was a waste of money. Let me guess it's gonna restart as soon as we go back. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Um, I want to say green, but I don't think it would look that nice. I think black just black looks good
Purple like my eyeball my eyes are blue and my eyes are blue and yellow. Have I really not shown you my eyes enough?
Like they're blue. Oh, are they purple? Hold on. They look blue to me
I'm not colorblind. What color are my eyes? Tell me right now
Blueish purple
Okay, now tell me what color my eyes are
Too late now
Oh, that's those. Oh, that that looks more purple. Well, okay, that definitely looks more purple
Yeah, oh no, I think you guys are right the black rock headquarters
Stop that's my problem. My favorite. Oh, where did the heck did I go? Hold on. Sorry
I'm too much. Sorry. I'm being an unprofessional streamer at the moment
Black rock headquarters. So I can't get over how fucking hilarious that meme is. Do any of you guys want to trade Ken Stone?
Welcome to the library. Right. Let me finish this here. Keep saying I'm gonna finish it. I don't
Uh
Okay, whatever. Um, oh, maybe this guy will
Oh, yeah the exchange Ken Stone pieces with me
Have you ever watched like a medican popcorn? It's always that like
Oh
My god, you're so right the bell in the middle. You're so freaking right. Wow
Yes, I completely forgot
Okay
Now I think I've done everything if no one is trading me pieces. I want to but basically backtrack
Oh, no, we need to do we need if we need to um
Yes, hold on. Hold on. I think we need to trade that little minish guy
Um
and then
His wish will be er
He'll make a
I am so sorry. I'm trying to speak one sentence right now. I think this becomes a house
Oh, no, it doesn't
But it's not him that makes the house
Happy to help good girl. Hey
I've been submissive enough for one day
Right, so that was all about reading
So then what was this?
You know can it must be the one that's in the builders heart
I'm not watching professional corn
I just find it funny because if you ever watch like American
Like mainstream all you'll hear is
Okay
I don't know how to get that house down
No one wants to use with me
What's that? I should stay indoors just because there's monsters about don't be silly
I literally if you ever
Yeah
Without fail right. He doesn't do it can still infusion which is fun. I'm finally home from work time to eat rest well
Sleepy
Maybe I'll build here. I think yeah, but how do I get you to build there? How?
I don't know
Okay, everyone's dialogue has now changed to be worried about the monsters
That's curious
Oh him him him you're new
Yes, it must be you it must be you because you're new you're not normal here
It doesn't destroy the minish house that we I rehomes the minish in the house
And I'm secretly 87 years old oji san spotted and I lay oji san on site. Yeah, we did it
Okay, now if we go in and out it should be built
No, not yet. I'll build here. I think wait. How does that progress?
Oh, wow it progressed. Okay
Tell you I just need a single female. I bet you need a single female
I guess rent free as long as she's pretty. Okay, I should I should that red up poster. Oh god
Right, uh red or blue
Oh, you're showing me an empty house. Well, not yet. Hold on. Why not? Hey, why not? Well, let me know if something comes up
You want red buff or blue buff. What does red or blue do a single one?
Red gives damage blue gives defense I may actually need blue on ironically
I
I am more of a defense than uh, what does green do then?
I am a defense boy
Actually, what happens in here? Do we even gamble? What what was this? Oh, no customer
Welcome. What do you give me? Yeah, sure 10 rupees. Take it. What would I do?
What would I do? Level one is more than enough to take your money, but if you're feeling particularly we've already gone level two
Uh level two. Why not?
I have no idea what we're doing
What?
Just open which chest you like if you win. Oh right
What one left middle right and whoever gets it wrong is getting timed out
I'll open up my stream right now second time is all out if you get it wrong
Right, someone says right. Okay, we'll pick right. Are you getting timed out if it's wrong zone?
Right is
No way you got that right
How did you do that?
Do you want to wager again? Sure. Why not? I see where you're ready open another check, right? Okay new one
I I can see chat right now. I'm ready to tame you's all out for who gets it wrong
What are you saying double or none gamble middle first one was middle. Oh right time out whoever says middle time out
You put user in time out 10 seconds confirm who else said middle you said middle
Timo 10 seconds. Yep
Middle not you Timo Timo. No, you're wrong
All the chat's getting removed
Yeah, okay, we we're done
Last time I listened to you guys again. I'll the chat again remove. Yeah
Don't ever do that again. Sorry. No crazy stainless right gambling is not what it is
And don't think maybe I'll win next time either. Wait, they're actually saying it wake up man
Get out here before you lose the shirt off your back
All done all done
Is there anything else in town no right, I think we're going to take it from the top
We'll start at link's house and work her way to
Oh
I'm not even going to start it
Uh, there may be kinstone pieces if we cut the grass
No, I told the lie clearly
There's a beetle coming after my ankles
All right, we can swim as well just as a reminder we can swim now
But yeah, we're going going a little adventure now
Oh
Red which means major
Which means major
Pause my get my screen off the my stream off the screen
Oh, what did we unlock syrup syrup got an idea for a new potion
Hmm my special red potion is that damage is this just damage and defense at syrups
We did it right. Let me just make sure that's everything for you buddy
It is so I hear the mushroom lady finish a new potion. It's bright red. That is one seriously nasty color
I'm not touching it. Okay. We've unlocked a aggro via syrup
I did it. What's up here? Oh, I found my baby Minish. I can go down here. Okay
Okay, let's go
I saw that beanstalk so we'll go down there. I don't know where we're heading though. We're heading somewhere anyway
Hey, we're supposed to go when I'm tiny
Oh, I see it
Oh, yes. Yes. Yes. This is exactly what we need. Yes. Yes more this please
Red famo's buff is more limit time, but boost boost it makes you purple just look up
Has often Mendo for me Nintendo for making us play gacha and then calling us out for it. Honestly
Oh, that's perfect. That's exactly what we needed
Oh, sorry mess up cutting the grass. Excuse me. Pardon me. Come through. Oh wait. Is there anything in my house?
There might be I actually so this is your house. Well, it seems like a nice place
So where's my room? Uh, you don't have a room. You're a hat
Hi grand papi
Oh, he wants to trade. I'm so glad you're safe link. I hear the terrible things are happening
By the way, have you been using all of the items you've found if you ever get stuck somewhere?
Use that trick. Just try everything in your inventory. I love that
Literally just ram your head into the wall until sun happens
What if I miss you fell asleep? Are you gonna sleep? You're allowed to sleep if you need to sleep
Um, we are now just doing all the little sade activities
Um, because we're about to hit the end game, but if we hit it
Oh, it got 20 rupees from that choice. If we hit the end game, then
Uh, a lot of things aren't very nice. So we're gonna try and 100% it like right now
So this is your room. That makes it my room too, right? Yeah
Hey, aren't you tired? Do you want to take a rest? Sure. Let's go to sleep
Oh my god, look at us sleeping. We're so cute. Oh my god, Esso looks absolutely gone
Oh
Yeah, that was just what I needed to get back in the fight. Let's get going. Oh, we had a little map together
Best feeler girl step on me. Uh, she be she has heels
She'll make sure it hurts and you say thank you after
Um, I've already been in here. Haven't we? Yes, it was a heart. That's perfectly fine
No, no, no, no. Oh, sorry. Um, I um, I've already done this tingling, but just in case
Yeah, okay. Have you found all the tingling brothers? You can fuse kinstones and we'll have a certain fact
Tingle is positive. You will get something very very good. Good luck, Mr. Fairy
Wait, why am I a fairy? Who are you calling a fairy? You're the one dressed up in a freaking
I can't make that joke, but
What's this if it shells? Oh, that's how I get my other bottles. That's fantastic
um
There's a beanstalk here that isn't uh growing
There's a reason tingle calls you a fairy that can't remember. I must be related to other war
Hey, we're going to do a complete backtrack of the woods right now
Okay, maybe this is the bean
Yes, it is the bean. Okay, we can literally go straight back to where we just passed. That's perfect
They call you a fairy because you're also green. You guys are you guys aren't afraid of heights, right?
You don't be shy
Let me just double check. He's not gonna give me a second one
Yeah, listen, you remember the bean I posted? Yeah, I do. I saw it cool
Tingle calls you a fairy because anyone he thinks in green is a fairy because he thinks that's cute
You look like me. You are me
Right, time to claim
Let's see what's up here
Okay, that's a bit dramatic. I have to admit that's a bit much
Well, there's a heart up here. So I'll take it
I need I've got three. I've got 200 rupees. I think I'm gonna max out on rupees. I might buy shells in that case
If we're gonna backtrack should I just 100 guarantee gamba these figures if we're gonna backtrack
I think we're gonna end up with like tons of shells
Yeah, I've like wasted a hundred shells with that. We're just gonna do guaranteed pulls
I shouldn't but if we're gonna backtrack we 100% are gonna get like
Tons of shells and that was such a waste. Ah, that was such a waste
Okay, right. Let's see. You want me to do what your back? Yes. I am back. I'm addicted
How many do I need for 100 probability?
I'm just gonna do 100 probability because I don't want to gamble like 60 and then not get it
Let's do 100. Let's do 100. What is it drum roll?
Fire wizard money gang. I burped when I said that. I don't know if you heard that or the mic may have covered it up
Okay
Is there a faster way to do this? No, it's not. I literally have to go all the way up manually
Big gamba time big gamba
We're gonna do good
Okay
74 so I think we get like six pulls and then we're done
No burp on the mic. No, I did it as I was talking. So I don't know if the mic even heard it
One for each percent and yeah, the uh, this is rough. So I'm only gonna get like 10 gacha
new from it
I
Now pull that lever I
What do the figures do in the game it unlocks a location that we need in order to get 100 percent
So unfortunately, we're kind of stuck doing this right now
Um, but we are just gonna get rid of our shells because we're about to backtrack and we'll be rewarded with new
Um, oh was that 99? I swear if that was 99 and we don't get it
Okay
It's too easy it's too easy ladies and gentlemen, you're lucky I refrained
You're so lucky I refrained
I I have so much ability to hold it in okay
All right, let's see
In that room is the music play
Let's play in game music. I believe in that room is the music player
Yeah, we haven't got I don't actually ever recall getting it before you know that
And
Oh, you're charging me bro, you are charging me
77 just for a guarantee
Happy hearth in oh my god, that's such a lovely name for an in
I wouldn't mind. Oh my god. Maybe we should develop an in game
I quite like meta games. I'm really impressed with that. Um
What's the name the team that put together needy streamer overload. I am so impressed
I really want to look into them and see to produce anything else. I was blown away by that
Uh, what game did I really enjoy that? Um
Um that double shitty game
Oh, I can't I remember it with the nightclub and I had terrible luck on it buckshot relay
I was very impressed with buckshot relay. I definitely want to look into the dev team
Although I think it was made by one guy actually, so it'd be interesting to see what other games he came up with
Um
I'm out of shells yet
Buckshot's just one guy literally need see if he's got anything else on the market though like, um
Definitely put my money where my mouth is type thing like, um
The more shells you use yes this thing
Am I out yet? No. No, I can still get more
Wow, you lose a hundred percent the same. So this is teaching us go big or go home
I'm addicted to buckshot after watching I did so bad
But it was funny though stamp a busy hard-working employee
Although he can be a touch edgy the stamp he uses his own personal ones. Please don't borrow it. Thanks
I love like the little details like you didn't have to come up with that lore
But the game was like, yeah, we're gonna make random lore for these times people
Are we out shells now?
No
80 though, bro a
Any chance for another buckshot relay stream, uh, most likely a member stream if there's any games we want to revisit
Um, I'm quite happy to do it in members because if you look it might be a bit like, oh, you've already shamed this before type thing
She says she'll please Viva pinata and cameo shamelessly to back-to-back endurance rooms. Um
I think I said I got the achievements on Skyrim working again. So we can actually go back to Skyrim in
July
Um
Oh peaceful high rule car loves peaceful high rule scenery. I don't know who car love is but you've got good taste mate
Uh, you can just carry 990 max. So 10 is 11 pulls. No crashed warp 100 percent. Oh, I'm not sure I have that kind of skill
I'm not very good. I don't comprehend. It's a child's game, but I'm I don't think I'm that good
I
How does he know about the minute to make figures exactly?
minister
Caval is the figure guy. Oh silly me
Want to try again? I feel like we're now out of shells. We've done quite a lot
No
There it is right. Let's do it. Let's just go down to zero shells
Wish us luck
What do we pull? What do we pull?
Malari
He lives with the seven apprentices in mount carinal
Serenal
Carinal which contains all the mineral riches they will ever need. He seems gruff, but he's trustworthy. There we go
Let's go right. We are officially down and out on shells, which is actually a good thing
Um, because it means we can now high tweety bird. Um, we can now pick up chests without being worried
She says as
Uh, she's full of rupees as well. Can I buy this?
Why do you keep putting it down speak 200
Oh
200 rupees
for 30 shells
me
You're lucky. I need to empty my pockets
That's all i'm saying. You're lucky. I need to empty my pockets because
30 shells
Right, bro. That's outrageous honestly. You should be ashamed of yourself
Oh
Fair these shells also
Sorry, sorry for what a third tea. I speak the king of the queen's english th 30. Sorry. It's fair in scots
Capital man even cap I can't escape capitalism in my we video game
No, wait, no wait, was this the way I came
It is right. We'll do this then
200 rupees oh a cheeky cheeky we 30 for me then
Is there anything under the water? Nah
Whoop whoop whoop right we are literally just gonna go back to the start and
Take it from the tap. Oh, we've not unlocked this
Wow, we've not unlocked it. How well there seems to be something for digging here. Maybe there's a gore rock that we can trade
I
Let me be fellow beast
50 not bad not bad not bad a kinsome piece not bad. Okay. That was a quick one very quick one
Yeah, it sounds like seven or eight rupees to a shell
Extortionate well, I know what business we're opening up reflands
In order to pay for the farm because are you joking me?
Are you joking me? Is there anything hidden in here anything hidden in here? Nope just a minute
A red piece I'll absolutely take a red piece. I keep forgetting that the chest can also have
A other stuff in them
Kinsome piece
That's not one shot
I
Nothing in here, which is fine
Right, we'll go we and then we'll go to the minish
Strone could sell them for more because her pretty cool
Did the minish sound like naikor when they talk?
Don't ever type again. That's the funniest thing I've seen all day. That's hilarious, but don't type again
What the fuck?
Do they sound like naikor? Oh my god
That's really funny, but don't talk again
Leave my squeakers alone
200 okay, we now have like
I don't know another two batches of therapy
Naikor
Don't speak
I use the shells first that would add value
Wait, why is there water unless there's something in the water because why would you put that here?
No, you didn't there's nothing here
Am I being trolled why would you put these here if there's nothing in the water?
I'm being trolled I fell for it have foolish the egg is on my face
The gamer instincts has failed us truly
There's something over here. Oh my god. No, he's all alone over here. Are you okay buddy?
Wow good job finding this place. There aren't many people who visit me. Wait, you don't want to trade or anything
Is there nothing special? Is it in the water?
It's in the water, isn't it? It's in the water. Are you sure you don't want to do a kinstone fusion?
Oh
What's in the water come on?
Must be in the water
Talk to the minish in the barrel shaped house, okay
Hmm, maybe I unlock a chest at his house or something and we'll come a bit too early
With our timing
Hello
You've heard of the travelers of feng kinstone get really lucky. Well, that's thanks to that
It's made by husband as you see we thrive on making humans happy. Oh, that's so precious. Hi, buddy
Sometimes if a flower seed and sometimes it's a stone we hide our lucky items and all sorts of unexpected places
But the real trick is making it tough for humans
Kawaii ne
Relayer, thank you for coming to replaying. I appreciate it. Hi buddy. Hello
We're doing cutting edge research on bloom. You see that plant with a little bud. We're working on waste and privet
Do you need water?
Uh, if you need
No, okay, that's not real water. Are you real water? Nope. You're not real water
And there's no water on the side talk to him again. Oh
What do you mean he doesn't instantly tell me what to do? Oh, I need milk
You need milk
Could you have asked me for that before I came all the way to these parts?
Okay, we'll come back with milk soon to yem, but not yet
Uh, as far as I'm aware, none of the houses have anything
And
I was born and raised here. So I don't know much about those. I hear there are huge green monsters in the woods
I can't believe they made it through. Oh, I can't believe you made it through their life. That's right
He needs some azura
We need some
So how is old yes, yes, he was fine
Right, we'll come back to the minish village with milk. What a request. Well, what else do you want sugar while I'm at it?
I'm at the shops for you milk
your child
maybe
Okay, he does want to fuse that's good. Oh, I should maybe talk to that other one
He might want to fuse an important piece as well. Can we have yours instead?
He needs green water from the mountain
You know what would be great a bomb that went off when you only wanted actually I could make that now. Oh
Okay, well, we're actually about to go talk to him. Thank you, mate
I'm gonna talk to the old geezer from over here
Green liquid as well
Uh, do you want to trade? No, you don't
You don't want to trade
Thank you, thank you
You have saved me
Someone calls us that we have a good green
Right, he is happy with all our trading man. I love I'm sorry. I said this was the first time we walked there
I love this kind of pixel art. It's just so adorable. It's so roomy. It's so cute. It's so kawaii
Pardon me. All right remote bombs
You aren't normal begin. Just try that. Do we want remote bombs?
Maybe
Sure, sure. Give me remote bombs. Why not?
All right, let's wait. Well, let's fuse. Oh red. So it's important
I'm like, hmm. Do we actually want to thank you again Rilaire for coming in below? I appreciate
any
members
Yeah, that swamp is absolutely filled to the brim with items like stuff that we're gonna need to pick up
It's gonna take us a hot thing
Right swim over here while we're little. Is there anything we can, you know, we can't there's two big grass patches in the way
Right, we need milk
And we need green likewise for these
boats
Had to go to the store
Well, we're about to go to the store in game
Uh, because we need to get the milk
Uh
Is this we've already been to this guy? Yeah, we have
God, how does that keep bumping me? Right. We've already done him. We've done jack and the beanstalk, which is fine
So we're gonna get milk first
Milk I need milk if me milk
Whoa
Right lawn lawn
Ut mawee
Ut mawee, ut mawee. I'll use ut mawee
I
Need milk straight from the source
Yes, please. Oh, hello there. I'm selling nutritious milk. Please give me milk
Give me milky
Right, I'm gonna buy
Shells again because we've got we're already at 500. We just spent all our rupees and we're already back at 500 again
Uh, so it might as well put it on the gamble
Yes, bye, please
It's her milk cart a cow-shaped chariot. Oh, is that actually
We will inspect it while we go pick up the green
the green goo
Oh, ah, I keep doing that
It doesn't seem to register instantly that I want to talk to him. There we go
Strongly you also should buy the gorgon pieces at the post office
I'm gonna be so poor by the end we do all this quest and we can go make it
Right, how much coin? Okay, we have 150. I'm just gonna catch a one right now
What am I designed to be get? Let's see. Oh, you're back. Yeah, I'm back
Uh, well a probability is 18. That's horrific probability
Hey
odds 83 for a confirmed
Well again
Tingling tingle siblings tingle and green and his twin younger brothers ankle and
Knuckle they believe infusing will help meet the fairies
So they are recording kinsome data on their maps. David junior is not technically a relic stop
That's bizarre. I love whatever that was
There's like always not actually related to us. Okay
Right, let's go get green milk next
Uh, excuse me pup. Oh, you do this every time buddy
Oh, there's so much over here we need to
Do we just do it all at once? Why not? Why not? Why not? We'll just do all at once. Okay
What's this? Okay, very good very good
Hmm
Well, it seems like it's gonna take me down. Oh
No, no trading
There is
Well, I'll grab one now that we're gonna need it at this point in time, but we will come back to get
Oh, I love this song
Oh already came back already came back
All right, there is one here
Actually, we're gonna check that the the gorgon things aren't here because they might be the
Kinstone trading that we need to do
Oh, there is
Oh, we have 10 pieces of the one they've won
They all work from home analyst. Yeah
Although he needs one more friend and he can get to the next location
Are they all gonna hang out in the cave? Hmm. This wall's pretty tough
I don't think the two of us can break it, but that doesn't stop me
Right
Oh
I thought I smelled some gorgons around here. What are you guys up to buddy? We miss you. Hey, give us a hand breaking through
Bunk bonk bonk bonk bonk bonk, but they still need one more to break this big wall
Okay, that's fine. So there's a chest here. We're gonna go get that because we're coming back for it
Thankfully
Bit cheeky money so we can put it on our cheeky gacha. Don't mind me. Oh
Oh speaking of a tingling you were up here hiding from what?
Do you may perhaps have any other piece for no reason at all?
Please game
For no other reason at all. Give us something else
No way that one piece is what I need
You want to fuse I absolutely do well, I know I have that piece because I just saw it
Literally out of all the pieces you could ask for should you come in a gambler?
No
Just a weeble
Yeah
I did not pay attention to what location that is tribally hills
All those good old
Yay, they fit I wonder what that means. Oh, yeah, you wonder what it means if they fit together
Did you ever check out that warrior? No, I didn't do it yet. Please. Please
Surely I'll get a kinstone piece from cutting the grass surely
Copium
copium
Surely one kinstone feet. Yeah, you're a fuck it. We'll come back later
Right green milk time. No
wait
Give me green give me green
You know, you want to give me green give me green give me green give me green give me here
Well, we tried um, what was this?
Bomb the la wait. Do you want to fuse stones? No
Dig at the farmhouse for pieces
I just make oh, there's the green liquid
Okay, thankfully it's not that far away. I think probably already bombed that
Because I'm I'm playing messily. I'm playing messily. Oh my gosh. Goodbye. Don't care. Not my problem
Not my problem
Right at least we can do
You know what these are all in my way
Absolutely steamrolled. Oh, oh
No, okay. Well, it was worth the shot
Give me that. No, um, no don't fly me halfway across the map
We have milk we have green
I don't even know of any other liquid that we could need that I need a syrup
Link has become
Gardner destroyer boss. Right. We can at least do this
We'll come back to mount cereal later
Um, this one. Yes
We've got Nickelodeon slained honestly
Oh
Sorry, I ain't put these on because it's just so much faster
Look, I don't mean to come through your house with like my dirty shoes and my sword out
But so it's just so much faster going everywhere. I think the last one is either a red or blue potion. You know what?
You know what? I've just fucking go all this way
Have I missed your messages and chat telling me that I've just come all this way and he's
Come back again
It's fine. I'm actually not that mad. I'm enjoying this. I need milk
Wait, you've got milk. Yes. I brought it for you. It's all for you, buddy
Thanks, I can do my research
Great, and then I'll leave and then I'll come back in and they will have bloomed beautifully
Nope, they have not bloomed. Okay. Uh, let's try that again. Uh new bloom come back soon
Okay, I guess we'll do something else
Needs time but time isn't actually this game isn't actually timed
It takes five in game minutes, but well if we need
We'll go to the top of the forest then instead
I
Didn't even yeah, I didn't even know this time this game was like time
Oh, I'm gonna have to get my blank game cut in circulation off of my leg. Ow that hurts. I don't I never noticed the pain until
Till it's too late
Wait, am I supposed to? No, sorry. Sorry. I just I just literally juked that bird. I'm so sorry, Mr. Bird
That was so rude of me. I did not mean it like that. I do apologize. Mr. Bird
Uh
Not unlocked that clearly
What if I talk to this guy though?
Broke that bird's ankles literally juked him out
Yes, I got the elder. Thank you for asking about the elder. Yes
Uh right, we'll go south first because I have no I should be the north first
What was up here?
I think I already got yeah already got over there which is fine. There should be
Oh
There's another ting. Please do not ask for the one kinstone. I don't have I will absolutely annihilate. Thank you
Okay, we're making progress
Take care of the legs. We need them
The stream's so relaxing. Oh wait until I get into a fight and then it's over
Thank you for listening to me at lower volume. So I don't break anyone's eardrums because uh, yeah
easy
steady
You complete a heart container fantastic
Oh, we did it. We did it. We did it fantastic
Maybe
This place is massive
I can't even see if there's any enemies, you know
Wow this place is humongous
Humongous what
We
Where the heck am I going?
Is there a gorgon piece?
Whoa, I didn't realize I had a vicinity type thing. Is there a gorgon piece here?
No, I've got your baby
If I just ignore it, can it hurt me? Yeah, it can't hurt. Oh jack in the bean. Stop
Would you climb my beam? Sorry. Don't don't answer that. Don't answer that
Also, Strani, I want you to know how you sit as rude circulation like it's caught off
I lean with my legs against the desk, but I lean
So hard. Oh, we got heart piece. That's fantastic. I lean so hard
That there's like massive marks on my leg. I don't have my phone
Um with me, but I could take a picture and show you but like I absolutely destroy the circulation
Like there's indents as red as anything right now. It's really bad
It's 10 million uh runes enough for sure to keep farming
In in elden ring
You farming elden ring right now
I forgot no emmy today
Uh, is there a merchie today? Is there a merch in dice today?
Leg down is real
Wow right, where did that?
No, okay. Well, there was something down here
I can't see those
I can't see if there's an enemy so I'm just like swiping into nothing
Okay
Oh, there's a chest. Okay. Okay. It paid off. It paid off. It paid off. Don't worry about it
Okay, I like that gorgon gorgon gorgon gorgon gorgon
Sorry, I'm very excited to help see all his buddies come together to help
It's 10 million runes enough. Alright level up don't don't lose your runes
Oh, they're gonna do
They're gonna break a wall. Yes, is there any cheaper doing fall guys? Uh, mercy
I don't know. I think you showed us some marks on your foot on the swiss room. Yeah, that's gym
That's for
Stimulian not in that way. That's like for
Stamming on my feet. I have permanent scars on my ill-fee bows because of that. That's just me
Uh, right, that was good. We went this way now. We just need to go up and then we have finished whatever location this is
T-minus five hours for mercy. Can I complete the game in five hours and 100% it? I actually do not know
Wow, this is a big cavern
Big cavern. We should have picked up them butterflies that sped things up a bit
Where is this that want to come out here?
Oh, I I want to come out here. Thank you
Like this just in case you fall in the water
Must be
Yeah, okay, there's nothing hitting the wall. Wow. Okay, that was good. I like that
Any other child you want to play in the future?
Um, cameo and viva pinata are coming up in july. I'm going to focus on getting a butt ton of gamer score
um
So it will take me a hot second to
Get that where the heck are we going?
We're going so long
Is it stairwell?
No, it's a chest. What is it? What's inside?
Okay, I'll take the shells because we do need them. So I'm not that mad. Okay. I'm not that mad
Castle crashers could definitely see that
We've got a four man collab coming up. Um on uno
um
And then I think emmy broke the news
If I'm not mistaken
Question mark, hopefully should it break the news or I'm breaking the news and it's not really meant to break
Um, oh, that'll be the freaking piece that strip it hanging. Um
So did I go up there as a wean?
Oh, did I go in here?
Can't get me no
Oh, I've already been in here. Okay
Oh, keep talking nobody explodes can be fun. That is not a game for me. I tried it, but I'm like
Different strokes for different folks. Oh, whoa steady on refunds
Yeah, what's this? Can I train with you? Yeah
Are you the one that rejected me?
I you have found if you train with me. Would you like to train? Yes
We're gonna learn something new now. You will learn a dangerous technique for day
The peril beam first you must have only one heart second use your last and some strength and swing your sword. That's it
Yes, I understand
So there's no turning back for one must feel the technique
Position
Oh, so it comes back if I'm on one health, okay, I comprehend
Okay, we've got another scroll. That's good. That's good. What do you need? Oh something new something new
Oh, where's that top left before the grave area
What's in say North Hyrule Field, yeah
Okay, do you trade anymore or teach me anymore or is that you taught me everything, you know
Now there's nothing more I can teach you. Okay. There is one in the swamp that can teach us something
All right, we are just gonna jump in the water
We grab
As if that thing just aim bought on the arse
Oh
I'm trying to remember
Have we done this properly
Max health or one. Yeah below limit do that sort of thing now. I know this is how we got to this location
But
I just want to check there's not a gorgon tree
Stop
Wrapping me up. Uh, okay, so we have done it in this area
So we just need to know is that the only one in this area then?
Will this be a chest?
Yeah, okay chest
Um, wait, am I losing it?
Am I losing it? I think I'm losing it. Oh, well, whatever. Uh, we've already traded the gorgons
We don't need to anything else in here. Uh, we'll go small and navigate the map as a wee one
Uh, we'll just double check this little minish in here. Is there a minish in here?
I
Forget that we can swim so I don't need to deal with that lily pad anymore
Famous last words bro famous last words don't kill us
Oh, but we need to make triple quadruple sure because if we win a hundred percent in the game
We need to go all the way and uh
At least I can swim back and I don't need to deal with it
But over there yeah, jeez
There we go. Was there
No, there's literally not even a minish here, so I've wasted my time
Okay, we can do this at least
Oh, you have got to be absolutely kidding me
They did that to me twice
They do this to me every time
Oh
Now we may have already done
I think I've actually already done whatever this is up ahead
But just to make sure just to make sure
Oh, no, no, no, okay. Thanks. Thanks for no thanks already done it
All right, let me just go back
Oh my god, I love that. I'm like a tiny little speck on the screen as well
Did we do the one that's over here?
Wait, was there not one over here?
I'm going crazy
We already did this one just to make triple sure
Okay, did you want to fuse
You hear it steal my bean aren't you?
It's yours
Um, I thought is it this side?
Oh, yeah, we've not done this we didn't have the light source what we do now
Oh, ah
All right
Do not fall off because it takes me like half an hour to get back up
Okay, not bad not bad. I like this cave. I like this cave because it's not difficult. I like it
I guess a kingstone piece
Uh, it'll be important. It'll be important. That's fine
Right, why would you give me water if there's nothing hidden in here? Hmm, but there's nothing in here
Red red
Oh, right. Okay. So we've got that kingstone piece. I'm sure it means we can do something
Get bean done. How dare you
I'm guessing I can oh I can
Am I supposed to be no, I was gonna say I don't think I'm supposed to be tiny here
All right, I can't go up there. I've just been there. I've been there. Wasn't there something bottom left? Am I losing it?
I
There's a crack there
How would I get to the crack?
Up here. No, I can't take the stairs. I'm too weak for the stairs. Sorry
Well, I'm about as ready as I can possibly see for shadow the earth tree
And I've already been there. I can't take the stairs right. I think I've done everything I possibly can in this area
Which I'm fine with
You could do
Am I sure that's everything I can do though
Oh, I feel like I'm missing something but whoa, I don't know
Uh, then he can what I'm missing but it's okay. It's okay. We'll get through it
Okay
Oh, we need to explore long long ranch which I've no done
Oh, we need to explore the whole map which I've no done
Oh, there's the tingling there. How'd I get to you on the ranch? I need to go in the ram ranch
But
What does going small do it puts me in there, but I don't need that you guys have hearts. Oh, you do actually surprisingly
Uh, I've not done mount serially
Hmm
I oh I've already done this. Okay. Okay. Okay. That's fine. Um
Ah, okay. Okay, we're getting somewhere we're getting somewhere
Something new
I'm so cute in pixel form
Whoopsies
Okay, red. Perfect. We need it for future trees
And art you never have three. I need one more. Oh, that's fantastic. Oh, those are the worms
That's the first time I've ever seen the dang one
Uh, I assume
Yes, sorry my stomach just internally farted if you heard that one
Yeah, you like that. You like hearing my stomach internally farting
Are you gonna move mister? You know what puddle of water in the middle of the pasture. There's something hidden under it. Yes
Are you gonna get out of the way? Thank you
Thank you
Okay, I think if I talk to this cow there has to be a kinstone piece because why would the game want me to come
All the way over. Oh, that was too close. I thought I'd be ground chuck for sure. Wait
Oh, I can't do anything
That's it. I'm picking up this pot and throwing out when I'm tiny. Wait, so there was a waste of I didn't need to do any of this
Oh, well. Oh, well, we tried we tried. What's this?
Water dish that we can swim through baby
Is there like anything not that's a dead end right? Okay cows. Don't block me. I'm just trying to get back, okay
I said don't
Don't do it. I have to wait on this cow moving away
Yes. Yes. Keep going
I'll bite your ankles like a herder
Oh my god, is there a high she's a goat
He's stinky. Oh, I've already done that. But is this not how I get up to that tingle up there?
Yes, it is how I get up to that tingle
Oh my god, that was lucky
No, no, that's stinky
Right, if we can get more green we can go back to the original tingle
And then we've unlocked whatever that is
Because there's one more. Can I get green please? No, okay. I guess it. Oh, no. Wait, hold on. It's faster just to jump off the map
Yeah, jump off the site not off the map
Please don't participate in any dangerous behaviors
All right, isn't there something up here I need to possibly high probability I think
Go we and go across the bridge sure say no more fam
What are is the cross here? There's a hole in the ground. Hello. Okay, where are you here?
I'm getting a bit Confucius, you know
Call me a philosopher
And I assume the whirlwind is just to get over here. Is there anything special over here though?
Not really. I'm seeing
No, let's just to get over there. Okay. I think we've done what we can in this immediate vicinity
Unless
Spank
Oh, I've not unlocked that waterfall
But there is a chase here
200 rupees. That's 30 cheeky getch upon for us on a heart. We did it
How many hearts is that? Oh, sorry. I'm in the war. Oh, why not?
Oh, I saw it coming. Oh, he can jump in me. He jumped in my money
He actually gave me more in the end
Ah
Oh
Okay, we can now buy 90 getcha
Sorry shells. They're not even called getcha. I'm just oh
Yeah, definitely do not want to be messing about you
Gorgon
Are you here?
Nope. Well, there are chests though, so
50 perfect
50 perfect. We actually might need to go to town because we're already at 600 coins again
All because of our
Journey
Yeah, unfortunately didn't unlock the old waterfall here. So that's a definitely come back to moment
Ow that hurt. Don't do that again
Um, let's get the Pegasus boots on so we can get that heck out here
Are we a hundred percent in I am very tempted to 100 percent
Did I trade with the guy up here?
Uh, I am very tempted you
Did we a hundred percent you for you? Oh, I didn't
You
That was lucky that was lucky. I was like great another one that I don't have the thing for
A swamp again
There is so much happening at the swamp. I'm not even kidding
So so much. I think we're gonna have to buy green keystone pieces in town as well because this is getting a bit
It's getting a bit difficult trying to you know, I keep everyone happy
It's not working
Uh, because Tingling's asking for stuff I didn't have what is even in me
What is this?
We believe in you you can do it. Oh, yeah
Oh, how much have we got now? Oh, right. We're get we're gamma time gamma time gamma time
We can get six more figurines
Uh, I don't think this is the one that I've been in six more figurines
And I can see all the red
Did I hear gamma speak a hundred percent of the game? Are there achievements?
Are there any achievements for a hundred percent? No, this is like old game
That doesn't do that kind of stuff for you theories
Uh, I'll grab one of you. Sorry
Oh, no, I said I'll grab one of you. Is that a grab? Yes. Thank you. Yeah, we do need a cheeky grab
My apologies. Uh, I might not be that fun being in a jar, but then again
That's all I'm gonna say tea
I've not unlocked those two areas. So there's not even a point in going down
Ah, I've not unlocked it
Not unlocked it
All right, we will now do mount cereal after we hit the tune lads. We're going gambling on the tune
Or the pockies, uh, if you're not too confused with hit streamer pocky main, and
Wait, he doesn't restock
He doesn't restock unless I buy all the kin stones
I thought he would constantly restock
Sorry, but I'm here for the gacha
Give me another hundred of these
Back when all you got was the self satisfaction of knowing you did it literally
Just joining what you're gonna do with that fairy in the dark. Look, we were talking about fairies yesterday
And I was like, I get it. I get it
Okay
Great, let's see how much we can get we can get seven new
Gacha I have no idea what number we're at. Please drop a green kin stone. Don't be shy drop a green kin stone
You know you want to
You know you want to hello
You're back. I am back. I would like to give you all my shells
But not the ones in my hair. These are my shells. There are many shells like it in this world, but these two are my
84 pair
pair roll
Kin stones more like kink stones
Thank you. Thank you. I think I may have fucked up though
I
Why does he even want the shells? I don't know
Some people like collecting things
They ruined no me. No chinese food. Oh, no, it's a chinese shop
I'm brawley legend. Thank you for the the tip of the super chat
Where we want to remember whatever way floats you wrote the tip of the super chat your choice
um
How's the chinese shop 16 probability if we weren't putting them shells down
Oh no
It might be it might be look for bread time
Hold on a minute instead of that so raven i'm getting a vision that
Wait a minute guys. I'm getting some bodily function movements internally
It's not looking good. I can't believe it. I might need a I need a cheeky break. I might need a cheeky break
I think it might be a loafer clock
Uh
What do you mean by that? What do you mean by that?
See some of each of us do an idol meeting here we drop loaves of bread
Uh, I don't know how you're uh, you know, there's other euphemisms such as dropping the kids off at the pool
I have heard that 14 percent. This is this probability is dropping fast
Yes, I want to trade for a hundred percent guarantee
Wearing flowers
This is me wishing my gacha had a function to put more tickets in
I mean
Technically, that's why gacha is gacha the more money you put in the more likely you are to like win
Oh my god, I just want an internal fart if you hear that
Uh, I think that loafer bread's coming faster than I first anticipated ladies and gentlemen
Um
Yes, I will do 88
We are just calling them unholy
Oh, no, right, uh, I'm gonna go for uh
Oh, oh emergency viewer meeting me tell the girls how fantastic they are and uh to keep it up
Um, I will also make a cup of tea while I'm at it
But if you need to uh go and stretch your legs wink wink. Yes stretch your legs. Yes
Was that yes, yes
Oh, no, that's not how it works. Just because the Chinese is shot. He doesn't even give me money
Uh, yeah, but anyway, uh, we're gonna go for a bio hazard break. Do excuse me. Uh, should be a couple of cheeky minutes
Uh, but I'll make a week up a tea as well. That's probably what's helping it
Come on is all the sugar and all the honey in the tea
Okay, I'll be right back
Are you squidding me right now?
Oh
I love you, but straw me cuttles
Are you squidding me right now?
Oh
I was unsuccessful
Are you giving me fucking money when i'm away trying to fucking squeeze out a job? What are you doing?
What are you doing? Why is it a scroll up and you guys are giving me money?
I pour doomsday
Doomsday dan I poor sorry
Calm chaos. I love feature burst running calls
Why are you giving me money for going for a job? What's going on here? Now hold on a minute. Hold on a minute
I've made a cup of tea. I was very unsuccessful in my endeavors
Um, however, I think I've probably done one of the biggest wraps in a very long time
Um, I've got a cup of tea
Um, I've had to leave my door open
Because gimley is now losing her absolute mind
I don't know if people will come in but if you if you hear paper paper
If you hear plastic rustling, she's found plastic to chew on which on the rip off of her and spank her out there
Um
Okay, one more one more. Yes. Yes. Yes one more probably
Blue super chats to flush it that that is awful
Please do not roleplay as my toilet water via your money
Haha, please do not roleplay like that. Okay
Um, as long as you're having fun, you can just post the water emoji for free. How about that?
The braptuber. No, we're we're still peeler at this stage. Honestly
I might add to it. I'm tempted to add to it. Oh, that's one of the
Fantasies I should actually mention. What were we doing? I think we're going mount cereal, aren't we?
Yeah, we are
Mount cereal
I
you
Oh, hello, link. I uh, yeah, if you have an antibot, I'll just ask anytime. Sure
Thank you
As long as it doesn't come beam in your stop, that's literally what it would be called as well
Right, we're gonna take mount cereal
cereal. I know it's not cereal, but it's
Don't jump on me
Uh, right. I've already done that, so you don't need to worry about that
If that's the shortcut down, I assume I've already nuked whoever's in here
Uh, so much fun. Oh wait, I've not been in here. Did I run out? Maybe I didn't have enough bombs at the time
I'll take the money though. Fine tens. Poor things have been stuck in that cave. First thing I do is take one of their friends and leave
Uh, I'm just checking if there's anything that looks like I need to bomb at or something
Hmm, not that my elf I see. Havern
Daverny Davern
What about yellow super chat? Oh is that one? I cannot trade. No, sorry. I don't need any bombs
But thank you for the offer though. I'll get lost. You get lost. You
Yeah, your business scrub you. Oh, got him
Right, actually, I may just claim to the it seems like it's going to be like way faster just to claim the hill
Absolutely ruled that guy by accident. Oh, you can shortcut with the rot. Yeah
Yeah
There was a cavern that I couldn't do
I thought this would work. Or is this just how I'm supposed to actually, no, it must be the other cavern. Sorry
There was a cavern that we needed to explore with an item that I didn't have yet
If I need an else this guy, oh our cults groups. Damn, shoot me off. This one
I'm pretty sure it's a cave
No
This cave?
Short cut to the bomb. So then what's this? Wasn't there no a cave like?
Is it this? Yes, it was this. Oh one of the four tails apart. Yeah
Oh sugar. Oh my god. Oh, it's behind the door
Oh
And things
And he's got a special kind stone for us. Let's go
His name is gray blade
What does he unlock for us the water falling the swamp? Yeah, we're hitting up the swamp next because we're pretty much done everything in the dang swamp
Um
Yeah, you've missed a lot of bomb spots monkeys
Believe it or not. I'm gray blade and I'm a train. Would you like to train? Yes
You will learn the roll attack roll and then as soon as you get up scream. Hiya
Yes, I understand
But one must feel the technique position
Oh
Wow charge attack. Okay. Okay. We'll charge. I like that
Wait, oh, that's so good. That's a good one. I like that
We've got the roll attack. Is that all you can teach me master gray blades. I think it is that cat
Hi, gimli. Do you want to say hi?
There's nothing left to teach. Okay. Do you want to see do you want to meow?
Oh, she she doesn't really talk
Uh, gimli and viva actually don't talk at all
I know that think about it. You guys like never meow. Um a bit concerning. Should I be worried darlin?
Do you want to do kinton? No, you don't that's okay. You don't have to
Uh, whoops, I probably could use that saying but hey ho. Hi gimli. Are you happy to be in the stream?
Oh, are you all excited to be in the stream?
You're not supposed to be here. You're not baby girl. We can't help it
Oh, she she's on the floor doing the little claw thing. Um
What else is there? I'm sure on the actual mount that we have to claim there is like something on this
That is my yes
Pets for gimli. Oh, they're petting you gimli. The reef ones are petting you darlin
Okay, we need the wall because there was like loads of stuff. I know I probably should do that
Watch out for falling. Oh, what are you doing? Oh, you climbed my chair. Oh, no, don't play. Don't not with the wires
This is when this is when I have to take you out the room because you start playing with the wires
That's not it's not what those are for gimli
I
Rollin around on the floor like crazy right now. She's so happy to be in the stream room. You're late in the stream
Because you might you might do something like
Is that all we unlock? No, there was a guy up here wasn't there was we need to treat him like that
Oh
Wires are so fun though
Literally emmy and her emmy told me her rats like to chew through everything. I'm like, better not chew through. You're done
3d. Oh
Oh, no, don't no, no, no, no the table darlin. No, you can't be on the the jump down. Okay jump down
Right, so either sit behind me on the chair or jump that right. Hold on. No, she's done. She's done. Sorry
She's
Good girl
Got him pranked him. She thought I was coming with you
But pranked her. Yeah, sorry. She she was jumping on the table and I'm like, I can't I can't I can't have you on the table darlin
Absolutely pranked. So sorry gimli's but
It is what it is
We should not banished for bad behavior or anything. She did banish because I can't have her
Oh, I see it. I see it a heart a heart a heart
Okay, I'm not going that way. Ha ha. We'll go this way. We'll go this way because I can't deal with other one
Uh guru guru guru no guru
Look at this skill
Look at that skill and bait and can't can't get enough from the piece
Take a piece of my heart now, baby
I
Banished right then
Did you teach? Oh, no, I don't teach cats that trick cats are
Uh
They don't need to be oh
I cannot believe I didn't know you could wallop those. I thought they were just like a paramount enemy
That's so silly
Uh, but no, I never taught my putters any twigs. I don't uh, I don't know they're
They're cats really performative animals
Um
I have had to teach them to let me pick them up. So
I was
Had a weird like stance of like, oh, I won't pick up my cat because they don't like it type thing
But then I realized if there was ever an emergency I need them to be able to leap into my arms
Um, thankfully no emergency is ever occurred. Well other than
Oh, yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. This is exactly what we want
I'd a cat that leads play bitch. Yeah, teach me to come on. Come on
You want to teach me to do that?
There's a solid wall no doubt about it. Is this the last one we've unlocked a chest of some sort
I got a brother and a sister cat recently and there are
Uh, they are too keen on getting held. Oh, they aren't no it takes it takes a long time for a cat
If you think of it imagine something eight times your size picking you up like it's quite it's quite a lot
But over time over time
There's normally only one pair of caverns
Anything else
Oh
Yes, but you have to teach us to
H3o
H, you know H3o is technically right. Hello
I'm the hermit
Do you do anything else? No, okay. He just sits here. He's just happy to be here
Um, I think that's all we can do on the mountain because up ahead is like actual like quest and stuff
We've already seen the fairy
So I guess we'll go to the swamp already. Yeah
All right
Okay, now that we can swim
Okay, this is just a snake room
If only you were eight times my size, I'll wait until you hear about a zoo's lore
Okay, there's a little thing here
Back in the tiny
Oh, this is a vast map though
Oh a booty fly you call a joy you can now dig faster than before
Are you squid mirroring?
Curious
I am rewatching the member stream of the forbidden tail list
I didn't realize you had a gen 2 commission waiting. I already tipped on it, but here is some extra chocolate luck
Wait, what?
500 am I I need my glasses on unironically where my is that actually say 500 or are you fucking trolling right now?
Holy shit, what the fuck?
500 that are for love. Thank you. Hello. What the ink literally what the ink?
Um, I've kind of
I've said this before I'm happy to fucking hell 500. Thank you. Jesus
um
I have said this before
But basically we make a route a racially and this is terrible. This is the only way you can describe it
We make a racially ambiguous person and then
And then we can chocolate fire them if they're chocolate because you can't have a white chick on a chocolate
But you can have a chocolate on a white chick
Example she be chocolate
But she be she be she be's cooking
um
Holy sugar. Ah, that is a lot of money. Thank you
No, it's true. No, it's true. It's true. It's true
You can't have a white chick on a chocolate, but you can have a chocolate on a white chick, you know what I mean
Surely that makes sense. That was a sense, right?
Uh, right we need to dig under there
Wait what now? Yeah, no, it does make sense. Yeah. Yeah, okay good
I might have said it the wrong way by accident, but you know what I mean
Uh
Oh
Right, is there a box 50 I'll take it 50
We live in a society
Honestly, I don't mind like I
remember when the eyes were teased of the models and someone quote tweeted it and they were like
Oh my god, they're actually coming out with a chocolate
And like it really made me think like
Holy shit, y'all motherfuckers don't get any love, do you? Um
Because everyone's too busy being weird about it. Um, but it just wasn't even a it wasn't even a second thought like
um, so as I said
Azura was designed chocolate
But we then when it came to model production, we made her racially ambiguous
Because we didn't have a choice. Okay, we didn't have a choice. We had to make her racially ambiguous because we didn't know who was gonna get her but
Um
We could make maker chocolate. Um
Am I being trolled? I'm being trolled. Um, sorry puzzle time. Hold on. Um, and basically like not to give anything away, but um
You know, then you'd be surprised if another racially ambiguous pops up. Um
Because just
Not many designs really
Wow, what's this?
A dojo. Hello
Swordsman ship is spirit. I am the finest or
Maybe second finest swordman scar blade. Oh because he's got a scar. I like that. Thank you again for that tip
Fucking 500 that's insane. Please do not tip anymore. That is an insane amount of money. Thank you though. I really appreciate it. Um
But yes, um
Basically ambiguous slash chocolate or eating well at veiler. I assure you headquarters are
Looking after you. What am I doing spin blade?
You speed up your great spin charge. You won't have to hold the button as long anymore
Oh, what? That's so fast
Is she edible?
We need more chocolate. Well, I thought I thought you weren't so right
This is just me being dumb like surprise surprise me being dumb named better joe. Um
But I thought
That you weren't supposed to say like chocolate and all that
But then when azura came out and everyone was like chocolate chocolate. I'm like, oh wait, so
chocolate's fine to say
Because I didn't know
But now I'm like, yeah chocolate
Um
But yes, right. We've already been there. That's fine. Um
So, okay, we did unlock a few bits and bobbies here. Okay, we locked like a lot of bits and bobbies
And some people find out I thought they did too, but then everyone was like, yeah chocolate and I was like, oh, right
Okay, we're doing this right. Okay. Okay chocolate. Let's go chocolate. Yeah, chocolate feature first
Let's go like I didn't know
Um, but like, you know, I'm glad. Uh, yes, you please do not worry about
a azura being the only
Rashly ambiguous or chocolate. Um, you eat well at veal or I assure you that much
um, and
She be mere may not have something in the work smile smile. She may have something in it
I just gonna be one of those things where I go po po po po po and it doesn't work
and
That's the weirdest shit I've ever heard
Okay, let's go this way
I think it has to do with fetishize and finkle a rich normally isn't what they want, but they're not veal or it's a fine
Yeah, maybe I should ask Azura and she stares
Um, okay. I've already gotten more for the heck was here. I completely forgot. However, I can swim
I
I'm back from being stepped on by she be did you get wrecked under her a mungus?
Oh, I haven't been here. Okay. Okay. I'll take it red piece again. Okay. I'm taking a sipping tin of my tea
I can't believe it. I can't believe people know realize that I am h word for
a
Cheeky bit of choco
That's terrible. Please don't actually take anything. I say seriously. I am brain rot is from the core
Um, there was a water thing over here. I'm like 99 percent sure
Yes, there was I don't remember going in it if we have been here this
I
Have we been here?
Oh
Fucking hole in one don't mind me. I was uh one in five
It's kind of like saying
Need someone to be positive. Oh, she's almost died there because I was reading
It's kind of like how saying something needs to be positive and not directly. We love the hmm
I love that terminology
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa
Uh, I do not want to lose health because that laser thing is
Oh, that's cheating. That's right. That's how you get nuked into the strat sphere
Oh wait, can I just deflect?
Oh, I can just deflect. Are you joking me? These guys are so easy
I can deflect of course I can deflect. Why wouldn't I be able to deflect?
You totally neglect this area clearly don't at least you have
At least you have been to ask this stuff and tell people I hope yeah, like I thought it was bad, but then like
I am like chocolate was like celebrating
Azura and I'm like wait, so
It's a term fan
Wait
Now you all calm down in here you all calm down calm calm
All right, give me the goods
Sorry
Yeah, whoever said that sneezes are like one-fifth of a honestly agreed. It feels really nice
Oh, I got a new one. Did I get a new one?
I think I've got a new one. Sorry. I'm too busy. Bless you. Thank you
It gives on high. Thank you. Well
Random German noises, okay
Did I walk past this? I must go
Okay, now I can't do anything else being weak. So we're gonna go back to being big
Unless I can go over this
Sure, what's over here? Let me know
Uh can't go in there. Yeah, um
Right, okay, we've done all we can being we
How do I get big again? Jeez, this is quite a trick and I have to get big
Oh boy, I better make plans for this after steam. It shouldn't be oh
It'd be very refling that
About to get showered in quality
Um, I honestly thought it's gonna be a four hour stream. We've hit the five hour mark
And we're like no the end is not in sight. I repeat the end is not in
Oh, I'm actually gonna have to
Do that fly thing
No, I can just run across the
Mate, I'm getting so turned around right now. I'm getting so turned around
Where the heck am I?
I need something to claim
We might have a three parer I'm
Moving
That's so terrible that oh see that went a little better
Wait, I've not done that one
Oh, I think I need a poke it in its eye
I wish they would perish permanently my only
My only gripe with this game is just oh and I've gone away. I don't even need to go
What happens if I jump down here? What happens? Hmm?
They're far
You will you teach me now master ugwe?
Though my body may perish swiftly the first you were trained with me. So would you like to train? Yes
This is the technique that I only have mastered only one who holds the sacred blade can perform the great spin attack first
Do a spin attack press the button repeatedly. Yes, I understand
Okay, let's go position
It's a day ending in why so strong any forces are we flings for another 12 hour endurance stream no sleep blood
I like the stories where they're like, oh I fell asleep at the start of your stream and then I got to wake up to you
And I'm like, oh
Okay, I like hurricane spin. That's so good
My wings are like a hurricane
That's a that's a hobbit with wings the smoke. No, there's nothing more. I can teach you you're on your own
So if I'll learn everything
Wait, wait a minute. Oh, no, I have to be small
No, I have to go back
I had I had to go in the sweet lily pad here to go here
Say it so
I will not oh butterfly
You can cause you caught a joy butterfly. You can now shoot arrows faster than before. Oh, I like that
There was something I was supposed to do back here and I didn't do it out of pure laziness. I'm sorry
Oh, I need to finish my teeth. I almost forget
You guys are just so interesting that you're like, I don't think I've ever had like a nice pipe and perfectly temperature tea
I actually woke up from a nap earlier go waking up to use one of the pillagers
I think yeah, someone sent me a marshmallow and they're like, it's actually really nice that no matter what time of day
I get the opportunity to catch you live and I'm like, damn
like that sounds like
I'm like
Addicted and like online all the time
Also, me who is like, yeah, if you two didn't have vodishes, I'd probably pull you for like 14 hours
Yeah, like stream for 14 hours. Yeah
Maybe I do have a problem
But it's a problem
If it has if it's good, you know
Yeah
Yes, having a good day. Oh, I'm having a good day
We're currently mucking about going back to see if we can pick up more hearts before we do this boss fight
We are now missing 16 pieces, which is actually still quite a decent amount in all honesty
um
Unfortunately, I'm not aware where I missed. I need to trade quite a few Kinstone like there's a few waterfalls and stuff to the
Right side of the map that I haven't unlocked. So
You start when I finish working most of the time I just get to watch almost all of the streams that's good timing
Shawnee's the best problem to have it's not a problem if we're all enjoying it
If it's ever a problem and you need to you need to make your
Your issues heard just go on my alt twitter and see if it's a problem after listening
Oh, I just realized link blinks even though you're afk
Okay, finish the tea. Let's see what I am missing
We don't need to deal with that
Is there anything hidden back there? Not that I can tell
Okay, there's quite a few bits and bulbs here. Ow. Don't do that again
Okay, there we go
200 that's fantastic
Oh get your pawn work. Oh, no, we don't have access. This is definitely a Kinstone
Oh, and there's a beanstalk as well
Oh, sorry, I didn't know I thought he was perished but he's not
No, come on
There we go
Uh, wait, don't you be small over here? Oh, wow, I do need to be small from over here
Okay, let's take a little meter
You start streaming just around the time I'm able to get to my pc after work
It's like seven company will I get to raw at my desk bro raw after work all you need to
I used to be physically mentally drained after my wee shifts at the cafe
Although working on the care homes actually probably rougher on the mental and
But my favorite thing about being a waitress was like you'd be like
I forgot the water for table seven when you're like going to bed and trying to sleep. You're like, oh, no
Um, I always like laugh at those memories. You got a piece of heart make four
Oh
I still actually I still remember I served this couple
um
and there was a few
Waitress and waitresses waitress I I don't know. There was a few of us on the floor
But all of us unanimously assumed each other had gotten to that table
And they were sitting waiting for 20 minutes on nothing and I was
More like I felt so bad. I'm like felt so freaking bad. Honestly. Wait. I just under your turn. Um
And I still think about that couple to this day
I feel so sorry
But basically they all made me go because I was the youngest and they were like, well, they're not going to be pissy
Yeah, like a young waitress type thing. So I had to go but they were actually still like super nice. Um, and
Um
Because the owner worked with us like I explained the situation and we didn't charge them for drinks type thing
Like I think it's called cop pain or something like when you don't get the person to
um
Right, we need to switch off this guy
Because he'll run ahead which you really shouldn't do
um
I bet you made bank getting all the tips because you're so charming. Well, funny you mentioned that I had, um
A co-worker who used to send me to get payments from folk because I was like a
A peer very young and I look very young
um
And he was like, oh, they never tip me because I'm a guy but you're a chick
So they'll tip you they'll tip you so you go out and get them to pay like say oh
It's your turn to pay and all that
and
And I
It actually did work. Like I think we tried it and it definitely worked
And
you know
Strongly useful. Yes, I have a face of bobby
Oh
Because it's cutting the grass. Oh, there's a bill. All right. Okay. It's fine
Harris
I think there's an enemy in one of these
Shawnee didn't hit no from the start
Not quite
Of course it works. They proved it in mythbusters. Wait, they didn't mythbusters that you get more tips if you're a chick
I believe it. Oh bomba. How much bomba?
What 100 bomba?
That's actually pretty
too much
I just realized I haven't been checking the maps
There's treasure in the left
In the left
There's treasure that I've not picked up. Okay. I'm actually kind of glad I've actually not gone back into the other temples
Oh, there's treasure in here. What's the treasure? It's a freaking trap shadow wizard money gang
We love kissing spells
They got me
Yay, we got you shells
Okay. Well, that was actually kind of lucky because that I didn't wait. Is there like a thing here?
Oh, there is
Shawnee's passive, let me take your money
If you're cute and nice
Yeah, like I used to read the reviews and I always got mentioned in the reviews like ah, sorry
I took so much pride in my movie waitress job
Like I know some people might like well
You guys wouldn't because you guys are reeflands and you guys get up
But like some people then like oh it used to be a waitress like all you did was serve and like used to clean toilets at the end of the day
And I'm like, yeah, I used to take pride in my work. I love my job. It was so fun and
everything was like such a nice experience and
Yeah, and I got to talk to people from all around the world because um
it was like a tourism cafe and
Like fuck yeah, I enjoyed my job like let's fuck up. Never anyone
You know, some people are like embarrassed about their tail. I'm like no, I haven't made some time like it's a fuck size
But like it's so fun
No one should be ashamed of their job not then maybe like literally
like
I've never been thinking about it was like because I think if you ever like if
If you talk to someone who's like never had a job before and they're like, oh you used to have to clean toilets
Yeah, it's just part of the job like
Someone's taking a fat job a although I will say one thing
I had a really good boss if someone's fucking bombed the toilet. No, I didn't have to clean it
Because my boss was so good like if it was like absolutely fucking nasty as fuck my boss would do it
I don't trust this room
Oh, well, there you go
No, my boss was amazing
It was literally a
Change my life unironically. I know it sounds silly, but saying like oh that job changed my life
But I like it actually unironically that they'll change like trajectory
Um, because I was like very unconfident. I was like so unsure of myself. So
How did I miss this? This is out in the open
Right, let's go south see what happens
Ow
How did I bump off the edge of the map? Right, I'm pretty sure we're supposed to dig here
Oh in the money
Hello, we get to buy another couple of shells with that 800 coins for that
But here uh fairies jump out of those things as well here
Sorry, please don't shoot me. I'm just a little guy
Because you ignored everything basically they got kinstones open. How dare you how dare you accuse me of my terrible gameplay
Even though I've shown it here in 4k
Literally dropping the album having a good boss makes everything so much easier. Oh, tell me about it
Like at the care home
Look, I'm just saying if you ever want to do the care home
I'm pretty sure they committed like
paycheck fraud with me
and because when I like wrapped up my employment
um, I got like extra
500 great British pounds and I had to phone them up and be like you've overpaid me like you've paid me my
Like my wages when I've not worked with you and they were like no no just take it and I'm like
What do you mean just take it like a phone during everything no no just take it just
So basically when I departed from the care home, I got like extra 500 quid from day nothing
We are going to go spend all this money because this is it. Do you mind you're literally in my way in my way
Okay, you can't actually run off into the next segment
A little saucy. Oh, it was saucy. All right
and
I'm not going to complain an extra 500 quid in my pocket. They made me I was off on one
Put it in my wee bank account. Right. We're gonna buy
Out what shells we can because we have far too much money and nothing to spend on
Yeah, care homes are an absolute mess like they constantly change hands of management
They constantly change companies and all of that
They're constantly understaffed a stupid diss amount of understaffing
Um, and they do it on purpose to maximize like earnings and all of that
And it's like, you know who suffers the actual folk in the care home suffer because
It's just chaos like from and the shifts are 12 hour. Oh, forgive me keep them this
The shifts are 12 hours as well like sorry
But the human body is tired after six hours and you're asking like four people to look after like
How much elderly like 60 elderly on a ward type thing? Oh, it's absolutely crazy
Oh, it's like that all over the world. So it's no it definitely is all over like it's pretty outrageous. How many
Okay, we're gonna do five gamble
We must be getting close to being done unless I'm like completely just
blown smoke
It
Okay
Yeah, let's get that probability up because that is uh, there's not even a point in doing the 1% probability
Wait, is it gonna am I not gonna be able to achieve 100% if I put 99 in
Big green to chew
By all the monster adventure manuals
Is that what the post office thing was when she was charging me 200 quid for and I was like not on your bike in
Link between worlds lets you peg his his dash between screens if you play. Yeah
maybe
I need to look at that freaking new game that came out with the trailer
As I said, I'd put it on but probably get copyright. I door mimic appears in the royal crypt
They look like doors, but they're really traps if you get too close to make fall down. What a very unique thing
Indeed
Yeah, she is trying to sell you manuals which are the same price as the shells of 200 mimic hate
Honestly 91
Give me the goddamn getcha. Give me that thing right now
I went in that shop
Demi ma a pi ha appears on mount a cranel
The strange beast hover on preparer like leaves you can pull them out of the sky with a gustar
Does it get one more shell expensive retain?
Yeah, that's what I'm worried about because
It's literally nine percent probability one every nine getcha pulls. Yeah, I'm not doing that
We'd be here for a millennial
A hundred you're going to treat 92. Yes, I am
What do we get a helmasaur roar
Treat yes
Oh
93 yeah, this is gonna get rough
I'm going to know what this man's doing all these shells
Making acroband is although they actually be really cool and acrobat
Oh, how would you put that in a model though?
I always say I'm like, oh, that's such a good idea for a feature bar and then I'm like, how would you even execute that plan?
It doesn't hurt and I forgot to get my blanket for my poor legs. I'm cutting this uh bucket
78 8 of a new one one in four roughly
It's sorry three in four roughly
A rupee like appears in caverns dungeons
This rupee like has a rupee dangling from its headstock the clever lure attracts greedy and delicious heroes
They jump in me
Right, let's see what is going on here
One two three
Four
Four five
Six
Seven eight nine ten ten
No way we're actually going to do it
I thought it was impossible, but we're gonna do it. Uh, what do I need to adventure next?
Top
Did I go in the waterfall? I can't remember
I think it's the I love monster goes major but many of the best
Once has a bottom half a side in tragic. There's a lot of stuff where it was like in theory good
actually
You know executing it
Uh, sorry, I'm a bit flabbergasted on where to go. Maybe bottom and try bottom
Western world. Why not? I'm not really explored that. Have we have any question mark?
I am I'm still missing like a lot though
Oh
Oh, no, I did I did
Um, okay, maybe back over on this area again
Uh, no see that these are events
I need to trade kinstorm pooses and that was where the heart one was. Yeah, but it's fine
Oh, you're not getting me. You're not getting me. Okay. You're all getting me. You're all getting me. They're jumping me
So this was what?
Ah, okay. This is where I want to be. Yes. Okay. We're cutting the grass. Sorry. We're going on a grass cutting mission
It's really important to high rule that we cut the grass. Okay. It's very important. I assure you
It's not a waste of time whatsoever
Okay, percy you you goober
I knew I'd remember his name. Lawn cuttings. Lawn cutting more like. Oh, see see see we already unlocked something
Beautiful beautiful. What does this do?
Western. Yeah, so he's unlocked. Oh, perfect. They fit. That's it. I got it now the perfect verse
Adapter whole these two or one two lost and broken halves like me and my beloved
Do you want to go back to your house? Oh, perfect. Okay
So do you not stay in here anymore? No, he's got right. He's gone back to his house. So hopefully he gives us something for that
I'm cutting the grass cutty cutty grass. I'm cutting the grass. Well, I'll take the end
What's down here then money again, I'm not gonna say no. I'm not gonna say no
We've got we've got things to buy. We're gonna have to buy that newsletter from that lady
What was this did I come this way? No, I have already been here. Um
We cut the grass cut the grass and really fast
I don't know if this is actually faster, you know that I'm just getting hurt now, right?
I should maybe pay attention a bit my bad
I'm getting over zealots
Is that a word?
She asked nicely
Is there anything here?
No, I think there
Wait, so I can go downwards
Let's go and meet him in his house and maybe we can unlock something for doing it. Hi
Oh, no, what's wrong?
Oh dear Link won't you listen to my verse when I finally returned to my home sweet home a stranger was there
I'm an extremely shy person. I just can't talk to someone. I don't know
Sad to put my feelings on a verse
Well, I was gone. Did you break in to practice your thieving art even if you robbed my home?
You can never steal my heart
Uh a dark room settles my soul. I say do not turn the lights on I say. Mmm. It's giving demonic possession
Sorry darlin
Wow
You're an enemy
Oh dear you find me. Don't tell anyone. Oh
Extortion casual extortion. Hello
Okay, and now he's here. Oh my link. Thanks to you. I can finally go back to my house
It's been totally rearranged, but I think it looks good. I put my feelings of gratitude to a verse
to
The way made safe I come back home to find me inside all alone in my chest my poor heart aches
But for you I feel the deepest thing wait. Did that ring or did I say that wrong?
My dresser is entirely stuffed with these icky blue shells. Would you clean them out for me?
Yes, I'll clean them out. Yes, I will clean them out. Thank you so much. I appreciate it going with cute little heads
So you don't want to trade any kingstone. You're happy. Yeah, you happy bean. Okay, happy bean
Okay, we're gonna go back to the minish realm
Because
Um, I think we can now give over our magical green liquid. She'd let me give over the green liquid
What a peaceful little game honestly I say that is if when we do the boss fight, I'm not going to be screaming
Uh, just as a warning, uh, I'm not very strong at the boss fight. I
Five minutes are over for sure for sure. She remembers. I know
I don't remember having
Oh
That was so pretty
Look, I succeeded in growing yellow. Thanks to you. I'm so grateful, right? I'm working. I need yes
You can most certainly have it all yours, buddy. Yes
Thank you welcome come back when the blood's awesome
I said
No, I gotta wait. I gotta be patient. Oh, fine. I'll go. We do question
Blood for the blood garden
I'm just gonna check I didn't leave any treasure in this place
Because I might have left some twitters just in case I'll check the dungeon map
No, I cleared it out completely. Okay, that's what I like to see. That's what I like to see a little cheeky heel here
And thank you very much. I appreciate it
We successfully grabbed everything into Twitter
Ink for the ink goddess
Uh, was there something to the right?
I
So tiny
Wait, can I go this way then? Oh, I guess if you wanted to come out on this side, you can
Um
Is there anything I'm in there?
I think so
Wait, was there something back here I missed? Oh, I've not opened it up yet. That's why
Her let's see what if I've got the gemstone that that tingle wants I do right
We're gonna go to the last tingle guy which was like
north
Northwest ish
Surely surely I know what I'm doing northwest ish
It might wait. Oh someone said dig here. Hold on. We need to dig
Oh, okay, we're digging we're digging we're helping we're helping
Here I'll help you right on that tail that you're working on
Jeez this field is rubbish. Okay, I'll take that though
Can you burn the thing? Oh
Wow
I actually did give me what I wanted. Stop. There's so many bulls right this
Oh, okay another green that's all I like to see that's all I like to see
A ruby
Lovely soundtrack 10 out of 10
Okay, here we go here we go here we go
All right, that'll do it. That'll do it. Right. Do you guys want to trade or anything any mini? Nope any mini are satisfied
We've already done under their hoose. Sorry. Just breaking your stuff in that
Lovely scrawny to go with
um
I'm trying to remember I guess top left that mount cereal
Wait
Is this where the guys are?
It is right. Let's check up on the guys. Let's see how they're doing because I'm pretty sure we unlocked a chest
We did
Don't mind us. How's it going? Do any of you want to trade? No you don't
That's fine. Hopefully that's the last one down there
Oh, sorry
I feel this soundtrack
I didn't actually think I was going back for the time
Excuse me pardon me come through. Excuse me pardon me come through
Uh, excuse me pardon me come through. Excuse me pardon me
Oh
Uh, he's there. How'd I get there? Was it underneath? Must have been underneath. Sure. They sure they was underneath
Yes, okay, it must have been this there's no way it wasn't I refused to believe it wasn't this
Nope
We've already done that. Oh, look how fast that is and then we picked up that butterfly
I don't
Yes, yes
Here you're you're the one piece you won. It's all yours. Please don't ever ask for something so specific again
Okay, we will go back and investigate one earth is in this chest the panel for the length of me remember what it was
Okay, they do fit perfectly did this guy one did we do this guy?
I
Did you ever check out that watery spot? Yes, I did. Thank you for asking that watery spot literally
I do talk to this character about fusing. I have terrible news. I do not know the characters by name
You're gonna you're gonna have to be a bit more specific than in certain name here. Sorry
How do I open this bridge?
Oh
Hold on give me that right now
I'm gonna sworn you can turn this bridge on
Wow, wow another trainer
Do you want it? No, he doesn't want a kinstone, but that's fine. I am great blade train with me
Yes, I would like to train with you a great blade. Show me your way
Duration of the great spin
Wait, so I can like do it for a g spinning spinning spinning spinning spinning spinning
Wow
Wait, so you just wait under this waterfall the entire time for me to show up
It's like
Do you do anything else for me? There's nothing more you must train yourself. Okay
Okay
You can just jump over the bridge. Oh
What's in here already picked up
Then what this is the way to get to the
The graveyard and that
Yeah, we're on the graveyard
Okay, I don't really need to come up this way, but hey home. We'll come back to the graveyard and I'm the mental
Unless
I saw that other chest there's no way
Hey
Oh my god
Yes, 100 shells as well
No way that's such a um
Such a hidden place
You can't go any further that way. We're just fine, baby. You
So then what's in here
That's just where we were. Okay
More shells gamer time
Was it this bomb left one?
And then we can see what it what this is all about
Red piece. Perfect. That's what I like to see
Okay, okay, what is in this chest?
Because it's big whatever it is. It's not like a regular chest
It is uh
You've got a magical hold the button when you throw it and use to control its path. Oh
So I can dictate now. Okay
Uh, I need to go buy shells now because I'm starting to get a lot of money on my persons again
We're gonna do we're actually gonna get all the gacha from and where do I need the shop the main shop
Oh, I went past it
Do
Buy the manual first. Okay. Yes. I will go buy the manual
It said you said it was 200 for the manual, right? I'll buy two
I'll buy two
Shells and then I'll have enough for the manual
How many you got in you? Oh, sorry. I like perfectly cover up. I've got
345 so we're gonna go get the manual which is 200
Out my way you're post-a-bam
right
I don't even know what this does. Hello, I'm selling uh swordsman's letter right now. You can buy it. Yeah, absolutely
Thanks for supporting remember to come out as swift as the blade right. What did that do? Is it something new? Okay, there is something new. Hello
Would you like to read it? Sure
Go wall so somewhat it may look like a regular wall, but you may find something you can bought
There's actually easy way to tell and I'm here to teach you build up the power and start sticking things in a wall
If you pay attention, you'll find a spot that makes a different sound continue
Don't give up start mashing buttons. You might be able to escape quickly continue reading
Sliftly gossip the magical boomerang somewhere in Hyrule. You can find a credibly. I just got it
Uh, so this is like just telling me
Oh, no, see you in issue two. I don't have enough for issue two
Manual that's plural. Well, I've just lost all my money. We need to get you first. Okay
100% of gamblers give up before they win or something. I don't know
How many shells all of them
Because then we don't need to put our money towards the shells anymore when we're traveling about
You're gonna trade 95. Yeah, I guess 95 shoes
Unlike the shells there aren't infinite manuals
Spear moblin appears in minish woods. They rush you on site. Yeah, they're great. I don't like them
How many have I got I've got one more roll. Oh, no
Yes, one more trade, please
One more
After getting every figure you can trade them for money, I believe
Actually that may be infinite money glitch because you get five coins for a repeated figure
And one shell to five
A trap appears a very a trap with sharp blades. Yeah
Right, we what was that? We need eight more things. We just need 800
The house has it after getting every figure you can trade them the house has a money on heart. Yes
There's definitely a heart in that like casino type thing
Um
I've lined up a sizable pile of cash for my maybe I should start breeding pets next. No, that's the mean
I think the time has come. I've moved beyond words
Um, that's for gamba wait, I keep going in here, but I've already done it
Breeding the leaflings
I think I've done
What I can
In this area was there someone in school
Oh, the teachers are gone. Oh, they've changed. I have to see the kids off home myself
Yes, you need to look after the wanes, believe it or not. Oh, the children aren't eating anymore
Oh, no one's even playing outside. That's so sad
Gimli I can hear it going up
Uh, I can't remember. Is this the but okay, that's the bomb side. We don't need to do that
Mm-hmm
And a new mpc gonna spawn oh look at the meatball
Uh, right, where have we not we did go down in the swamp
Western
Highlands we've not mocked about in the graveyard
Let's go with the graveyard. I know this seems really weird. We've no mocked about in the graveyard
Can it show them
It's graveyard. Oh, I think it's off a bit more
Wait, is it? No it is
But I can't go that way
Hardly mean for being so rude it wasn't
Hmm
Let's see if there's anything to do in the graveyard that we technically haven't done
Okay
Oh, there's so many sections of the map
The lily pad I forgot to do the lily pad in the swamp. We're gonna go back and do that
I like if you've interacted with it. It's no longer on the map. I actually really appreciate that. Thank you game devs
Um
Post office still needs something to do the placement
There's a waterfall. Okay. Actually, this is like really handy dandy when interested math. It's just
Building
We're to go to the mystic hut. There's a treasure chest and there's a monster. Okay. This is like so I didn't really even did this for you
That's fantastic. Honestly, right? Let's deal with the graveyard first
Let me let me give a light on
Literally such a like quality of item type a quality of life type thing for games to put in
They didn't have to go this hard and yet here we are
Shawnee is close to 8k. I'm going to try and schedule the clapping video. I've already got the artwork. Wait, what's down here?
Is it the same way is it north? Yeah north
North
North left left north
Right, anyway, I'll start from scratch. So north left
Left pressure's up
Same as the beginning yeah north left left
Right
And then up if I'm not mistaken. There's so many enemies here same as to before up. Hold on. Yeah
How do I
Got the ambience is so whoa, I just like face so that goes my bad
I'm gonna check on the grave guy poor guy doesn't get many visitors
So we'll go check on him. How are you doing me? It's been a while been a while. Oh, you good, right? Oh, you're infused yet
I'll take it. I don't know where you're gonna get me
I think she's ignoring the bomb places on purpose wait for
I think I just saw a bomb spot
Bomb the gap on the fence. You just passed the bomb. It's like, oh, how do you guys know these things?
On the fence
Like not like back before the mapping section
Like back before that map section is just the left north north left
The north left left
Are you for real? Yeah, like before the map
Yeah before the maze section. Okay, hold on. Let's get
Uh, please don't do that again. Thanks
A bomb please
Bomba bomba bomba
Ah bomba, okay
See you know the last fairy this must be the dragonfly
It is it's the dragonfly. Hello
Welcome to the adventurer's spring. Would you tell me of the things you've seen on your adventures?
Yeah
The first element you found was the fire element. No, actually it wasn't
Yes, I see now for the next question your grandfather's name is me. No, it's smith
Because he's a smith now for now the next question malaria of mount cereal has seven apprentices. Yes, it does
Yes, I see now for the next question. The blabber knot gives you the ability to understand the minish
Yes
You have lied to me as punishment for your lie. I will reduce your number of arrows to zero
Well, it's fucking skews me hen. I didn't know I needed a
Is it no the jab or not? Oh, not the blabber. Oh, sorry
Okay, ready to get zapped again, I guess
Welcome to the spring. Would you tell me of the things? Yes
Their first element you found was the fire. No, it's not
Oh
There was a miss input miss input come the fuck down
Bruh
She tricked you literally
Like sorry, I didn't answer your fucking riddles correctly. Jesus Christ woman
Yes, I will tell you of my adventures
The first element you found was the fire element. No, it was me
Your grandfather's name is smith
Has seven apprentices. Yes, he does
No, it doesn't see the rope of the current king of high rule daltas is white. No, it's red
Thank you for telling me about your quest you remember also well such a faithful memory should be rewarded with my power
A large quiver. Well, you better fill it up. You fucking skank. You just took all my quivers
All my bows. Sorry
Yeah, that's right. Fill it up
Slag honestly
No, we're not getting a dragonfly vtuber. Sorry. She's just shot that down. I'm absolutely raging
I have to go through this fucking path as well now
Right, uh, what was it up?
Left
Up
Right
Oh my god, I'm so MLG bro
Rip dragon to fly already gone gone before she even could get and it developed because what fuck
I'll see you sure. Let's see what's the dealio here
Oh, he's gonna move and we can interact with something in the town
I don't know why I've been such a nasty little prankster all of a sudden. I feel like a week's been lifted
I feel like I've made up for all my dreadful deeds. Hey spooktor. See you in paradise
Okay, we can get access into the chicken farm now. I'm curious. What are you doing here? Yes
Okay, uh
Butterfly you call a butterfly. Oh, I didn't read what it did though
Well, whatever it did. It must be worth it. Thank you. Thank you
Red piece. I'll take it. Uh, I've already pushed all of these haven't I?
I don't know what that unlocked
But it made the unlock noise
Pushing all these graves
Uh, are you wanting to oh you are thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you
I've only got one of them
I could swim faster man. You can read fast if you read that even I didn't read and I'm the one playing the game
I can't even read that fast
Dig on it. I did try and dig on it before
Right, hold on. I'm gonna come back to her in case she wants to trade multiple times
Ah, no, you came back. I'm so happy in this group, but please make yourself feel at home
Mmm. I mean technically it'll be home once um
So
Is she actually that wrong? Do you want to trade again? No, you've traded out
Um
Hold on. I'll put the v ocarina on a ocarina. Wow
It's that was a graveyard area, right? We'll go to town and see what's going on with that chicken farm
Oh dig the dirt in the group
I did try it. I did try it before I don't know why it wouldn't let me do it the first time if that is actually the solution
Um, right. I need to be we and I need to go inside the chicken house
So I will go in here. Do you want to trade? No, you don't
You should visit the minish. It's probably been five minutes. I agree. It probably has
Right, what's going on in this chicken house?
Oh, shit fucking get me out of here
What the kinstone piece fused and disappeared now? I can't get it now. I can't get it back to anju. I'm still happy
Fucking getting demolished leave me alone
Let's just just got absolutely wrecked and decked who's annish the dog
No, do not go into the cuckoo house seriously
Fewer people means less trash. I'm having a tough time fading. Oh, no, he's a swing kind of swing
Okay, get me to normal size again
Go back three left and three up
Three left and three up
And you is the chicken lady, is she gonna trade me a kinstone? Oh, no
Oh wait, I have these shoes now. I can go to the chickens really fast
I know I don't what can cycle pass that
Oh, well, right. I'm not going for the gold chickens, I guess because they don't actually stay
No, I can't run with the chicken in my hand. No, I'm gonna mess up. Okay. I messed up
I won't go for the golden ones because the golden ones don't stay in your hand
Hmm. Well, it's like I'm still missing a lot of cuckoos, but thank well, maybe if you didn't have some golden bam ones
Oh, I hurt him
Sorry, look a bit of animal violence never really hurt anyone. Just hurt the animal
Maybe if it didn't run halfway across the map, I could actually have a chance to get the dying thing
Oh, no pick it up. All right. There are four. Is that how much you needed?
Time's up. Time's up. Okay
Thanks, here's your reward 10 shells you got 40 doesn't it feel good to help others? How much do you want?
Four of them right one
We got four last time. It's fine. We got four last time two
And then one up here
Oh, you couldn't have been any further away. Could you have been mate? Right four
Fuck off postie. Right there we go. Can I get this golden one to fuck you?
Oh my god, if you spank it he comes closer
There take that you've got a golden cuckoo as well
Okay, I know I can collect five now
Thanks, here's your reward 20. Okay. I'll actually take that and 90 rupees
You still need wait, is she like infinitely helpful?
I
Catch five of them. Okay. We know we can catch five at least
Why is the placement changed lady? They're not supposed to actually
Oh panic panic at the disco. Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no panic the other way you stupid bastard you
Panic the other way bro. Panic the other way. Oh my god. No, they've changed locations
You're not no, no, no, no, this couldn't have gone any worse. No stop
Running away. Just no. Okay. Well, I didn't realize that we're gonna change locations
Uh, what was that four?
Yeah, I believe it was four. I have balls that up. I didn't realize they could change locations. You're so cheeky
Hmm. Yeah, not enough. Yeah
Hmm. There is a finish. Is this the last one?
All right, I need to set up in my gamer chair for this one right they changed locations, which is fine
Okay, you can get picked up first and go
And then who's next uh, you're up here and there's a third one by the water which is perfectly fine
Okay, that's three that's three. Okay. Mm-hmm. Oh, yeah, I'm feeling it. I'm feeling it
Give us a fourth. Give us a fourth. Oh, you're moza
Uh, sorry
Okay, okay. Okay. Mm-hmm. Oh, yeah. Mm-hmm. Okay. Here's a first. Here's a first. That's all we need. We've got a first boys
We've got a fifth
So we need there we go five boom just like that and just to flex on them. Let's go get this golden one boom go that way
Yeah, that's right. That's right. That's okay. Close enough. We got five. That's all that matters
Get them chickens beat them up. Yes. Tame is oh
Thanks. Here's your reward 20 shells. You got 90 rupees another round
Oh, I'm having a heart attack. Did I need to talk to this chicken here actually?
Yeah, sure. Give me a charm. Why not?
You've got fewer shrimp your power in guard will be boosted
Sure
Doesn't actually sound that bad. I'm gonna be honest
Another one right. Let me buy the paper up at the postie before I commit to another one
Because I need all my papers from the postie
Hello, we've got a new issue for you. Yes, give me give me
Oh
Come back later for the rest. I've got 169
Um, right cuckoo. Let's go again. Sorry. Sorry didn't mean to stab you with my
my pointy
reward
Oh, I'm burping away over here. Sorry, right
Yes, what are the spawn locations?
Okay, it's very unlikely the first time we do this we get it because of the spawn locations changing
Uh, wow, they are not close by holy moly
That's the spawn locations
Halfway across the map
The third and fourth
Oh my god, get out of my way guard if you could evaporate that'd be classic right now
That'd honestly be classic. I could only have four she wants six
Oh
dear
At least the white ones tolerate you like holding them
Only
How am I supposed to get six to her? I can't pick up
I'm out of time unless I can throw it. Can I eat it? Can I punch it? Can I punch it? Oh
What was that? Hmm not enough. Why are they so far away?
Need no clips. She said five
And wait, I could have done it if I didn't mess up the pickup right hold on
I can't remember where the other ones where I've already freaking forgotten right. There was one on the staircase
You're coming with me right. There's one also there by the staircase. It's just fine. We can come back for him
Pegasus boots
Okay, two
Okay, okay, and then there was one by the bridge and one by the dojo
Oh
Okay, no, don't do that. Don't do that. Don't do that. You don't want to do that
It's fine. It's fine. Just allow the knife to impale your no your little chicken meaty body. Stop. Stop
Stop. Oh, right. We're gonna have to redo this one
But we know stop stop just accept the the impolition
Right at least we know
Three to the left to north. We know we know. Oh, I can use the bridge as well. I forgot about that
Right
Give me a chance. Give me a chance kids game by the way. Give me a chance
Right two up north. Let's go
Easy easy easy get this freaking beast that are checking first
Easy easy into the pen into the pen
Easy to pick it up
Lunk, you know exactly what I was getting you to pick up there. Oh my god. I'm spending 20 seconds getting those two
Stop it stop it. Oh, I keep I give up
There's no point. I give up. I give up. I'm going in the house. Fuck you. I'm resetting. I'm resetting. I need a reset
Maybe I should go for the ones to the left first
Give me a chicken body. Yeah, we bam you
Oh
Literally how long to get this first one in the post
It's fine
It's
It's fine that he keeps getting caught in the same
Oh
Don't ever lose those chickens again. Do you understand me young lady? Don't you
Ever lose those chickens again
Here's your reward. I appreciate the shells
She's not done
Now do six in a minute
Oh, please tell me she gives a heart piece
All right, one's right at the door. That's fine. One's by the water. That's fine
One's by the shop the general store
Up the waterfall maybe
No
Well, you're probably going to be a lot faster. Okay, we know there's no two up north which is fine
And there's not one by the dog. We're just doing information gathering on this one. Okay
It's not a big deal
Okay
Yeah, I do not have enough time to reach
Unless pause
Oh, we did it
Oh
It's it's not over
It's not over it's not hashtag over
Uh, we'll buy the next manual because she's actually given us enough money to buy all the manual so
I'll buy the next one
Just unequipped your sword. I never even thought of that. Holy crap. Where have you been all my life?
No, we all had to do is unequip the sword
So the chickens would stop running halfway across the map when I touched them with my pointy sword
Yeah, take that right. Well, I definitely don't want to accidentally activate that item
Decape a terrible idea
All of these seem like terrible ideas have it. What do you want?
She gives me an extra five seconds to catch a whole other chicken
Oh, you're taking the absolute mincemeat honestly
Oh, all right. Okay. I'm not right. Okay. This is just information gathering clearly
One by the stairs. Is there one by the dog? There is one by the dog. Okay
Okay, let's try the waterfall. I call it the waterfall, but it's not one here
I am not picking up a golden chicken. I actually refuse. I'd call me chickenist. I don't care
I am not picking up a golden chicken. They are liars. They are cheats and they smell bad
Okay
Is that six? One, two, three, four, five, six. Oh my god, we did it. It's so much easier if you just don't touch them
That's up
Please be done
That's it. You got
Oh, please woman
Can I even pick? Oh
Just restart just I'm not even entertaining it. I'm not even entertaining it. Yes, I will I will help
One
Two
Is there one by the dog? Not there I can see
Oh, there is but it's golden. Don't trust it. Don't trust the golden chicken
Oh, maybe trust it a little bit because we can just start right in
Fuck you
I don't know what number oh postman give the
fucking road
Get out of the fucking road
Right, what happens if I do this? Do you just accept it? Oh my god. Go go go towards the pen into the pen
Did I do it? Did that count?
Oh my god, did that count? I don't know
Go into the pen
No, don't go back you silly sausage
Go into the pen into the pen and no, did I get it? I don't know if I got did that count
No way that worked
190 rupees. Well, I guess we'll go buy the
The next manual because she's actually giving me so many rupees we can buy all the manuals
Not to be confused with Emmanuel the one viewer from Mexico watching us right now speak welcome. I'm selling. Yes, you are. Yes, please
I'd like to buy
I'm literally smurfed that golden one honestly. I don't know how I did that
Wait, how many I can do another getcha. I think there's at least eight left
women
I don't trust it
I don't trust it. They like on the other side of the okay. They're like literally on the other side of the map
Right one is behind the
Shoe shop as for the other one
There's where exactly by the skull no
I don't know
By the exit, I don't know if I'm gonna make it over there in time
Maybe
If no one gets in my way
I said if no one gets in my way then maybe I can make it
We may have done it we may have done it
Wow, we actually did it. Please be the last one and I'm so tired
Time's up. Time's up. Yes. Yes
Thanks. Here's your reward king stone piece
Darling
What do you want now three
And they're on the other side of the map, of course, because why wouldn't they be?
No
No, I don't know right. This is just information gathering. I'm not even
Is there any on this side of the map? I don't think so because the dog would block you
Right, are you John? Get another
That's what I think about you as well
All right, let's just check out the town center nothing
A golden one is I have to contend with two golden chickens
Oh, I don't know if I can do that
Sorry, we're gonna have to do a bit more information gather
That's the three two golden and one weight from halfway across the map
Oh, I don't know about that darling
I don't know if I can do this
It's the last mission is it actually you're not trolling me. She shouldn't be able to have chickens. I haven't much I drown
I'm honestly
Uh, right, we'll do a run
We're gonna swim across the water to get that blue one the white one. Sorry and literally run like nothing on earth
Wait unless
Can I throw it without getting in the water? I can okay curious curious
That's probably our solution. Unfortunately. It does get a bit freaked out
But if that is our solution
I
Was going to say to because to go all the way around seems pretty impossible from being honest
And then the golden one should be here go down here and then pick you up and go down there and pick you up
Then go down there and freaking pick you up and then go there
No pick you up and then go there right. I've not got it
But I think I have the mechanics that I'm supposed to participate in down
which is fine
I kind of just need to like pick it up so it doesn't change its mind
We are never having the velar farm at this rate. No not by the way. I'm fucking handling these champions honestly
Right get the white one first
No, don't get stuck on something long. We're literally in a time crunch right don't
Okay, much better much better strats are coming in strats are coming in I repeat strats are coming
Call me strats because I'm coming
Right, there's one up here pick them up throw them down the alleyway pick them up
Not now not now buddy not now. Oh
No, I did it. No way
That better be the last one reflin or I'm gonna take you out for telling me fibbers
Oh, thank you. Oh, thank you. Thank you
Oh, it's over
No, you're on your own you've given me what I need couldn't get less of a shite
Couldn't get less of a shite if your flock goes out hen
That is your problem
You are so incompetent and I couldn't gear at us
Now it's repeatable for crap cash, okay. Yes, I would like a guide
Please
Uh, right we are going to go small
So we can talk to the minish that's currently inside this house
Oh
Chimney a bit of a chimney moment. Oh, pardon me
I need to break the pots
Oh, I need to break the pots
I
Need to of course I need to uh, sorry. Sorry. Don't how could I be so silly?
Of course, I would need to break the pots in her house first in order to enable me to do what I need
Of course, don't be silly
How preposterous of me to break a pot. I'll break your fucking pot honestly
Right, let's try that
Break a pot
Why wouldn't I break a pot?
Break a fucking pot. Fucking stupid bitch having fucking pots. Hi
Want a charm? No, I don't actually I'm so annoyed at you for those pots and those pots better stay destroyed
Exactly. That's what I thought. That's what I thought. You are not replacing those pots
I will destroy them every single time you'll waste all your earnings and you will never quash
Of course, it's okay. It's okay. Of course I would need to break the pot. Why would I need to break the pot? Of course I would need to break the pot
I'm losing it
Okay, I don't know if we can a hundred percent it because unfortunately I am running very low on ideas of what I need to do next
I like how she doesn't notice any of this going on behind just a
Like really obnoxious like furniture moving noises and she's like, okay
Welcome, this is my new house. Uh, don't you just love the new house smell?
And I was just thinking about building a new house. This is great
Imagine moving from a musty old mushroom to a fabulous house like this. It's like a dream come true. I'm glad
Wait, so you don't want to like do
any trading
Okay, so I don't need to come here
I didn't need to come here
Isn't that funny right here right at this exact geo location? I didn't need to come here
I need one more heart
Those cabinets they move all the time doesn't notice or doesn't care and I'm sure that she is zooed out her mind on her blue juice
Hot smash for nothing literally. I thought the game was like you have to go here
Right, we'll roll one more gacha. Oh, that was really cool. I'm gonna go do that game like
Right one more gacha because we have enough for it
How many shells all the shells the probability is six percent if I don't hand over the shells
Minish need a visit again. Yes, they do
Okay, we'll visit the minish and then we'll go to the top of the forest because there was a few bits and bobs that the forest have
No done
Yeah, I need to go north as soon as I enter a spike spiny choo choo
I
Was this is spiky what we've got 92
I don't think that's enough for a hundred percent and I'm not wasting 92 to get one. I've already got sorry, but
Right the minish need a visit so the visit we the minish we shall
And then they can tell me what goop they need because they need one more goop
Um
When you have a hundred there a new mpc will spawn right
We're getting incredibly close to that mpc spawn so
I'm quite happy. Hello. Uh, I'm gonna zoom about this place though. Just to hurry things along a bit
So
Oh do we get to watch the flowers blossom
Oh, they're blue look it's so helpful
I'm working. I need a red potion to finish. Okay red potion yet. We can definitely get you a red potion
Please do not worry little minish. We will return back soon when we are all big and ready for some potioning
Uh speaking of potioning. I actually know exactly where to go to
Do it because we were gonna head that way. Anyway, so this is actually worked out perfectly
and
I'm gonna do a little bit of this way the flowers
I do
Um, I'm very interested to see what kind of shitty games I can come up with
If I do end up doing the the game pair the root thing
Uh
Be curious
Because I do like I like the progression games where like you make a visible difference in the game
But I don't know if everyone likes that. I was like, oh, I can't believe I'm probably gonna end up making games for girls only girls
No boy gamers alone
No
Okay, let's beat the absolute
Yeah, take it take it little octordal thing. I've already forgotten how to spell your name
Yeah, that's right. Give me them rooms mirrors, but this is where
The what now the game developer
What's that? I can't stop and I must do a billion projects that wants to overwhelm myself. Uh, I would like this, please
And 150 I don't have an empty ball feign feign. What's this? Give me this. What are the practices?
Okay, I mean I'll take it sure
Yes, give me that red shape. Yeah, thanks. I appreciate it. Uh, do you want to trade fusion stones?
Back for granny's red potion one sip will have you absolutely
Fucking jacking. Oh, sorry granny. Jeez. What's going on with you?
Oh, forgive me. Sorry. Sometimes I forget to buy inhibitions. Jeez granny. That was kind of weird. Don't do that again. Okay, sorry
Would it be
Maybe faster go another way, but you know what?
I don't mind. Look
This stream was only meant to be four hours and we've accidentally turned it into an endurance stream. Oh, no. What problem?
What what shame that you have to listen to me ramble even more? Oh
Life is filled with woes and mysteries. No, no the jargon portions the blue one
What color are viagra pills?
Like viagra fall pills
Or did they come in a different array of colors?
I
Don't us on goal. I just send you the ever
They're blue only three more hours until mercy. Okay three hour
We've got three hour timer to complete this damn game so we can read into mercy
Yes, I got you red potion darlin. It's all yours
Well, thanks. We just need to make come back later. Okay. I will come back later
Right, let's check the map for what we can do
Nothing is highlighted there. Nothing's highlighted there. What about the lake?
Nothing on the lake is highlighted
Nothing in this area is highlighted
Western world two trees have moved up
Windrunes there was something we also missed something in the caster winds, but the claiming we actually
Didn't miss anything which I'm glad because that location is
stinky, uh
the castello
Waterfall definitely haven't explored the waterfall properly
The ranch
Gideons we haven't finished yet. We might have to
Do
See she's asking the post office
I think maybe we just need to talk to that wife and then she'll stop
bleeding
Right, who am I going with?
First western world two trees fell windrunes and swamp
I think swamp that was literally the only thing that we missed so we might actually go back to swamp, you know that
And then we'll come back and finish off whatever is going on. Azura is live now. Are they both still on?
That game. Yeah, that game. Yeah jellybean game
You missed the grave keepers instructions for directions through the wood
Oh, is that a secret?
No, the collab finish Azura is on one shot. She's addicted to one shot
I don't even know what one shot is. I've never heard of it since she's playing
Oh, I'm glad they had fun. I'll need to check out and actually watch them. So I'm sure there's a giggle first
The graveyard guy gave some special instructions
Right, we're big again
We're gonna go back to the swamp because there's two things we missed in the swamp
The mage has a hidden path. I would never have guessed to do the hidden path
I would have been like oh that guy's like actually losing it. He doesn't know what he's talking about hydration check
Um
I would actually be faster to do the the one that's here
I can't remember what it was
But there's something here
I think it was a wee minish
Oh my god, I I checked twitter. Thank you for everyone who like interacts with me on twitter
Please don't I'll say I'll repeat this again. Please don't ever be afraid to like double ping me on twitter
Um, someone was like what a perfect way to like get good and ballerent and it was a clip of me singing
um
Um, and I was like, oh my god, you're listening to this. We'll try to focus. How the fucking you focus
Um, that was good funny
Or I found it funny. Anyway, I found out tiki hilarious me. I'm a little think I'm a little think things funny
Okay, I'm a little too. I'm a lot of go tiki
If this is going to be the beanpole
Fun fact blue wd is actually about by bagbra
It's about niacra falls
It wasn't true. It's true. It wasn't true. Are you making up fibbers?
Are you making up fibbers, huh? Are you telling us fibbers? I believe it. I'm gonna I'm gonna end up believing you
It leaves you harder, right? So is this just a debate these two ones are
I mean, it looks like there are debate. There's nothing to go in
Oh, he fibbing. All right, right. Get on boys jump on
Pile up on I'm reefing
Tickle the crap out of this man
Me when me when I do some mischievous false spreading of information on the internet
Well, there's definitely a bean here, but I don't know how to activate it
Well, I'm an ish cavern
Oh my hashtag literally every time I go on twitter
It's like sorry. Don't know what a hashtag is. Sorry. You're trying to search that. Sorry never heard of it before and I'm like
Bro, I just give up
I like honestly give up
Is there anything special up there? No
Right, we will do the lily pad leaf which oh that was well like that shortcut do that again
Right, we need to go all the way like back ish
Yeah, we need to like go up become small and then take the other so
Prankham John. Yeah, you're doing
Uh, I actually need to take this
Right
I don't know I'll just let him come after me because he's literally that slow we can just do that
How do we
Oh, I didn't need to actually do anything
Okay, become we go down and then go down down like
I'm falling down
I'm too slow
It's sounding like you shadow man
Oh shadow. Yeah, no, I'm not even surprised although. I haven't even done anything outrageous on it yet
That part comes later. Okay
Oh
This better be worth it
It's a kinstone piece
I mean, I guess it's worth it, but it took me like forever to get here and I'm out
Oh, I just got stabbed by the plant and now I'm here
Can I even out jeez louise?
The game tested that section
Right. Okay. Now we need to go back and become big
Okay, and then I think everything in this area is thankfully done. If not something you'll unlock but we'll know about it
It's later up. No not birds
Oh true
Oh, yeah, you like that. Yeah
Sorry, I'm losing it. I'm losing it a little bit. Maybe I should get something to eat again
I didn't I didn't think I was gonna be streaming for long because I'm not really eating anything
Eh, right. We're gonna go to the rave yard
Um, and listen to what the old man's pathing was
I actually don't know what his pathing was
Oh, that was a direct hit jeez
A quick little snackie
You can eat me out. That's not that's not even subtle. That wasn't even subtle at all
Uh, what is it? It was left left left up up up. Okay, we can do that
Oh making another baby loaf
Bro, my loafs of bread are are just no having it
I would like to spawn a loaf of bread please
Right, let's see. It was left left left up up
Left
Up
Ow
Wow
What getcha
Okay, I'll take it
But there isn't any more secret on the map here
Nah, there isn't so who have I not or where have I not done? I just cleared out the swamp
It's really just doing kinstone pieces. I need people to trade kinstone, but they wouldn't stay not in the kinstone
Maybe the folk maybe the folk in this building will do more kinstone trades with me. Hold on. We're gonna quickly
Um
Fly away and see if we can get kinstone
pieces
Uh by agro was intended as heart medication
You get you guys need any heart medication
I can do that nurse roleplay. Oops
Sorry, sir. Looks like I accidentally gave you the wrong dose
But I can't leave you like this. That's too inappropriate
Please sir, let me make the situation right. Don't report me. Okay
I need to keep my license. I need to pay my rent
Mummy's old natural heart
I'd be up for that. Oh, yeah, you'd be up. All right. Uh, it wouldn't be a choice really. Do you want to trade?
Your heart is so big
Yeah, you have massive heart all that blood that's pumping
I'm sure I can watch the screen over here
I'd be up for three hours
I cannot wait to start doing project passion project audio
Right, do you want to trade? Yeah, well, they really do like trading up in these parts
I think I'm just gonna have to like reset these rooms and keep coming back and forth
Oh lord, please don't stop. Oh, no, we just finished the rave yard
Hopefully it's just treasure
Uh, right, let's go down again
Please call the doctor if it goes past four
Oh, no, it's been a couple of hours now. You need emergency help by me
Oh
No one else to trade here
Jeez, I'm struggling to figure out what to do next
Our new universe situation is trying us into not telling us and we keep our license. Oh the other way around
Get them gloves on get them gloves on
At four hours, you need a big needle in and drain the blood
Yeah
Which uh, no, I don't think I'd appreciate that. No, I think I'd be rather adverse to that if I'm being honest with you
Call strong if it goes past five birth. I'll help out
Right, I've actually done all the people in the clout of right
Who am I needing a freaking
Maybe the miners and
And
The
No, no, no, sorry. Sorry. I didn't mean to ask for your help. I'm sorry. I'm trying to explore
Isle I'd appreciate it if you'd let me explore in peace right we can go do two more gacha at least
Um, but I'm getting a wee bit lost on
I'm still missing a potion. I just need to be able to
Trade with people might we can stones and
Deep fairly text or
Nate trail. What's that?
You had my curiosity so much so I'm gonna look out right now
What is this you got literally we've all just spiked the google search
Oh
I mean
Yeah, the the regular schmigular gloves
uh
The uh, you're using four. How low is the pot five percent if you do one shell goodness gravy me
You can go back to the minnish village. Oh, I can go back to the minnish village. You're absolutely right
I will do it after my two gacha pulls
Okay, I'm done making an onion. Hmm
We're almost there. We're so close. Yes another trade
One more just one more. I'm not addicted. I swear. We're almost there
You're gonna treat 97 hey, can we treat 97
What is it drum roll
It's
Hooker inspector
Okay, the gambodiction is real
Oh wait, you didn't dock with the big gorgon at top of the wind temple
Right you
Oh
If you ever find a complete set of figures, you should tell me you do know what I'm talking about
Well, do get to it. Well, he really said get gamble
Right to the minnish village
Oh
And you don't want to fuse
Fine, I'll take it. You don't want to fuse with me
I'm actually going to swim to that other one across the water again because I felt like something should have been there
And maybe I missed it, but I just felt so
You guys don't want to fuse in general, do you?
No, it seems like special the minnish views. Oh, no
I'm too early
Are you sure this hasn't bloomed?
Well, I'm not calling you a liar because I can see the flowers haven't but
Wow, I've been away for a hot second mate. I'm not gonna lie
And being away for a wee bit
Is there anyone in that minnish house outside the village?
Is there anyone in the in that minnish house that's outside the village?
Yeah, there was one in it, but he wouldn't trade me like I don't he didn't have a kinswoman or anything
I'll go talk to him again because I thought it was a bit sauce
No, I did get a heart from here. So that wasn't that bad
But he was like wow, I don't normally get visitors here and I'm like, well
Good job finding this place
That's it
Oh, I like that they follow you around. Oh, look at their tails
He's not the one I meant I meant the one by the shrink
He's the bomb guy I have done it a few times with the bomb guy
I don't want
Let's check since we're too early
Let me go check
No, he's he's done
I'd like to ask just to make sure strongy would you be okay if I cosplay do yeah, sure
Uh
The white on my outfit is pearlescent. That's my only good luck hint because
I don't know how hard it is to source pearlescent material, but
Huh, right, let's check the HUD
We haven't really done much on the waterfall
I think we'll do the waterfall that seems like the most logical thing to do right now whilst we wait for our little um
I
Sorry, sorry, I didn't mean to shoot that inside the uh, the town we're able to top right
Oh, nope
When pointing my sword tree in that hole there
out
Right, let's do this
Nope, let's not do this currently
Uh, oh, it's this cavern. Okay
I napped and I woke up again
You're out
Okay, ever okay, I'm getting jumped
I
Have not opened up that waterfall so it's not that one
Oh, there's a chest there though. Do you have gacha currency? I could have flown here
Oh, I'm getting absolutely annihilated. Um, he pushed me off the oh my god
It's over. It's over. It's over. I'm literally not gonna make it. He's jumping me. He's jumping me
The insects are winning the insects are actually winning
Right, right, that's it. I can't even charge it up to do a spin attack. Oh my god. I'm actually gonna die
No way. I'm gonna die. Stop
Right, that's it. We need to suck off these other ones unless he like jumps off. No. Oh my god
I just keep spawning in more enemies
Oh get here right now you freaking bam honestly
I'm gonna drop on my head
Yeah
Hold on. Oh, just get sucked in honestly
Getting yeah, yeah drop it and then lower yourself and get absolutely right
I'm getting fucking annihilated. Fuck me. No, just get me here. What the fuck's going on?
I'm getting jumped
I'm getting jumped by everyone all at once
No, I get in the water
Fuck off me bam
Fucking waterfall bam
Oh, that's exactly what I needed. Thank you. You've completed a new heart container. Thank gosh. So there's only what 12 on the map somewhere
That was awful
I'm getting freaking annihilated there
You phone there you wouldn't know there's a bomb room in the cave you just got
Wait, that was real. I thought it wasn't real. I knew it was hard to know
I was like, huh
Did you end up getting that red kinson piece for the tingle brother? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I got all the tingleys
I cannot for the life of me remember what I'm supposed to do right. No, no go up the stairs
And go along
These are all in my way
Right. Thank goodness. I have so much health because I don't have to like contend with everything all at once
this
What does it do? Is he saying far?
How does he come up? He's hating from me
He's just making Goro noises throw something at him
I'm gonna hurt him. Maybe a ball of them. Oh, I can't do anything. I'm completely rocked in
You have to dock with someone
Okay, good night. Thanks for hanging for anyone. Please do not feel bad if you need to rest get all the rest
You need get all the sleep seas you need
Oh, what is this? This is to backtrack, isn't it? Yes
Then be trolled. What was in here then? Oh, I got it wherever it was
Good girl. Mm-hmm
Good thing I'm not feeling submissive right now. That's right. Wait, there's only one of these left. Is the game gonna remember?
Is the game gonna remember?
He like gets up so quickly that I can't even suck them though
Mm-hmm right there that dig spot dig dig
Dig spot
I'm here for the long haul. I'm on vacation from work. Yeah, I literally can
Wait, there's a dig spot back there
Back in here
Opposite eye of the chest
In here
Nope outside. Wait, so I was in the right place
Other eye
Ah
That
You know what I've actually had enough of you mate. There's no way you're gonna survive
How have you seen refusing to die?
The rocks are skull shaped
That's what you want to drink. Stranny you are so blind. I'm getting nuked to death by this thing that I can't kill
He literally won't even go in the paw
He's refusing to suck because he's mental so you got to smash him or something
I'm freaking trying
Fuck off man. Right. Was that what I was supposed to do?
Have I done everything that you do in this area?
I
I'm seeing guy refused to get sucked. Honestly. Is that everything I had to do this little bit? No stop. It's not no
What else is here?
First Ronnie still a bomb room left. There's a bomb wall. Where the fire skull was
Down here down here
I can see there's something here. I have an access
On the way down. Yes down. Okay down down I go
I'm following the reef flingsery flingsery flings are following the reef flings
Because I am a good girl
ah
bomb
Bomba go
You don't saw that a little bit, but then I never went for it because I was like no, that's silly
Following the reef flingsery flingsery flingsery flingsery
They're gonna
Ski week
No, no logic puzzle
Well, I can only push it to the side
Oh geez how many of you did just spawn?
If I push it down by one
I don't ever recall doing this, but
Oh, that was so tricky. Oh, no
Yes, we got the shell
Oh
Yeah
Oh shit
This
In order to get out. Okay. Okay. I understand
I saw a go go go go go go. Oh, sorry. Sorry a little brazilis there
Probably better I don't like go that one
I did it. I did it. Does the ghost respawn? No he doesn't
You can teleport
Probably
Okay, surely the minish flowers are done by now considering how long that took me to figure out
Surely
Surely the minish flower is done by now. There's no way it's not
Yes
Surely copy them
All right, let me get my let me get my speedy goons hours
They're probably done and don't call me surely
Do you have a checklist? No, I'm just following the reeflings. I trust the reeflings blindly with my life
And in exchange they get milked. It's quite a good uh
Um relationship honestly, I mean, I think
They're so beautiful
Look, I succeeded in growing an orange bloom. Thanks for your help. I'm so grateful
I'm taking a break from research, but I've lots of good ideas super hyper cyber. Which one should I pick first?
Give me the goods give me the goods. Come on surely you want to give me something for it? Come on
What did that do
Did I walk something doing that or do we just have pretty flowers now? Honestly, I ain't that mad
I ain't that mad. They're they're pretty cute scammed. No, honestly, they're pretty cute
Uh
Copy them
I like flower games like I like games that are like oh the store nature
Dude in town
There's no someone in town
In minnish town
Your name will go down in history as a flower scientist
Called botanist. I'm a big botanist. Someone's got booty. I see
I've got a big round
Uh, didn't didn't turn cells in there cells flower
I
The flowers make me think oh
Keep toughen away into the evening
Did it did nothing actually happen other than unlocking these flowers, I mean, that's cute, but
I
Flower guy in town
In minnish town
You want to trade no
I've been asking the same people all over and over. Please. Do you want to trade please please?
I'm getting desperate and castles in high rule
I
New guy in town
I'm looking I'm observing
There's no new gentleman in time you're teasing me
No one wants to link them
Uh
There is a game where you can dodge the bird if you want I always remember things not funny again
Oh, it's the library
Did you jump in the bell? I did jump in the bell
I'm gonna unlock the next edition
Welcome. Yes. Yes. Yes. I've almost finished
Right, we'll go bottom left. No, no, I didn't mean it but thanks. Oh, I appreciate it
Um, we'll go bottom left and the reason for that is because there was a few dig sites we unlocked
Uh, there's a up here
Man, just let me cut the grass in peace. Okay
Some of us need to to feed their gacha habit and if I'm going to fund it by cutting grass then just leave me to it
Okay. Oh, there we go. That's what we'll see. Wee
Okay
All right fallen trees
All right, this one's
Wow
Soon soon
Wait, that was a swamp. That was the guy's house
And then this one did we dig up we might have already done that
A bomb place. How do you guys spot the bomb places so easily?
A bomb place
Oops, a bomb place
That's here
A bomb place
Can you be this zero in a bit? I've already been in here
Nope to the right
Aww
Oh
Get in the bowl, hen. Thank you
She's me just going for a dip plus I watch you lovely ladies flutter about
I still don't get how you guys see that honestly. I would never have caught that
Um
We can dig this up, nice, nice, huge, is that everything for the sweet region here?
It was?
Oops, sorry.
Is that literally everything I've unlocked?
I just need to fuse stones with people, but I don't know where they're located, basically.
Hold on, just checking.
Right, I need to finish the post office, and I need to talk to that wife and get a charm off of her.
I need to finish the gacha, which I'm literally about to do.
I've not finished off the gorom, which is a shame.
The lake, apparently, is finished off.
Bro, I'm just shite, as it clearly is.
Is there any mythical features in Foch Foch, or tons?
Kelpies are probably the most well-known.
Um...
Kelpies are horses that convince you to ride their back, and then you drown.
So basically, like, marry me.
Um...
Right, we have 300 rupees.
Let's go talk to this wife, and let's go get the latest issue.
We've got one more?
Hello, we've got a new issue, yes?
Yes, thank you, I would like it.
Um, right, we're actually going to purposefully fail a gacha, so we can make 10 rupees.
I've got 190, and it's 200 for an addition.
So we're going to purposefully fail this, okay?
We're going to purposefully fail this, please don't worry.
It is all by design.
The difference is Kelpies eat you after you drown.
Marry me to do that too.
Yeah, that's fine.
Okay, yes, yes, yes.
Okay, we need one, we just need to fail one more.
And before I win it, could you imagine?
I curse you with good luck, 3% probability.
That would be blessed.
You raid their back and they drown you, basically.
So Kelpies are like, marry me to drown you in water.
How many shells, right?
Let's get to work.
It's a hippocampus, so it murders in time.
Name to eat shells to get one correct gacha.
The classic red cap goblin is also a Scottish myth.
Big blue choo-choo appears in the temple of the droplet.
It's an ordinary blue choo-choo, faking him, minnish sizes, daunting.
Just try to avoid the electric.
Congrats, I'll keep the figurine in case you can see it anytime.
Wanna try again?
Yes, I think I have enough, question mark.
We do have enough.
Yes, name to eat, give me that little lever.
Kelpies are squashful.
King Daltas.
Congratulations, I'll keep the figurine in case you can see it anytime.
Do we have enough?
We do have enough for another roll.
Wanna try again?
I absolutely would love to.
Yes, please.
Oh, no.
Oh, well.
Okay, 2% gacha.
Wish us luck.
2% gacha.
Yeah, surprise, surprise.
Yeah, I don't think so.
I think there's legit like 4 missing.
1, 2, 3.
3, wow.
Okay, 3 more.
2% is better odds than a gacha 5 star.
Well, after this, it's literally 2 more and we're done.
We are done with gacha.
We can finally access that room.
The third last one is...
Aw, Ren's sleep.
Ren's shoe shop.
Using a secret technique, he makes shoes in his sleep.
Princess Zelda is his thing.
His biggest source of income.
That's cute.
Okay.
We are out of shells so we can't do it again until we get a few more.
But literally 2 more to go feels good, man.
Oh, hello, Popper.
You're in the way.
In the way.
Yeah.
Nope, you're straight back in the way.
Yep, there you go.
Oh, wait.
We're gonna talk to her so she gives us her blessing thing
because she does...
Yes.
We're just gonna use that so she can give me the charm.
What does it do?
Blue Link can't hurt you.
He isn't real Blue Link.
That is cursed.
And last but not least, yes, give me it.
And then that's fully gone.
All done.
What do you see now?
You now have the full collection of layers,
but I guess you must know all kinds of stuff now, huh, Professor?
Are you flirting with me?
I will...
I will perish right now.
Let's see.
No one...
No one wants to link our cheeky stones.
I'm really struggling to find anyone who wants to do it.
Read.
Do you want me to read?
Oh, I'll go and take another one.
Purple Burglar Alarm Link.
No, you don't want to trade either.
You still need to buy the Goron...
What?
Did I really have nowhere else to go?
I don't know if I should just go back to that field and farm it,
that one that's like to the west.
Did you dock with the Minish in the bookshelf?
I think so.
I'll just go back to make sure.
Make sure.
I've seen games with a 1 in 15,000 drop.
See, that just like completely turns me off.
I'm like, well, I'm without lucky, so what's the point?
I wouldn't even spend my pennies on it.
I'll see if there's any we Minish.
Actually, I do need to go back to the mining village
because I think there possibly had been someone that might want to...
Oh, there's a wee guy up there, maybe he wants to...
You're still playing this.
I went to bed when you started.
Well, you must have got a terrible sleep.
There's only been seven hours, you need eight.
Okay, we'll go back.
We'll go back to the mines after this.
The children yearn for the mines.
I did have a terrible sleep.
Exactly, see?
Reminds me of how I thought I could get the woodcutting pen.
Oh, so you passed the trial and returned.
I'm so jealous.
But if you're going on an adventure,
there's no one better to learn for the elder.
He's so manly, so rivally, and so full of fire.
Oh, it's green though.
It's not very important if it's green, unless I'm mistaken.
Oh, I'm not back at the swamp.
Come on, have you never been to the swamp so many times?
No, it's just for jewelry.
Jewelry for gems.
Well done indeed.
You're almost as surprised as I was at your age.
How about again?
No?
No, I can only do it once and it was green.
I wasn't even an important one.
Get out of my swamp.
I mean, honestly, we're what?
Missing three heart containers?
That's not that bad.
It could be way worse.
I feel like three heart containers is pretty good.
I actually have no clue what I'm missing, but...
Maybe.
Just maybe we do the boss.
Because when does Mercy come on?
We've got T minus two hours for Mercy, so...
I will get the last gacha, though.
I want to do the gacha part.
Addicted, I know.
I'm gonna cut grass for the gacha.
I can't believe I'm saying this one.
I'm a way to cut grass for gacha.
Oh my god, that's when you know it's bad.
Start doing manual labor.
Terrible.
They're not dropping anything.
As if he hits me.
See, these guys are so in awe.
Go and just perish me.
I need 200 coins to buy 30 more.
This is gonna take forever this way.
Why didn't you get the rest of the red rupees at the bean?
Oh, I don't know where that bean is.
My inventory was full, so I didn't want to pick up anymore.
Me wallet was full.
Can't believe it.
I'm at 41.
This is gonna take forever cutting grass.
Was it this one?
If it was, that's incredibly lucky.
Oh, I'm beating them up.
If it was this one, then...
How much do I need?
Shell.
Oh, I need quite a few more to be honest.
Oh wow, I just cut that arrow in the air.
I wonder how much time on my life I spent cutting grass and Zelda.
Link gets the job cutting grass.
Okay, that'll help out quite a bit.
That was, we've got 230 rupees now,
which means we can buy 30 more so we can get the second last ketchup.
Or we could just keep farming to be honest.
I don't know, I think we're gonna have to farm for this.
Is that a special?
Has it got fairy in it?
Yep, it was special.
See?
Ow.
Did I do this right?
That other one gave me six coins in one go.
Drapped.
Remember catching chickens give shells on money?
Oh no!
My biggest enemy.
Like, for real, for real though.
Is there something here I've yet to do?
Or did I already do that?
I already did it.
Did you check the orange people flowers?
Where?
I checked up on the guy, but he never did me anything.
I'll see how hard these chickens are.
Maybe, maybe I can't believe I'm saying this,
but maybe it's worthwhile to go run around and look after chickens.
What's that, 90?
I think that's about 400%.
Second last figure, we can do it.
Second last.
What's it gonna be?
Oh, you're back.
I am back.
And I'm addicted.
Probability is one.
One.
Wait, so am I gonna have a move for 100% guarantee?
I don't have enough to put 100 shells in.
I am not risking it, sauce, but...
Oh my god, I can't even get rid of it!
No, I'm sorry, I am not risking all those shells
just to get it, just to not get it.
Roll them bones, no.
You guys have no idea how unlucky I am.
Did you not watch the Buckshot Relay Stream?
Where I lost on the tutorial twice or something?
So we can clip it if it goes wrong.
No, I am not that brave.
I literally, I lost.
We never lose.
All gambas quit.
Right, I can't believe I'm saying this,
but we're gonna give the chicken a try.
See if that'll give us the money we're looking for.
Hi.
Sure, what do you want?
These are the ones that are halfway across the map.
No, I'm not playing in your stupid chicken game.
Fuck you, I'm going to the swamp, where is it?
Down.
No, oh, no, down.
No, I am not, I'm not playing in your chicken games
where they're halfway across the map.
I'm going to the swamp and there's nothing you can do about it.
Swamp to kill this little golden goose thing.
Where was it? Was it down here?
What is that?
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
I'm actually really bad at that, I don't know.
Can I go down that pool?
What do you want to do?
Ow.
Oh, well, yeah, you're right, I could have gone to that one,
that would have been a lot quicker.
But we're here, we're here, it doesn't matter, it doesn't matter.
Look, it's about the journey, it's about the experience
we made along the way, the experience we made losing our health.
Row, wake up.
Wake up.
Prepping slow cooked stew while watching strongly.
Good girl, man.
Oh, that's what you did.
Oh wait, did I go in here?
Is this new or am I just making it up?
Have I been in you before?
I have, because I've already...
I can trade, I can trade, please take it, take my stone.
It's been so long, four minutes.
You're beanstalk as well.
We're in the money, boys, we're in the money.
Beanstalk as well as Golden's thingy, my Bobber.
Oh, and I'm like two centimeters away from it.
Oh my god, you're such a good boy, little Minish thing.
Hold on, have you got another trade for me?
You don't, but that's fine, we're gonna go to the Minish mines.
I keep forgetting to go to the Minish mines.
Oh my god, we're doing it.
We're doing it, I can do it.
Shawnee's just gonna try and fill two more,
so we're perfect, right?
I've not even killed the main boss yet.
I've not even done the boss fight.
I'm too busy like getting distracted,
like doing all these wee side things.
I was gonna try and a hundred percent it,
but I have no idea what I'm missing,
like I'm not smart enough.
Clean, clean, clean, clean.
I'm climbing, I'm climbing.
Oh!
You got large quiver!
So we can hold 90, oh, 90 bombs, 90 now.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, I'll take it, I'll take it.
Did that thing get away down again?
That's fine.
Copium telecom is doing.
Right, let's go get that sneak,
and then we can finally a hundred percent our gacha pawn.
I like how the sneak just let me beat them up earlier,
and now that's fine.
Right, I actually...
Oh wait, there's a freaking short cut right here
that I walked right past.
Cutting the grass.
Cut the grass.
Can't wait to play grass cut or similiar.
I'm actually surprised the power washer doves
aren't coming out with some stuff.
I'm pretty sure you can't activate them
or hurt them from behind.
We need to not upset them.
I mean, did you get oiled up for the clap audio?
Yeah, you can hear me put it on, actually.
You can hear me take off the apparel
and put on the...
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
And...
Put on...
I've taken a while to make the power wash on that.
It's a battle of the laser beam!
Oh, I love the laser beam.
Did I unlock something else here?
I have a feeling I unlocked something else here.
I didn't.
Okay, I love this laser beam.
Stay with me all the time.
That's what I want to see.
Right, how much money?
Oh, I'm only 150.
Is that supposed to do something else?
Where does it come from?
Maybe...
something?
Should I be giving chat a large cover right now?
That was so good.
Well, it's getting uploaded first, right then.
I think I'll tame it to come on...
to go live, like, an hour before AC,
because I don't want it to, like...
It's not going to disrupt AC's stream,
but...
I mean, you didn't even want to...
I don't want to, like...
Obviously...
Yeah, I'm trying to pick more words.
I don't want to be, like...
I don't want to steamroll over my gen mates.
Also me, who streams for 12 hours,
so it's kind of unavoidable.
The last few heart pieces are actually in the dungeon.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, that was fine.
Was that supposed to do something with the orange guy,
or am I being trolled?
I think I'll just have to go farming in that field.
The orange flower guy?
Someone mentioned it again, and I'm like,
are you trolling me, or is there actually
something with that orange flower guy?
Did you say he was in town or not?
I don't...
Someone said...
Is it Beel?
Him?
Why hello there, thanks for coming by.
I start playing the theme.
No, I think I'm mistaken.
Right, this is the Gambo, man.
I'm not sure I want a Gambo, to be honest.
Beel sells...
Who's Beeto?
That guy, the guy I just spoke to.
The veggie man?
Click on the jar.
Why hello there, that is the weight
for people who want to get lucky.
Oh...
Okay, that's actually...
No, I did not have the money for that,
but thank you anyway for asking.
Okay, have you played Brit...
No, this is my only legend Zolda game.
I have not had any Zolda experience
other than this game.
Right, give me the money for cutting the grass
right now.
Hand over the money and no one gets hurt.
Did I make myself clear video game?
Check out all his other ones too.
Wind Walker.
Wah, he wants to trade.
I saw that, I saw that, he wants to trade.
I knew you would want to do it.
I knew it, I knew it.
I knew it, what do you want?
Please be a treasure chest, so I can get money
for easy peasy land and squeezing.
There's one for shells, is there?
I don't know where that is.
That's super easy to get to.
Right, we're heading straight for it.
We're making a b-link for it.
A perfect match.
Thank you, Grandad.
I appreciate it. Do you want to do it again?
Maybe?
No, sorry.
Sorry for even asking.
Have my money, don't hurt me.
Why are you giving me money though?
Wait, where the heck am I doing?
A little to the left?
Thank you again
for the tips.
Why are you giving me pieces
that I can't even do anything with?
I can't even do anything with them.
The bad guys always drop coins.
I feel like the baddies actually drop a decent amount of coins.
I'm just making that up.
I can't remember what this was.
Thank you again, Broly Legends.
As I struggle to say your name.
I've already...
And you don't trade
because that would be too easy.
Don't forget to pay your taxes.
No smile.
Just kidding!
I pay my taxes.
Thank you, Australian Government, for letting me set up businesses in your country.
I should have better tax rates
than in the UK.
I should have gone to Australia.
Let me set up a business.
Set one up in Australia.
This isn't helping either.
I'm not making any profit doing that.
I think we're just going to have to go grass farming.
You know that.
I'm trying to make the money
and the shales
like that.
Like in the grass patch.
Because I can do a lot of it in one go.
I'm sorry.
She says that she gets absolutely annihilated.
Do these guys drop money?
No.
I'm sorry.
You're just going to have to wait for me.
Be patient.
Please.
Get annihilated.
Is the grass patch a buffer below me?
Look at the ball.
Maybe.
Oh, maybe Parasy wants to trade.
Parasy might want to trade.
At least use the spin attack on the grass.
You are so correct.
Holy crap.
Parasy doesn't care.
Sorry, I just picked up you're saying that you just replaced.
Spin attack on grass.
Spin on the grass.
Spinning on grass.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
I completely forgot I could even do this.
Holy crap.
Are you serious right now?
Completely forgot I could even do that.
This is going to be a lot faster than
what was originally going on.
Okay.
That's right. Drop me nothing game.
Drop me nothing. It's fine.
It's not like I wanted anything.
Okay.
We're getting shells.
Hold on a minute.
We're getting them soon.
Oh we're getting somewhere.
We're getting somewhere. Don't write it off yet.
Don't write off the tactics yet.
Don't write it off yet.
Pandoraeos?
Pandoraeos.
Sure.
Thank you for the tip.
Why are we hurting Wre flings?
I mean, only if they consent.
Okay, I
Can't believe it. It's working unironically working. What are we at? We're at a hundred and six and
We're close to being able to buy 30 from the shop. Oh
My god, oh my god, it's actually working
Reflings suck that man off that suggested to do the spin attack
Kidding, that's actually not for me. It's more of an anything I think
It's more of an anything. Yeah, we respect it. We respect it
Oh
Yes, mommy
Only if any things are dressed up like hero
Oh, no, you oh you cancelled my little spinny attack
We're almost done. I'm so sorry. Thank you for bear bear with me. I see's in the room bear with me
113 I have enough to make it one
Mummy club that replaying with pleasure. Thank you, Barrow. Oh
This is so good
Thank you for the 10 Barrow out
Ah, I know you'll link don't do that the one time I actually don't want code stone people showing up
Kinstone my apologies
Emmy loves back haggle and deck you from my hero
Whoa, that was a lot there
Take the five how much 120
We have 200 to buy 30 so we need another 50 more. We're getting so close we can do it
I can taste victory and it's sweet in my mouth
Code stone new place player detected. Yeah
I was actually gonna do a series on new pets
But it would have to be recorded video because I can't make it like a fun live stream
And like I know doki bird. I think she wanted to stream your pet, but then
Just sweet in your mouth
Wow, oh my god, we're actually doing it. We're in the 30s. Let's go
I just need a couple more shells
And then we'll be in the far East and then we'll be in the fifties
Lovely jubilee that's what I like to see long
But the men is working overtime trying to hate all these things in the grass for me on
They're like geez this boy won't stop
Okay, that was a that was a pur pur drop rate that round
Rune-scape green screen stream, but it's actually just
What 140s oh one 40s and then we'll be 150
Okay, we've got to that run got to that run
Like please I haven't seen my family in 30 years. Oh
Now all the Kinstone pieces want to come out of the woodworks
And I've been like absolutely scrounging around for any of them for like how long the entire game and
We're sitting in this
Right
Sorry, how many times have we not had one spawn? I do this like a handful of times and we've got like 10
rough I
Know your game living to Zelda
Your drop rates are doo-doo
I'm so sorry for the change of music
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and another one drops of course it's on another one while we're okay
Absolutely getting trolled right now about this game
Ever since like one pair links new landscaping business
Oh
I'm gonna be so happy when this is over
One we're in the 50s. We need to get to like
170 and then we can go by the other theory that are missing and we're done
We're done. We have we have completed the catch up and we can finally get into that freaking shot honestly. Oh
Oh
That was a good one that was a good one if you saw that I think that was for that batch
You're gonna dream about the grass cutting sound effect on his way we're almost there
Oh
Terrible drop rate that time. Oh, no, we got to we got to we're about 60s rate. I just see 70
Give me 70
Six more one
two three
That's three
and then
Three four if I can pick it up five six, I think we've done it. I was done it
One seven one perfect, right takers. Oh
It's the drop rate we can't submit more than a hundred can we just to be sure
I'll pick up one literally one more. Oh, no, I won't the game knows exactly what I want to do right now
I just want one more for like reassurance in case the game is gonna ask for more than one right
Get me to that gamble shop right now
Do you how long we've been at this? I will do the main quest now because I don't think there's anything else I can do
We're just go straight down
Wait, I'm gonna do I need to buy the one from the general store
Need the batch from the general store, which I have yes, I will buy
The gamer paranoia is real. I am like sitting upright for once my feet are on the floor
That's how much I was try hard and during that segment
Okay
Gacha collection. I'm not gonna skip the dialogue in case he like says like congrats trade
How many shells?
The more shells the more likely you win. Let's get it to 100. Okay. Let's get let's get a few things right
Let's get it to 100
100 yes, great. Now pull the lever second last gacha is
Him the sculptor finally cast figures many considering the best sculptor and how he enjoys collecting the serious shell
Congratulations, I'll keep the figure in the case on the left for you. You can see at any time
and last
It's certainly not least
Wait, you're sitting normally sounds like the horn of the apocalypse on a clue
Oh last one. Let's go. You're going to trade 100 great pull the lever the last design that we were missing
is
The monster lady a weird old lady living in pericy's house without his permission
She doesn't want you to turn on the light. She might actually be uh
And he falls over
Congratulations, you've now collected all of the figurines that I've made
I'll keep a good eye on all of your figures in the case
Please come see me anytime or them anytime for me
Ah, thanks for coming. You seem to have one of the figures I've made. Would you like to draw one out?
Oops
I didn't actually mean to draw one, but sure. Why not? Let's just draw another one for good luck question mark
Uh, oops
Gina a strange uh ghost who wants to fuse Kingston pieces which is somewhat peculiar
She has a lot of pieces so keep on fusing. Okay, maybe we'll go back to the rave yard for her
Right
Give me whatever the heck is in the shop
Right mate. I've got your collection
Nope
Eh
Whoa
You did it. I can't believe you did it. This is a totally complete set
How incredibly awesome and you've even got the legendary
Carlov medal it shines with a beautiful light at every collector's dream
What you've shown me here. It's just it's just amazing here
Feel free to go into my house and take whatever you want in it. Thanks because you know, I'm rich ha ha ha
Wait, is that without space? Well, no, there's still spaces here. I don't know what the spaces are
Under quest stars
right
What you go money
Money
Money, yeah, I'm gonna say because we don't have a need for shelves anymore the way it's door time
You've got a piece of a heart collect four more
It's a phonograph and it looks like it works here to try it out
Uh
I
Love the peaceful harmony one
It's a jukebox most expensive phonograph like literally the hoops that I was made to jump through
So how much are these then?
200 sure why not
Why not at this point 300 knock yourself out
No more no more but come back again. I'll get you more. Thanks mate. Uh, right. Let's get the reeflands with a nice yummy pie. Welcome
We need a pie before we go and deal with this enemy because
There was a kinsome. Oh, I got a red piece for that wall
Great fairy fountain song
It's when you when you finally meet strongy. Yes concern. Do I even need to buy these anymore?
Ah whatever
Ah, whatever in game test and lock behind worse side first
Well, I think that's all I can do. I think we're gonna go for it
Um, unfortunately, I don't know what I've missed. Do you guys say there's a few more ahead?
Oh, they're being guarded. I forgot. Pardon me
Okay reeflings it's time
I don't know how sensitive the ai is in this game
It doesn't seem too bad
Uh famous last words. I bet you it does seem too bad
I bet you a pie
Okay, okay. I'm not too bad. Not too bad. Let me get up. Let me get up
Don't want to be caught. Don't want to be caught right hide under here
Can't see us can't see us. Take it easy. Oh, I'm supposed to go for it there. It's
When he turns back
piss
How did you see me?
I'm okay. They're a little bit more sensitive than I thought
Look, it's not bad being sensitive, but she's giving me a chance, you know
I
Head behind this bush
There we go
Look at a split
And hide behind here
How did he see me?
Am I doing the taming wrong is there maybe maybe there's a taming on the bottom two down there that I don't know about
I'm struggling
I'm needing uh an
Invisible cloak that would probably go quite that would go down quite well. I'm not gonna lie
I think you have fusing left, but it's hunting down the people. Yes
It's definitely fusing because there's so many things that are blocked off and I'm like bro. I don't even
Sneak past them into that
He turns
No, okay, there's definitely some sort of tile distance. I cannot cross
Hey, I never even came in
Right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right. I never even came in
Okay, definitely a tail distance. Keep that in mind
Tail distance any tail distance a analyzers
Analyze analyze analyze safe
Analyze
It must be on the next input when he turns around go for it
Wow
Come on
Bro, we actually just want to like progress with the main quest. Can you just like let us in?
Can you just let us in we're
Genuinely just trying to play the game at this point not even like haha funny stealth like bro. We're just trying to play the game
Safe
Right when he goes down I can hide behind here, but then I need them to do another rotation
Which is fine and he will taste which is fine
He'll rotate
I'm out of you
Wah
Get that sword out right now
Oops, I hurt myself. It's fine. Oh wait, I don't have a full fairies. Do I I don't know where the other bottle is
I'll be an infusion need out
We made it
Okay, last element to infuse and everything's going to go all dark and not very nice, but that's just the way the games
And now it's golden
That looks like a beast of a sword
Oh, it's pretty
The power of the wind element has infused your blade with the power of the four elements your blade has become the four sword
Focus focus power in your blade and release a fire a beam use it to break batty's curse and restore the people
That's fantastic
Oh
Secret door. Hmm. Hmm. It seems that forging the sacred blade somehow opened that doorway
It must lead to the rooms that holds the secret of the light force link. We have to go inside
Oh
How interesting look at the images on the stained glass. I bet those pictures show us where the light force is hidden
In the principessa it's the opening
A long long time ago
When the world was on the verge of being swallowed by shadow
The tiny picori appeared from the sky bringing the hero of men a sword and a golden light
With wisdom and courage the hero drove out the darkness
When peace has been restored the people enshrined the blade with care
But here it is and the force of the golden light embodied in Hyrule's princess shone forth upon the land
So that's what it means
Oh
As low you really are too kind first you give me my magic cap and then you guide me here
You've been far too generous for now. I no longer have any useful. Yeah
Batty
Yes, that is brish. I don't know
What
At last I finally know the location of the light force it's the princess
Link wake up. Can you wake up?
Batty disguised himself as the king to search for the light force
When he learned of this place he waited for us to reforge the blade if that stained glass is accurate
Princess Zelda holds the light force batty will do whatever it takes to steal that power from her
If he succeeds, he may never be able to return the princess to normal
We've wasted too much time link. We must stop batty
Oh, yeah piss. Oh, yeah piss. We're on the timer. Are we actually though?
Or am I being trolled?
Why it's golden well, it's all different now, isn't it?
All different now
Oh
What what is this what's happened here? They've been turned to stone all of them the minister and the guard
Everyone in the castles like princess Zelda. This can only be the work of that evil batty
What cruelty link we must use the power of the sacred foresword to undo this evil
Oh
Thank you. Thank you. You're the one who returned me to normal, aren't you?
I don't know how you did it, but I cannot thank you enough. Listen. Have you seen how strange the king's been lately?
That's because it's not the king at all. It's batty. He's taken over the castle
One by one. He's turned us all to stone everyone cursed by his evil magic
Then the monsters arrived even paralyzed. I saw it all
I only pray it's not too late to undo this evil
There's so many
Link we need your help batty took a petrified princess to the roof of the castello
He must be planning something fiendish. You must stop him. I'm going. I'm going. Fuck me. I've only got two fairies in a ball
You're in my way, mate
Okay, we can get past
Thanks, mate. Thanks for not putting me in a dialogue as well actually
dark hyrule castello
Oh
Is this really hyrule castle? I can't believe it. What's happened here?
Patty's magic has grown more powerful than I imagined
But the king and zelda are in danger link. We need to go
Oh castle, but evil literally
Oh, I'm not full health. So I can't oh, I'm definitely not full health after that you don't
Fucking wait to add it up
These are fake rooms, yeah
Surely I won't burn myself
Oh
We go because we don't have the key
Oh the jail cell we'll get the jail
Can I undo you from here? Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Sorry. Sorry king. Oh, I can't eat you
Hold on. Hold on
Is this the final dungeon? I think so question mark
Fairy fairy fairy fairy. I've never been happier. See one of you you
You yank
I caught a fairy in a ball
Right there we go. We're fully healed now. We have three fairies at our disposal. Let's we'll put the name mess up a bit too much
Um, I don't have a key
I can't go that way but I can at least come in the back faster
I very easily could have gone wait, what the fuck am I trying to do? Sorry
I'm not supposed to be here yet
Thank you
Is it the same layout in super mario castle? Oh wait, maybe I'm supposed to be there. I assume
I'm supposed to oh well the game is the game said take what you need right? I even need arrows. No, I don't
Wait, so I was supposed to what am I missing? I'm missing something
That was a fake door. This is a fake door. No, it's not okay
Uh, let's jump see if there's some time
Can you guys be
Right and then you next
And you next and you next nope
I'd rather stay feel healthy. Okay. That's a fake door. So there's something down here. I apologize
Am I to fall in the gap? Maybe that's what drops me into the cell. Okay. I think the gap drops me into the cell
Boss battle imminent and everyone's reset because why would we not reset?
Yep
No, this is just here. Okay that okay. I'm missing something. Sorry. Give me a second. I'm missing something
Now rattle the cages rattle rattle. Okay can't rattle the cages like a feral dog
Hmm
I can see I can get small there
Right now what?
Open sesame literally wait, can I like batter the door down maybe?
Oh
Should have been through the kids it seems to get blocked there
Yeah, it's getting blocked so I can't do that. I need a key to get to him
Spoiler alert, this isn't the final dungeon
If this isn't the final dungeon, I think I'm gonna need to call a food break. I'm already stuck
And I've not even gotten started
Is there really nothing back this way? Is it like a bomb?
Is there a tail that oh, there's a bomb on the wall, bro
Of course it's a bomb
I knew something was me right there. I was like, this is me
This is me working it
As if you come flying over to me
Okay, I need to fall down as a medium
This makes much more sense now
I was like there must be a wall I'm missing because I can't interact with anything that seems
Okay, I assume the switch is gonna open up the gates
Now although that makes no sense, I'm not going to question it at all and instead be thankful
Hello
Oh Link, are you the one who broke the curse and returned me to normal?
You've gone you've gone quite brave since the last time I saw you. I must say
Oh, but how those kisses
My love is under vice curse
Is this all the work of one man as king of hyrule? I must do something about this villain
But I'm old and I would only hold you back link. You have the sacred blade now
We must
You're gonna rely on the 12 year old. Please you must find a way to rescue my Zelda
Take the key. You can use it to get out of the castle from the basement
Ah use it to open locked doors. Yes
I will absolutely take that
Yeah, I said if you put the switch that opens the cell in the cell that shall I'm like, hmm
Not sure this would work out in theory. Maybe if it was like one-on-one
Actually
Link my boy
I might have to call a break and get like food in that and maybe try and squeeze out a loaf of bread, you know
It's not really it's not really happening. I'm not really sure what's going on with the look of bread situation
Okay, here we go. Here we go
I don't know how I avoided that but
I think there was a chest over here
There is
Do we even want to see how big this dungeon is
It's five levels
Yeah, uh, I'm gonna go with uh, let me get a break. Um, and I'll get some real food on me and
rehydrate and all that because uh, yeah, this is going to
Like how much time until mercy we've got less than an hour to try and do all of this
No an hour and 15 sorry and then mercy comes on
Wow
Lower time values sometimes referred to as the sage of dark winds and it is
Hected in later games as a demonic winged eyeball
He makes his home in the tower of winds, which is his final dungeon
Not the temple ones
Uh, right give me a minute. I'm gonna make a tea. I'm gonna make some lefto berries
I have no idea why even having the fridge to be honest
Um, and I'm gonna bake a loaf of bread not in all in that order
Some of the orders might be different, but I think we can do it
I think we can finish before mercy if I don't if I don't get absolutely rolled and smoked
Need to be on my a-game though. Need to be on my a-game
all right
Stoney buy some prunes. Actually, I have chocolate raisins
I've tried to eat them like twice on stream so far and I keep forgetting about them. Are we gonna raid into mercy?
I'm gonna try to raid into mercy. Yes
um
Oh, is that what that slot is for? Hold on
No
What the frick are these did anyone type what these are for or is it just like random space?
Nah, I can't even be random space. It looks like I'm gonna put it everywhere
Um
Right we speedrunning well, hopefully we can do it in the mirror
I'll let you guys analyze the mask okay, so you can tell me where I go when we get to that section
I'm sure you guys will be able to tell me where I go
Raisins do have some fiber even though they're covered in chocolate
do they count
Right, I'm uh, I'm gonna be a solid few minutes because you know, I don't know about you
But when I go to the toilet, you know, you need to bake the look
Right, I'll be back as quick as I can. Please stretch. Please get some water in here
Please go toilet time if you need toilet time and please go to sleep if you need to go honk
Honk, okay, I'll be back and very shortly. Okay
So
Are you squidding me right now
What the fuck are you giving me
Oh
It's actually quite a lot
I
Imperial monarch
Logo Dogo
I'm
I know and it's your time. Yeah, I don't know where caca anon is but we're calling upon you. I've had enough
I've had enough of King Kong's finger knocking at the door then disappearing away again
I'm getting tired
Fake door
Real
Dark Glasgow castle
Glasgow DLC unlocked
No idea what this is supposed to go
Have I just
No, definitely not that way
I
Can't believe it
The bread might be a little overcooked by now. Yeah, the bread might be reekin
Perhaps the sword could reflect the black as low as low mate. I was in the middle of it. Maybe doing that
Christ
Something tells me my Scottish rage might come out
Hmm
I'm about to order take away to reward myself
I think this part of the game gets incredibly hard and like no child should be able to actually complete it as I said bye
I wouldn't work at lunch and strong he's still alive
We're gonna try and redirect him to me
Yeah, yeah, can stone pieces
Yes, order lots of takeaway right hold on
That cheeky sighting
What are we feeling feeling a burger I think I'm
Okay
My easy-peasy burger I
Have to admit my diet my diet gets terrible when I'm strumming because I don't have time to cook
So we do we do a little pickle
Burger chips what drink cooler spray? I've just made a tea though
I'm probably probably a spray to wash that
I don't know
And I'm not full health, so I can't even do the thing
Right. Yeah. Oh Dale has been made. We know wait
She got it
How do I get away with this? Oh
Geez they are not making this easy holy shit children are supposed to do this. Oh
I think the Scottish rage is gonna come out from being honest
All right
These indestructible
You want the rage to come out are you sure you want the rage to come out I don't
I
Assume it destroys my little shadows as well
I was supposed to just send it okay juice have this
Rookie that's the good news
Let's put the cape back on because we can probably negate a bit of damage just using the cape and getting away
Oh, there was that locked door back on the stairwell to the right
And it was an actual door it wasn't a tribute
Right that's to jump down which I don't want to do shadow was your money
Oh
Surprise
It's not a spin attack or maybe it's the spin twirl attack hold on. I'll be the spin twirl. Oh
Okay
What
I use the spin attack it has to be it can't be the other one
No, it's moving me about though sugar what it has to be the spin attack
Is it just like a position?
Help hold hand, please any handholders. Oh, sorry. Sorry. That was me that time
I
Has to be this right let them shoot how
And then in position
I knew it. I knew it was a spin attack has to be
I
Am just spamming so I don't take HB damage
You're done. Oh, I miss
Like thank goodness we don't need money anymore, so I'm saying I'd be raging
Wait, there's no key
I was just for money
Oh, no, we're back at the star
Oops
I'll take that fairy though
Oh
Everything's good on the hood. Oh, sorry. I'll swap them back. I'm gonna get very confused very fast
I've gone the wrong way and I'm I'm all turned around now. Sorry, let me jump past you guys
There wasn't anything back there
Or is it a hidden bomb spot probably it's always you know what it's always a hidden bomb spot was this
What are the guards nice to me all of a sudden
Ring the guards
Wasn't there not a teacher guy down here. Did he teach me something? Nope. There was definitely not a teacher guy
Hold on a minute enemy spotted
Hold on a bean basil and booze and momentum do my little elf eyes deceive me
No, they do not well, I don't actually need that but thanks
I don't need it anymore, but I do appreciate the sentiment nonetheless, and we already spoke to this person
Visitor her rear
Wait, was it you that teaches me
All right, so I can come go into the Castello anything just fine with me. Hello. Can you teach me something? Oh, you confused
What do you do?
Hold on we're doing side quests already by accident
The waterfall one right, sorry, we're gonna go do that because music lovers under waterfalls is like really important
I
Yeah, it's like a road to the rest
Sorry, hold on. I didn't even ask you if you could train me. I just got really interested in the Kinstone
Okay, I already know
You just taught me all I need to know
Right, so I'm actually gonna be a naughty Nellie and leave the castle
I know who Zelda needs help, but so is it's not my problem like that
And maybe your problem, but it's not mean right at this very moment, you know
I like how you can just straight up leave if you need to you're like, I'm sorry. I'm a bit busy at the moment
And then don't me me
Where is it? No
Hello
I have to go back to Moo Moo Ranch
The thing about her right now literally, oh, I didn't even you can get Kinstone from a tree
Oh
It's a trainer oh
It's a dojo boy the spirit in the sorter one. I'm ready to
The best swordsman I will train with me you'll discover the secret to your head and tower. So would you like to train here? Yes
Hmm now I'll teach you how to fill your split gauge faster than ever. I take visually
Training very seriously. I'll have you know spot visualize your body split and even faster
Spell lifting
Huh
Now you will fill your spirit gauge much faster. Oh, okay
Okay, um, I'm doing it. Oh
Yeah, that's bass
I'm a I'm a I'm a take
Thank you for that. Thank you. I'm a visual learner too strong. So
That might order coming in fast, so we
It's already been updated on the status
Don't mind me. I'm gonna be in the middle of the boss fight. I'll be like, no, leave out the door mate. Leave out the door. Hold on
Right, let's try to cast in
I went
way
Somewhere to the right I'm to go
And if I jump down there, yeah, so that's definitely not that way. I'll walk straight into that not gonna lie
And if I jump down there, I've already been
And this was a dead end. Is this like a vomit kind of end?
What so this as if the ball spawned back I'm sure whatever
Yeah, nice try this time
Bomb the carpet like Isaac's style
No bomb here
Like I've got enough bombs to waste. Okay, let's tell them isn't it? There's gotta be something in that wonder. That's what I thought
I've gotta go back to work. Have fun at work
Suck up the carpet
Maybe something drops in this room and we're just a step too far ahead
Because I mean
I mean I can check if there's a oh
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I knew it. I knew it couldn't have been finished
Where are we heading? I'm getting nervous. Oh, it's the
Out in nowhere
And I accidentally actually dodged that
Oh
The chair just shook move that motherfucker thing. I saw it shake
Yeah
That's just an end room
Compass I will absolutely take a compass. What did it change?
Where's the compass change tells you where there's a loot and stuff
Shawnee getting so good. Yeah
Yeah
Sorry, I'm just doing distance. I I don't want to lose my ability to do this distance attack
Because it's like helping me get past areas without taking any damage type thing and obviously if I take damage
I can longer do this move
So I'm quite appreciative of it
So
Oh he what he could do
I'm just checking
The weird corner room
Okay, just uh, just a wee weird corner room. Sorry a little gamer sense was going off, but it must have been the wind
That must have just been bad. Yeah
You funk. Thank you
I don't know can I like okay that was incredibly silly um
I
Does it take me out of the air or does the game just be like, yeah
I mean didn't take me out of the air
That's quite a facial expression want me being a goofy giver
I literally did not trust any wall right now because of that
It looks beautiful
All right, what's the dealio? I need to get to the four. Oh, I burnt myself twice. I saw it
Couldn't see it properly because of the metal grate above
Let's see how this goes
I
Wait, I get put on fire for one of my phantoms. Yeah, sorry not buying that mate
Are you doing time?
Please don't make me do this again
Oh
There you go, how do you like that? You don't
If you goober god, this map is intense. Sorry, but holy crap. We're like flying about the place. We've got bombas going on
Can I like
No, wow
They're just go for it
I can't do anything
Well, if I can't do anything, there's no point in crying about it. Let's just take the heat take the damage
I don't know what I'm supposed to do
Okay, thank you
I'll make it to this one a little to the ray
Okay, we did it. We did it. We did it. We're getting there
I like that we're one shot
Okay, this there's just two random enemies here. Oh, there's a bridge. Oh, please
I
Intrusting them now there is a building through in here. So I'll go in here
To the dead end
Uh, not really sure if I'm to do anything at all actually. I don't think so. I'm supposed to shoot in my arrows
Oh, no, no, I'm not. Okay. Well, I'm not supposed to do this section at all. Hi
Thanks, please join in. We are currently on the last dungeon bit on Zell law
Uh, I'm also getting very nervous because I'm not very good at this section. I don't recall ever
finding it easy. Um
So childhood me kind of going out the window right now
It help wise
Oh
Whoa, that's what you get for being too close. Yeah, take that stinker
Stinky McGee
Oh, is that what the problem is?
Oh, well, there's not much of a problem
You're doing great so far we're getting there. I
Whoa
This is that's not hurting them
There's two of them
Oh
This is a bit of a
Have a hand moment
Got a cheap shot and
Throw it again. How dare you
Out. Okay. Whoa. I think they hit for a whole health. That's not good for at all
Yeah, if you guys can kind of separate yourselves off so you can get a few wax in that group
Do it again throw it again
See when they come in together like that, they don't like that. That's hard to kind of
can't even reach
Can't even reach my cheeks and that other guy is now protecting him because they're now stacked up uh game dips
If you could patch that out right now. Yeah. No, no, I understand. It's a very old. Wow
They are actually whacking me for one. I do not like that
I do not like that at all
Not one itty bitty bit
Okay, okay, okay much more. Yeah. Yeah. I deserve 50 for that. I'm not gonna lie
Do you want to throw it or we're just gonna play ball for the there we go
Okay
So what is where does the red take us just for curiosity? It takes us to the start of the castle
So if we really are up Shisa Creek, then we can
You can stun them with the boomerang. Okay. I think there was two of them. I was a bit like
But we do have a check point which is huge
That's not the right way that's opened by uh, is this a wall moment?
Yeah, it's not
We have a check point. That's the main thing. That's the most important thing. Okay that we have a checkpoint
Because this game's getting scary
If the enemy through starting to thwack for one, I'm not quite confident
I
You just put a bomb on this
Oh it falls well
Oh, that's the wrong one. Sorry
Huh
So what's the bomb before
Sorry
Am I missing something I might to pick up the bomb and throw it at them without taking damage question mark
Huh oh well close enough. Um
Um
Now that we have the red portal we can go back and get heals
So it's not really a problem
Can I pick up bombs like chickens? I can't
Oh
I want to say let me cook but um, I tried to place a bomb on the thing and it never let me
Yeah, it just falls down. Can you throw one?
Can I throw a bomb from above? I think no the bomb's gonna stay up on that top level
Oh wait, can I drop a bomb and throw it? Oh for fuck's sake
Wait because they don't explode on impact
That can't be right
And I can't place one on the tail
You've got a tamer I can't tame it. I don't have tamed bombs
Maybe it's just timing on the platform like I can stand on it and it just
Like luckily I have 85 but like there's no
You know what you know what game making a they're making a mockery at me ring the guards ring the guards
The guards are to be rang
Making an absolute mockery out of me
Absolute mockery right give me these fairies right now
Nope, sorry, okay, I'll take that
That's beautiful. I'm very happy about that. Now that I know those guys heal
No, don't face that way then
Oh
Three damage bro, I even got three health right good thing. I have a shit ton of bombs though
Wait the bombs don't always necessarily work. No way. Come on. That stinks
It's a dark. No, I can't believe it
I
Wait, why are you being so difficult?
Ow, let me just kill you seriously
Seriously, let me just kill you. There's a problem
Wait, can I like throw a boomerang at space then?
No, I can't the boomerang does absolutely nothing
Is a bow and arrow do anything on the armor? Nope
Is that the best I can do literally just shield and hope I can get frickin whackin
I'm scared
Huh
Okay, there's champions in the four rooms
Oh, man, I'm gonna need to heal up for that one
Oh
No
Two in one room, where were those fairies again? Okay, they're literally right here. Thank you. I will definitely be taking the fairies
Thanks, I appreciate it
All right
If I apologize, I do apologize for any rage
Against two enemies
Well, I'm cornered right now. I'm gonna be honest. I'm cornered
Okay, these guys maybe because they swing they leave themselves open a bit more
No length the other way and now we've just lost our ability to
Uh
Fire
Hams to the best of us link. Oh, sorry. I'll put that on
Okay
that went
Strangely well all things considered
Uh, I think we're just gonna do the same tactic where we just
Do that and get the fairies out so I can shoot at least
Thank you, darling
I'm getting formed so literally guys. Why aren't you here to carry me? So what happens if I go up?
I've got like weird quest rooms to do now because they were all hiding behind doors
I
Open the door
What's in here? Oh
Well, no, I can't do my freaking laser beam
I didn't even hurt him. I hurt them all
Um
Oh, there's keys behind every boss room, okay
We need to defeat every single one
Just fine with me, I'm sure I'm sure can be a big girl
Yeah, thank god it wasn't wait
There's a platform there, right? I'm uh heal up fully because I like being able to shoot from my weasel or my
Um, sorry if it is tedious, but it's the only way I know how to play game
Oh my god, I can't believe it
A gamer that's bad at games
Saying so
I will not go kind of like so carry me home. Oh, I never sung that during the time
That would take me outside the castle, why would I want to go outside the castle at this point in time?
A shortcut
Oh wait, hold on hold on hold on
No, no, let's get this clear. No, I hate those kind of guys. I hate the ones that do the freaking
Yeah, you know what you're getting a bomb
Let's see for all change that attitude. I think okay, maybe not
Uh, maybe not maybe not hold on maybe we got a bit a bit too
over over
confident, um
honest mistake truly
Okay, he just swings and gets vulnerable, which I'm quite happy with but he does have that move which I do not like at all
Am I just let them attack?
Okay, okay, that's not bad. That's not bad. That's that's handle-able handle-able
Instant loss. No, no, no instant loss. I'm good. I promise
Fortunately, I'm not full health so I can't deal with all these
Enemies. Thank god. I've been playing Isaac
Uh, because yeah
I
Was a game wants me to have arrows curious
Oh, that's why the game wants me to have arrows. Yes, the mystery's no more
All right, get me away from that, please
Truly a mystery
I miss
Okay, we're good. We're good. We're good. We made it. We got we got what we wanted
Had to clean the cat food bowl and I'm back. What did I miss? Um
Me getting rolled, um
So I can only go this way but I can only drop down
Don't go up
Nope
Nice try nice try nice try not happening
What's upstairs
Ta-da
Came back from walking my dog. We're still in the castle
Um, I've ordered food. So I'm just waiting for it to come
And and I'm gonna refuel because I think this boss fight is gonna be there. Oh
Is
Is this just the way to teleport out with the bird if I want it
I mean
Is there a platform coming towards me maybe
I
Am I missing
This just seems like a dead end and I can't go back
I
Can go back my apologies. I can go back
Due to my foolish. Oh, of course. Ah, lovely. Thanks for respawning. Don't ever ever come back again
Let us heal with the fairies
Map check and you go bottom left and bottom right now
Oh
Maybe check the map out there. Uh, yeah, you're actually pretty valid for that
Now I'm just to pick up the chest
Yeah, I'm to go down
Oh
What's the quay expect and I'm gonna be honest bro, my foot's gonna be here soon. Please stop leave me alone
You have to understand. I'm just a hungry streamer. Okay. Ow. What a fucking wingspan on that bloody sword
Fucking
Hey
Mate
Yous are actually too OP. I'm not being funny, but you guys are actually a bit too OP
Like I'm completely out of my depth against you two right now and you're both are doing different directions
Oh, come on
No, okay, hold on. This is going terrible. I'm gonna be honest
Am I not just gonna say yeah, okay, we're just gonna fuck out of themselves
Okay, okay, that's much more manageable one is much more manageable than two and absolutely no one is
Much more manageable, okay
Because of 1v1 this is fair. I'm literally a 12 year old boy and you're some sort of demon like this is getting a bit weird
Honestly, why do you want a 12 year old boy in a room with you?
Oh
Yeah, yeah, that's what
That's right cry to your mama
What are we eating today, um
Burger oh, that's the reason oh no logic puzzle
Okay, sorry, I'd sorry if my model tracking so I had to put my hand over my mouth to try hard so much for that
Hey, I hurt one ghost in the rest or like I'm out I ain't doing this
Okay
I
Got the worst makes considerable time on sorry as if you just did that you weren't even aiming at me
Yeah, we're here
Again just an outside of a castle curious curious. Let's go up to the treasure
Yeah, there you go
steakhouse burger
Where am I with the steakhouse burger?
I got a breakfast burger I got bacon on it
Uh a restock room wow, they're actually being nice how much all right
I'm gonna go get some more bombs because the bombs are the only way I'm winning
So I'm just gonna keep restocking. Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute games actually being kind
Oh no logic puzzles proceeded to do it in three seconds
The only reason I know how to do those kind of puzzles is because of pokemon ruby
There is an ace tape gem where you had to do something like that
and
And it took me so long to learn as a child one earth I was supposed to do
Oh, is there a heart in here? Oh, there's lovely lovely jubbly don't have to put the theme
Shawnee can I have some of your bacon you can?
Great, okay, this is one be one the way I like or is this a drill guy? I'm getting nervous. Oh it is as well
I don't know. I kind of want him to drill because I can just shoot from oh well if I don't mess up my shot shoot
Okay, well that ability is gone just like that
Oh
My god, that was clean that was clean mr.
What's the job a four-way
I have no idea how I'm supposed to serve this room
So you think I'm skinny
Hold on oh that works no way
Oh
Shadow was really good you can cast spells somewhere else me
Great up top to get the goose
She's getting too good at this that was incredibly lucky because of his attack pattern could have been different
We now have four keys. Where do we took the keys? I don't know
Are you gonna do a pokemon stream?
Let's see tomorrow the heart's covering up your message again. Is this just
Absolutely no comment
No comment whatsoever. I'm gonna go get a fairy
Hey, are you gonna do a pokemon streams too strong? Yes. Okay. I'm eating. I'm sorry. The heart was in the way
I keep forgetting to move the heart of the way
No that way
Uh, yes, I will most likely do pokemons
Um
Pokemon
Where's the fairy room? I think it's back up here
So I don't want to waste my heals just because of the dire situation
We're gonna be in when we actually go against the boss
I would much rather throw my bimmering at this thing over and over again
Uh
We'll do pokemon three four and five, which is pokemon
emerald
pear
Diamond and white are the generations i'm familiar with
There's something ahead that I couldn't get access to
Oh, it's literally what four the keys were four my bad
Yeah, they don't need jumping maybe helping
Which one's your favorite pokemon but my first one was three
So it has like a special place. Oh, no, we have the boss door key
Where's the boss up here on floor three
How do I get there?
The door it's upstairs. Oh, I just need to go around an alpha thing
Do apologize for my
Which starter
Oh, no tar chick
And tar chick was so OP. Oh as soon as tar chick turns into blaziken, bro. You're OP as any of him
Oh, no, I don't know if I want to go in. I'm gonna have to pause if my delivery comes
Oh
Yeah
Wait, hold on. Let me check my phone. Oh, yeah. No, sorry. Let me check and get my food and refuel. I'm sorry
I've just seen this for no, sorry. I'm turning back. I'm scared
I'm scared. Oh, I forgot I had a cup of tea
Oh my god, it's cold. Oh well my delivery's here right hold on hold on
Hold on give me a minute. Oh
I'll be a second. I'll be a second. I'm gonna refuel. I'm gonna get food in me before I do this boss fight
Because I know this is gonna be angry scottish mode. I can already tell
So
I hate my delivery guy went off of my can of spray
Well, I hope you enjoyed it because I have cola in the fridge that was lucky. I'm not region
Um
I've got my burger and it's absolutely outrageously large. I'll see one thing about Australia
You guys do not mess around for your food portion sizes
You're starting to get a bit um American
Hey, I don't know. I think he may have accidentally forgot to give it to me, which is fine. It's not it's literally can of spray
She will port it now. I'm sure he just left it in the car. I rolled out. It's fine
Oh my god, the chips are cheesy and they're so good. We fun. You need to take a bite. It's so good
I'm most laid-back customer in the world probably because I was a waitress and like I mean I fucked up. It's just happened
um
You know, I've never had anyone be I'm gonna report you to your boss or whatever
Meanwhile, my boss is literally always on my side
Chips like chips
Like chips like I'm made of a potato and deep-fried
But cheese
And
My place doesn't get scotland getting americanized. Do you guys ever watch beard meets food?
It's this guy that eats like a stupid amount of food and he travels to america to make his content
Because america has such large portions that are like good for sensationalizing in his videos
He's like I'm going to america again
I'm going to america again. I'm doing a tour of america
We do big, uh, literally the girls were telling me about american food and all the places they take me to and I'm like, oh, please kidnap me
I'm like such a fat bastard. I love food
Um, it would be nice to pick out on american food
Hmm and like
I I think the mexican food would be better in america because you'll never guess what's next to america. Mexico crazy. I know right?
um
and uh
But apparently street vendors are like a lot more popular
And I love me some I think they're called dirty tackles if they're from a street vendor and I'm like fuck. Yeah
That's like my kind of food
American mexicans actually pretty bad. Oh, no
Oh, no, only the mexican food is good in Mexico. No
I thought because it's literally land connected
Yeah, be good. They are like a taco truck. I'd absolutely die for a taco truck
Um, there's like no street vendors
Are hardly any
Sorry, I'm just choking on a chip there. Excuse me. This is what happens
If you're talking in stream at the same time eating stream at the same time
Um, I'm okay. I'm okay. I'm okay. Don't worry. Um
The the only like british takeaway pop-up shop
I can think of is a fucking potato a baked potato van thing
It got really popular on tiktok and it was like the british
Like takeaway thing truck is a freaking baked potato stand, which is hilarious
Well
If you're east of mississippi, you can forget about authentic mexican food. No
They put beans on the baked beans and potato and baked potatoes absolutely delicious
Right, let's take a break of this
Bait of this breakfast burger. Um, it's got an egg on it baking on it hash brown on it. Oh
Delicious not nutritious, but delicious. I'm gonna need this for a the boss fight. We're about to do
American mexican each
It's
Jacket potatoes. Oh, we can't be potatoes. You come jacket potatoes because they're in a jacket. Yeah
Oh my god, the egg is running
I know
Oh, no, this can't be I don't think I like it that much but the chips were delicious though
Oh
They put something funny tasting in it. I didn't care what it is
What's that flavor I have no idea
I'm like continue to eat it anyway because I'm a fat bastard but I have no clue what it is
I
Didn't can as din and why a dinny I don't
Being 14 I 14 hours behind the streamers while what?
I
Sorry being fat as well
I'm definitely gonna do an eating. Oh, what the fuck is that?
It's great. Oh my god. They put like avocado
On the top of the burger. No wonder. Oh my god. It's a breakfast burger because it's fucking astralian
They've put smashed avocado on the top of it. No wonder that was tasting weird. I'm like, where's my fucking
I've just noticed I'm eating something green
Green
There's your Mexican food
No, I do like avocado, but this is like
On a savory burger and the avocado is like a whole different like palate
Mm-hmm that makes sense. I was like, what the fuck am I tasting?
I like the way she says avocado. What? How'd you say it? Avocado? Avocado?
I hate surprise avocado. I didn't realize it came on the burger
Yeah, they could go a bit confused literally supposed to be a savory break breakfast burger
Oh, I will say, you know the memes about Australians going nuts for avocado toast. It's kind of true. I'm sorry. It's kind of true
You say it normally
Free shavakado
Avocado
Shivakado
It sounds like a spell
It sounds like a spelled way. I say avocado
Avocado! Oh, no, it does actually sound like a spell
Take that Voldemort avocado
I'm awful
Oh, it's ruining the fucking flavor
Avocado cadavro
I cast avocado
Right, I'm gonna have to take off the top bun that has all the fucking
Green on it. I'm eating now the top of the burger
All right, yeah, that's so much better
Oh my god
Look, I don't know about you
But the most pleasurable
Non-sexual thing you can do is fucking eat a greasy ass burger when you're hungry
And appreciate the flavors that are swimming in your mouth, okay?
Is that like come on
You know and what other what other pleasures of the flesh that are not factual in nature
The sensation of falling asleep on a warm bed
When you know you have absolutely nothing to wake up to you don't have to go anywhere the next day you can rot and bed the next day
Hmm a burger releases a hundred units of dopamine which is close to an inking fest
Um
The flavor swing
Oh my bacon
Okay, I think I'm gonna have to wash my hands unfortunately because it's so greedy
That is gonna fuel me for this fight that's ahead
No, that was good. I took the
The green shite away get that green get that healthy green shite out my fucking burger and chips
Hmm
No, it's like grease is not like flavor on my fingers. It's just very grease
Grease a lightning
You don't like when it gets messy
Okay, give me one second the bathroom's literally just right there. So
I'll be back in a moment second
You
Okay, my belly is full of meat
I have my reeflings to support me through this game
I just want to warn anyone that mere season 10 minutes probably and even the box fight god damn
I was gone for so long. Let me you don't have to make it up to me
Okay
What
Whoa, here has a screensaver mode. I'm a cut off is my hypnosis. You're not to attack me when I'm asleep. Okay
Architects
Calling all
Let's get this. Oh, thank god. I walked out. Holy crap. You are persistent, aren't you? I am
He he he he
So you've come to stop my little ceremony while you're too late
A mere three more times of the bell will bring the ceremony to its end
And with the third toll of the bell, I will become like a god
And your precious princess Zelda will be nothing more than a cold
dead stone
There's no time quickly link to the ring
To the roof to the roof. I don't have time for your games
Did you hear that link hurry? There's only two times left. Wait. Am I actually being timed or am I being trolled?
Am I being timed like I'm actually being timed hold on someone look it up. Am I being timed?
Holy shit, right fuck it just do the swords and slash them
Holy shit
Get out the way get out the way. No, you don't need to pick up the freaking Kenstone piece. Holy shit. We're in a timer, bro
Oh god
Another bell is no no and right. It's a progression. It's a progress
It's fine
Oh
Doesn't matter who I hit doesn't matter if I'm wasting bombs as long as I'm hitting someone bro as long as I'm hitting someone
Doesn't matter doesn't matter honestly doesn't matter. I have fairies as well. I have fairies as well. Don't worry. I have fairies. I have time. I have time
As soon as one goes down everything becomes 10 times easier. That's it. That's the truth as soon as one goes down
One down. That's it. See
All right, I'm gonna need to
Okay, see
That's fine. That's fine. Not problem. I wouldn't mind that. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Uh, sorry. I know I'm gonna I'm gonna fight with you and all that
but
Okay, he recovers far too quickly. So we're gonna just have to go for the old uh whack him
Like that. Yeah, oh that's so good
Whoa, this guy's fast. He's like really he's hardly given me a chance to breathe
Okay, okay, let's go. Can I get hearts? Yes, absolutely would love some hearts
I would love to have
Fucking thingy, but it's fine. Doesn't matter. All right. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go
Oh, this looks like a boss fight if I've ever seen one. Hold on. I need to roll my shoulders for this
You're welcome to roll your shoulders with me
Oh, I'm taking a drink of cola. I'm feeling nervous
Just a few more moments in the ceremony would have been complete
You really are obsessed with stopping me, aren't you?
Very well. I have not yet drained all of the light force housed in princess Zelda
But what I should have should suffice. I shall be transformed unstoppable
But let me first attend to the pesky worms who would trifle with me
Well, if I'm a worm, you're about to get wrecked by me
By a wiggly worm
I'm in the glory hole. No, what? I just finished the fight
Huh
I will have no more of your interfering with my plans. Let me show you my true power
Monkaos is a boss fight in this tiny-ass room. Am I about to fight a master bath boss in a tiny-ass room?
What the hell even is that?
Um, um
Um, um, um suck them suck them
I'm sucking. I'm sucking. I'm sucking
Um, what am I to do? Am I to throw boomerangs?
Nope, not boomerangs. Oh, right. Just twat them. Just twat them. It's fine. Just twat them when they go around the room
Okay, that's fine. Not interested. Not interested. Not interested
Okay, just twat it. I take that. Yeah, you like that right and then what looks like her eyeball is open. He his eyeball. Sorry
Let's not make gender in this day and age
Okay, that did something. I don't know what something's happening. I can hardly see I need to get close to see what the fuck
I'm supposed to be hitting. Where's the other one?
Take that. Yeah. Yeah, you're quivering. Your little boots are shaking. Yeah, take that. Oh
What are you gonna do? Huh? You're gonna respond some more for me? Yeah. Yeah
Oh, you don't like it. Oh, oh your little eyeball doesn't like it. You're too you're quaking
I'm fucking scared. I'm not gonna lie. Uh, am I doing this right? I don't think I'm doing this right
Oh, I can I can hit it. I can hit it. Okay. Is your problem? I can actually hit it for damage
Okay, okay. We're we've got four balls now. We've got four balls. That's an upgrade. That's an upgrade. That's an upgrade
That's a difference. We're sniping it. Could you imagine if I hit that?
Okay, okay, sorry, uh, let me just grab. Oh, no. Okay, great. That was ahead
I'm a fucking oh
I'm a firing the laser. That's fine. You're allowed to do that. It's fine. You're allowed to have a laser beam
Like I have a I have a few items that you don't have so it's fine
Whoa, where did it go? Don't do that
Don't do that. Don't do that
Don't do that. That's so nice
Okay, okay, get twired get twired get twired get twired. Oh
Okay
Okay, take it easy
No, it's fine. Take it get twired get twired. Nope miss. It's fine. I'm allowed to miss
Oh, I get to that
Oh, no
No, just quaking in your little boots
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa Danny suck those away. I do not like to look those
I do. Oh my god. They have a fucking invincibility slope right spin right now so I can get the other two, right?
That's fine. That's fine. I can tolerate that
Okay, I can't tolerate that though. That's HP damage again with the damage again with the damage
So much so unkind so unruly
Again, I can't be making mistakes like this. I do have three fairies, but I cannot be making damage mistakes like that
Oh lovely. I can't even reach you
That's fine. I didn't want to reach you anywhere
Come here. Oh not again
Okay, that's fine
Link, I know your arse is on fire and it hurts so badly, but I'm gonna have to ask you to please stop taking damage
Darlin link. We're trying to save Zelda and I do not I
I do not have infinity. Oh my god. There was a fairy in the jar
We love fairy we love
Okay, perfect
I was gonna say let's not get hit by the fire
I have to deal with that, but I don't have a choice. Miss. That's fine
I just couldn't even get hit in
Okay, hold on. No, we didn't get it. Oh piss
Well, you seem to have some fight in you. I commend your bravery, but you will not survive this
Oh
God girl, I'm filled with the power. Okay, hold on hydration check
I'm filled with the power that you cannot begin to understand. Do you think that puny sword will save you from me?
Um no is my answer
Uh
No, I do not think the puny sword will save me but
Does it mean I'm not that I suck them up
I don't suck them up
Oh
I can't do any oh I can
They're cobble wobbles. They're cobwebs. It's fine. They're cobwebs
I can deal with cobwebs
All right, let's just spin. Let's just clear up the map. Let's just clear up the map so we don't really have any issues
What's the dealio? What's the plan? What's the deal? What's the plan? I don't know
I clearly have to make their eye shape, but you're not transforming for me big batty
But electroshock that's fine
Again
I mean, I'll clean them up
Can I get help from these as well? Possibly. Am I to shoot it in the eyeball?
Must be because you're not doing anything about it. Like you're honestly just kiss arse about no you are
I
That's it. That's my window of opportunity
Oh
Is this a joke or
Lovely no do that again
I think I'm getting trolled I can't tell
I mean, it's red
Is it is it narrow? Nope. I'm looking short
I'm looking short for that
I might have to reach out, give me
Hmm I think I'm missing something
Shoot at the ball feigned all the eyes it flashes for a frame when you hit it. I think
Shooting the closed eyes opens them reveal which eye
Oh
Oh wasted all that time my apologies my apologies. Sorry. I don't need to waste your time
Okay, we understand we understand
So a few mechanics to learn that's
Right, okay, we understand we have to hit all four. That's perfectly fine, right?
Can we do it in time?
Oh, we absolutely can ladies and gentlemen
Okay, okay, okay, that's perfectly fine that makes sense why they keep spawning
No, it's four bottom again. That's perfectly fine. Okay. Thank you. Sorry for your patience. Thank you for your patience. Sorry for um
Uh taking my time. Uh, it's sorry. I said that the wrong word, you know
Okay, absolutely absolutely loving it. Okay. We're on fire. We're cooking by gas
We are gonna have to clear up this map over. Oh, that was unfortunate unfortunate hit did not mean that uh, very unfortunate
Uh, right. I can see what one we're supposed to hit next
Oh, oh dear unfortunately, um, I'm just gonna clear the map if
Because it's getting a bit crowded and that is currently stuck to the right side and I actually need to shoot something on the right side
All right, there we go
There we go. There we go. Okay
All right, sweet. Oh, I can't
Do it if you're doing your electoral shot
Okay
Take your time. Take your time. Take it easy. Take it easy. Right. Same thing again. Cancel shoot. Uh red. We've got red
We've got red. We've got red. Yeah, I love this
Um, I'm not
Moving fast now. I think we're in us. We're in a phase. We must be in a further phase
Because that's outrageous as fast
But lovely. Um, not really looking for that please don't do that again question mark
What are we doing? What are we looking at?
Not that side top maybe no bottom. Yeah. No. Wow all right side. Okay. We can handle that
Yeah, that is moving so fast now like so fast. Sorry. I'm gonna have to clear this up a bit
Just doing a bit of spring cleaning than you might need me to get spring cleaning
Most we're just uh getting me that ideal
I'm missing
I am missing like nothing on air. I'm fully moley. Holy moley
Wow, I actually just took a bit of a hammering. I'm tempted to try a fairy
I am very tempted to try a fairy. Thank you very much. Love you. Please come all the time. Um to me
Because that was very cringey
Um
Mate
I really don't want vati to be on that side of me when I spawn. Yes. That's what I did
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa
What what is this madness? I have the power of a god. I haven't stoppable mate. How can I lose to a literal child?
There you go. Let's not be a just out here. Okay, children have a lot of potential
We did it. Wait, did we actually do it? You did it impressive. Now quickly. We must break the curse on zelda
I'm is that actually done or is there more because I'm scared. There's like a secret boss
Hi, so like this is use it on zelda. Absolutely
Oh
I lost her baby
Princess
It looks like the curse has been broken. I'm glad we made it in time
No, the castle's collapsing. It's too dangerous here quickly. We must escape from the castle
Oh my god, I think we actually did do it. Wait for real for real. We did it first try
Hmm. The door is blocked. We have no choice head back to the sanctuary
What is the sanctuary? Is it to the right? No, sorry. Uh, yeah, yeah sanctuary sanctuary. Yes
I know where the sanctuary is. Do excuse me. Yes. Uh, follow me princess to the sanctuary. I know exactly
Okay, uh
Come with me princess to the sanctuary
Ah, not that way
Ah the sanctuary
Oh my god, princess come come come
safe safe safe. Oh god, there is another fight. I knew it. I fucking knew there was another fight
You will not escape boy
No, you will see the true power of the light force for I have become batty the master of this world
I knew it
I knew it. That was I I succeeded too well
I succeeded too well. Holy shit. I succeeded too well
I succeeded too well
What the fubber knock is this?
Um
What is this I don't know
I don't know. I can become a minish
Which is fine
Well, I'm cornered now, aren't I? Oh, well, you know what I give up. You can have her
Nope, not that definitely not that. Um
What the fuck am I supposed to do to help? What do I do? What do I do? I don't know what to do
Suffering from she kicked too hard. What a kill boss. He's got arms, but I did oh
The cane the cane of course the cane man. I knew that. Thank you out
No
I think cane when he does that arm thing
This nope miss missed again missed again
Become a minish and go inside. I think there's a go inside moment to
What
I'm to destroy them all
No, one is not like the others this one's not like the others
You look different you must perish
Okay, get out get out so we don't get hurt did that destroy the arm it did it did it did right?
I have two fairies. I'm a bit nervous not gonna lie. I am very low
Oh fuck off with the fucking like this tick health taking not good
Oh god, can I do it?
I rolled over dear dear little long. I know you're a young child. Oh lord. I can't see a dying thing
Where's the one that doesn't look like him? You
Sometimes
sometimes
Oh, that was so lucky. I came across that like instantly
Oh god, what now?
Don't whack them all. I'm I'm sorry. I think I'm gonna have to dump the fairy
Oh, if we're gonna stick with even have full health for the last one though
Even if I use the last fairy
Is it triple time? I think I'm gonna be triple time
Oh my god, it's a deflect. It's a deflect. I can see it. I can see the attack pattern. It's a deflect
Oh lord
It's a deflect. It's a deflect. It's a deflect. Nope. Not if you're gonna do that
Not if you're gonna do that yet. That was so unlucky
Because of that attack phase. I couldn't do it
Again with this attack
Oh, I cannot press that button any harder if I tried
I don't I don't know what to do
Okay, that's fine
Oh, why why why I'm point blank, you know, I'm point blank. You're a wee liar
I'm out of time
Oh, you fucking pisser
Absolute shit for brains who knew exactly what I'm not I can't do it because I'm gonna get hit by that electrode
I didn't even call it a boss battle for nothing
Oh no, I'm not ready
But I don't have to be
I don't have to be first try
Fool but I the light forced my power. I had such power
Did we do it first try?
Actual gg or real gg like real gg
Real gg the hat has returned real gg real gg
Real gg
Link thank goodness you're safe
You defeated body. You're so brave, but we've lost so much the castle all those people
Not any worry about it. No, I try my best any worry about it
Ah
What's this the curse defeating batty seems to have broken the curse he cast upon me
Allow me to introduce myself to you princess Zelda. My name is Ezwo master of minish lore and sorcery
The mages cap was my creation, but it's limitless power has caused nothing but trouble for your kind
Is there any way that you can forgive me?
I know many have fallen and much of the castle has been destroyed
But it is too soon to give in to despair
The curse on me is broken and Zelda still possesses some of the light force
Perhaps together we can do something to make things right
Focus focus through that piece on your focus
If one sorry if one wears
If one with a just heart wears this cap things can be made right again
Princess Zelda let your wishes be made real
I was gonna say focus focus through the pizza on your princess
I wish to restore oh life as it once was
Oh no troublemakers on the road
I'll have peaceful
And always restored in the world
Look the castle all the people who had been turned to stone. They're all back to normal
The hat it's fallen apart. It's overflowing with the power of life
The hat has the power to turn the thoughts of its wearer into reality
Vati's heart was filled with evil and that was reflected in what he became
But it seems that Zelda's pure heart coupled with the hat's power has created a miracle
Oh
The portal is closing
Hmm. It looks like the time for us to part has come
The mini store opens but once every century and soon it must close
I must leave you both now and return to my homeland
I know I have caused you much suffering
But the evil one's power has withered
The power of princess Zelda herself has restored the light to Hyrule
Well Link my journey with you has been exciting to say the least
In fact, I'm more than just a little sad that we most part ways now
Please accept this
Oh, but it's not as low
You know, I've never actually seen you wear in a cap until now. It suits you little hero. Take care
Bye
Thank you for the advice. Oh god. You're so tiny. Please be careful. I thought
Bye buddy
Farewell farewell my friend
That's crazy small
There he is a proud boy link we did it
We did it
He's
Yeah, I don't know how big this team was but Matt hats off to this team
The only thing they messed up on was in my opinion
Was
The ending should remain
But I'm gonna show you something if I put up the game again. He's so small. He's five two. Whoa. Is there anyone?
And now we only have 40 more games left in the timeline. Wait, there's 40 installments of Zelda. No way
That's off. Yeah, okay. Actually, I didn't mean that hats off to the development team
Sad thing, yes
Broly legend
You did amazing
Thank you. Love you. Love you. Timmy's playing
Is it like 15 mainline games? I did not know there was that many installments
I know ocarina of time is rated very highly I believe. Oh my god. That's what they look like
They have like a little feather tail. Oh my god gen two. What the fuck they're called picori gen two confirmed
Little red and green inspiration little gold
I'm here for a little adorable tail just yonking it straight from your nintendo. Thanks. I don't even have to think
Hmm
I can't believe I didn't mess that up. I thought I was gonna be in for a rage fest like replaying over and over again
Oh, that's what that looks like sauce, but that looks like a chick. I'm sorry. That's like an emo chick
But a gen two confirmed
Original Zelda staff. Oh, this is a special thank you to the original
Management nose take product management
Are you shouting at? Oh my god. Link's taking it on the chin as Eslo shouts at him. That's adorable
Link, what did you think doing making us jump in that whirlwind?
Oh my god, that's such a cool friggin art that puts it into perspective how absolutely terrifying it is to be a picori
Gender bent batty confirmed into
Oh my god, that's such cool artwork. Oh
And here we are with all our elements
Dusted links quest come to an end
But surely this is not the end of Zelda and Link's adventures in Hyrule
The legend will continue
As long as the power of light force echoes throughout the ages
Oh, there's a wee picori bottom right if you see him next to the fire element
Hold on as we clover
All right, ah fuck off
And then get bent
Oh my god save absolutely save because that was a lot of progress not to save please save
What this is a real what are you talking about this is a game boy van
So this is the only what it's a real game boy van
This is my only thing
Wait, I have a triangle on my name. Why do I have triangle?
Yeah, this is the only thing if you complete the game but come back everything is still wrong
It's like it's as if you didn't do it
Which is such a shame. It means you won. Imagine the game Christianina. Yeah, like I
Now don't get me wrong for the explore. I don't I don't even know how I got there
For the exploring side of things I completely get leaving the monsters in the game
But I don't like it
The post game could have
Could have been much better in my opinion the post game should be the kingdom is restored
And you know make up some plot line where like oh linky need to you know get rid of the stragglers type thing
And maybe like kill all the monsters in the world and they perma stay away
um
It's too dangerous go home. Yeah, like everything's shut down
No, that's why we like did all that exploring
Um before because like everything gets all changed like the world is now permanently changed. We can't get to like pre
this
I think
Breath of the wind and thingy did that. I could be remembering what wrong
Yeah post games elder could be fun, but they've just never done it like don't get me wrong
If the development team like it a certain way they like it a certain way. That's fine
um
But I have to admit for a player that especially is enthralled with a zelda series like this could have been
This could have been a lot more fun
Um a legend of zelda god that postman did that leap even I can't leap hold on
How do you even I can?
um, but yeah, there's like
The only thing now really is we could just do code stone trading
and
Kinstone, but
You know is what it is
Closest you get is a password in the oracle game for the other game that implies you saved
the other land first
Um
But yeah, like it's just such a shame like how it all is as a mayor here
Monsters are coming everyone's standers. Oh that doesn't apply to you my boy link go get them
You're your sword and braver. You'll save the day
Um, yeah, it's such a shame because I think the post game could have been a lot more pretty like especially this in the situation
Being all alone is uh, well lonely. I'm going to find myself a nice home too
Um
There's extra dungeon bosses
Hey, wait, wait, wait for me. Um, but yeah, unfortunately, this is where it's like, uh, I really wish they didn't do that
And but it's the development team's choice, but for me as a player
Hi there, welcome. Sure. I'll take a rest. Um
Wait, I'll take the 200 room, please and three girls to come in that'd be great. Thanks. Enjoy your stay
Oh wait, we actually just straight up like stayed in a hotel
Oh
Well, yeah, I think we did it right. We should probably uh redirect into mercy. Hold on a minute
We should uh redirect into mercy because uh, there's nothing else I can do
Now I can get 100 but I honestly don't know what I'm missing and uh, we'd be at it for quite a while
And I'm not really fussed for it because I have kind of corrupted the fail
I've not corrupted it, but
The fail is now stuck in this like things are blocked off everyone go home dialogue
Which isn't that fun whereas like when you start the game everyone's like welcome to town
Town love all that jazz
But now it's like I'm messed up
You know what we'll go home and we'll see grandpa
Oh wait, he doesn't know that we've defeated fatty. Oh, no one knows we've defeated fatty. We can't even tell him
Oh
Oh, well
I'm so good. Yeah, it's just the same dialogue. Which is a shame that fail should have been us three girls come with a 400 room
I got 400
and but yeah
It's slow is on our head again type thing because we haven't done it
It's just a complete time loop. Which is such a shame. I I definitely think it could have been
A very adorable game if they did it right, I will make sure we're redirecting into mercy
Should I pick any kind of support?
Oh, she's playing death mark
What what's the what's the question she says the title of the stream is do you have the red stuff?
What's the red stuff the blue you got the blue?
I
Right, I'm gonna see if I can put me clapping a some more up
I'm probably not gonna do it right now because I think it's a bad time to do it
Where is my mercy?
See
redirecting to mercy
But we did it. Thank you so so much for letting me turn a four hour stream into
Nine and a half hours. Wow. Holy crap. It took me that long to piss off about
How did I do that? Honestly, I freaking I just I'll just stream for a wee bit
um tomorrow's streaming experience is
Only a few hours of old-school runescape. I'm gonna go hard on the wine because I have my first collab with none other
The mercy modis
We're gonna play hong kong gifts game
And we're gonna see what an earth goes on. Wow. We really endurance that I didn't even mean to like it was just like a little
Oopsie. Whoopsie
Thank you for showing us the minish cap. Oh, I'm so glad you could enjoy it for the first time if you've never seen it before
It's just a cute little pixel game
I think it's a very sweet game. Definitely if they had post games, I feel more fun
But that's just me. Thank you so so much my little reeflings
Um, I'll go talk in mercy stream for a wee bit because I don't know what on earth what kind of game she's playing
But might as well watch it wee bit might as well watch it a wee bit
um
But thank you so so much billet reeflings. I'm so sorry to endurance you again and again night after night day after day
I just can't help it. Okay. I need a lot of you
And and I'll get a lot of you one way or another. Okay
Right. Thank you so so much. I love you
Please look after yourself and get a good stretch and a good water and a good sleeping because that was a
A longer stream yet. It was a long stream
Okay, we will redirect successfully into none other than mercy modis and we will be nice
And we will be respectful because remember I'm a fiend for the ink, but you know, you got everyone has their different licks
Okay, and mercy now might not be at the same lick as me. Okay
All right. Thank you so so much. I'll see you tomorrow on rinse cable cable